GOOD MORNING. OKAY RIGHT
THANK THANK YOU GOOD MORNING-
I'M CALLING THIS HEARING TO
ORDER WHEN I THINK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY FOR ATIMELY
DISCUSSION ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADVERSITY BOTH ON CORPORATE
BOARDS AND DOWN THE LADDER FOR
ALL EMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
MY CULTURE MR HOLDEN AND I WERE
BOTH EXCITED TO SEE SB EIGHT TO
SIX BY. FORMER SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN REQUIRE WOMEN BE
APPOINTED TO CALIFORNIA BASED
CORPORATE BOARDS. THAT'S WHY IN
TWENTY TWENTY MR HOLDEN TOOK
THE LEAD ON AB NINE SEVEN NINE
OUR BILL TO SET A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF BOARD MEMBERS. TO BE
FROM AN UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
REASONS BEHIND AB NINE SEVEN
NINE THIS SOUND CITIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT CORPORATIONS WITH A
MORE DIVERSE AND EQUITABLE
BOARD HAVE BETTER COMPANY
GOVERNANCE AND HAVE BETTER
DECISION MAKING. WILL BE WHICH
LEADS TO A MORE SUCCESSFUL
COMPANY. EVERY CITY IN EQUITY
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE HEALTH OF
THE COMPANY WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THIS EXPERIENCE RACISM. MICRO
GEISHA AGGRESSIONS ON A DAILY
BASIS. CALIFORNIA'S UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS. OKAY.
CALIFORNIA'S UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS SERVICE SEAT AT THE
TABLE TO WHAT THESE BILLS HAVE
BEEN LAW FOR OVER A YEAR NOW
AND THE INTENTION FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY'S UPDATE US ON
THE STATUS OF IMPLEMENTATION
I'M PREVIOUS EVER SEE
LEGISLATION AND ALSO CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSION ON THE VERSA
FIND THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS FURTHER. BEFORE I HAND
THIS OFF TO MY CULTURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN TO INTRODUCE SOME
OF THE EARLY EVIDENCE OF THE
BILL SYNTAX. I DO WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE HASHTAGS THAT
WE WILL BE USING ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. A. B. R. HAS TIED AB
NINE SEVEN NINE. HI SIDE
CORPORATE THEIR CORPSE EVERY
CITY. AND HASH TAG OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL TO HELP TRACK THE
DISCUSSION ON SOCIAL MEDIA- I
WANNA ALSO WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE TODAY
AND WE WILL DO A LITTLE MORE
INTRODUCTIONS. AFTER THE
OPENINGS ON ON THAT AND-
FINALLY I WANT TO SAY THAT WHEN
WE DID AB NINE SEVEN NIGHT WELL
IT WAS A LANDMARK LEGISLATION
MR HOLDEN AND I WERE WELL AWARE
THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE AND WE HOPE THROUGH THESE
HEARINGS THAT ARE STARTING TO
DAY. WE WILL BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE WE'RE AT AND WHERE WE
NEED TO BE GOING IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE- UP
WORKFORCE THAT LOOKS MORE LIKE
OUR SOCIETY OUT THERE SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE. AND PASS IT
OVER TO MR HOLDEN. THANK YOU AS
A MEMBER GARCIA. AND THANK YOU
TO ALL OF OUR- PANELISTS WHO
WILL BE JOINING US- THIS LATE
MORNING AND- BEING A PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION I
WANT TO INTRODUCE AB NINE
SEVENTY NINE MY GOAL WAS TO
START A CONVERSATION ABOUT
DIVERSITY AND CREATE. A MATRIX
THAT SETS A FLOOR FOR DIVERSITY
NOT A CEILING. OUR EFFORTS
THROUGH AB NINE SEVEN NINE AND
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL TO
SUPPORTING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION POLICIES ON A
NATIONAL SCALE. AB NINE SEVEN
NINE SERVED AS A CALL TO ACTION
FOR BUSINESSES TO TAKE
MEASURABLE ACTION IN LIGHT OF
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR FACE BARRIERS TO GETTING
HIRED. FACE HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENTS AND MICRO
AGGRESSIONS ONCE HIRED
OBSTACLES TO GETTING PROMOTED.
AND ARE NOT ABLE TO CLIMB UP
THE LADDER OF SUCCESS. IN
ADDITION TO THE ATTENTION THAT
BOTH OF THESE LAWS HAVE
ATTRACTED. COMPANIES ARE TAKING
INTENTIONAL STEPS TOWARDS
CREATING SUPPORTIVE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN AND THE LGBT
COMMUNITY. EARLIER THIS YEAR I
ATTENDED EVENTS HOSTED BY THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP. AFRICAN AMERICAN BOARD
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE HOW WOMEN
LEAD AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
DIVERSITY SUMMIT TO PROVIDE
CLARITY ON THE INTENT OF AB
NINE SEVENTY NINE. FROM THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND EARNEST
DISCUSSIONS. WE'RE SEEING
MEASURABLE RESULTS. AFTER S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX BECAME LAW.
THIS FIRST IN THE NATION LAW
INSPIRED OTHER LOS TO FOLLOW
SUIT AND THE NUMBER OF WOMEN ON
BOARDS INCREASE SIGNIFICANTLY.
BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESS OF S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX AB NINE
SEVENTY NINE ALSO INSPIRED
CHANGE ACROSS THE NATION. IN
THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE NASDAQ SUCCESSFULLY
CHANGED ITS RULES TO REQUIRE
ITS MEMBER COMPANIES TO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE WOMAN OR PERSON OF
COLOR ON THEIR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. BOTH OUR OUR OFFICES
WORK TOGETHER LETTERS AND
SIGNATURES TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT. AND THIS HEARING WE
WILL CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
INCLUSIVE WORK ENVIRONMENTS AND
HIGHLIGHT THE VERY REAL IMPACTS
OF DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
POLICIES HAS ON PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES. WE WILL HEAR FROM
MANY EXPERTS IN THIS FIELD AND
HOPE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO HELP
EFFORTS AT IMPLEMENTING CURRENT
LAW AND CREATING NEW LAWS TO
ASSIST AND DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION POLICIES AT ALL
LEVELS. OF EMPLOYMENT. NOW FOR
A FEW REMINDERS BEFORE WE START
TODAY'S HEARING- MASS OR
REQUIRES SUCH A WITH LIKE UP
STOP WILL SHOP START STOP REAL
QUICK ON THE ON THE GOOD STUFF
AND THEN WE'LL GET TO THIS
TECHNICAL STUFF. OUR MASTER
REQUIRED IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND OTHER COMMON ERRORS
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON AND BY TELEPHONE. THE
NUMBER PUBLIC PHONE TESTIMONY
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. THIS NUMBER
IS POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ALSO APPEARS ON THE
VIDEO FEED ONCE WE HAVE
CONCLUDED ALL PANELS WE WILL
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
TWO PM BUT WITH EFFICIENCIES OF
I'M SURE THIS MEETING WILL
PROCEED- WE COULD CONCLUDE
SOONER THAN THAT. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE ANY. OPENING COMMENTS
THAT THEY LIKE TO MAKE ALL STAR
TO MY LEFT- SENATOR SCANNER IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS IT
DOESN'T YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
ANY BUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE AN OPENING COMMENT WE
CERTAINLY. WILL LOOK TO YOU TO
HAVE THAT SURE THAT MOMENT NOW.
THANK YOU- GERALD AND I'M GLAD
TO BE HERE AND I'M VERY HAPPY
THAT WE ARE PURSUING THIS
BECAUSE WHILE WE HAVE
LEGISLATION. WE KNOW THAT- IT.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO
ACHIEVE DIVERSITY. IN OUR-
PRIVATE SECTOR AND EVEN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR FOR THAT MATTER
THOUGH IT'S BETTER IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. AND CERTAINLY WE
WANT UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS
WHICH INCLUDES WOMEN AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
I'M TO BE IN. CBS'S HAMILTON
SAID I WANT TO BE IN THE ROOM
WHERE IT HAPPENS. AND IF WE'RE
NOT THEN THE- DECISIONS THAT
ARE MAE. ARE NOT AS- THEY'RE
NOT AS GOOD DECISIONS SO I'M
REALLY HAPPY THAT WE ARE THAT
HE COMMITTEE LIKE THIS EXISTS
BECAUSE THE TYPE OF OVERSIGHT
THAT WILL BE NEEDED. WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO IDENTIFY WHETHER WE
NEED TO STRENGTHEN BERRY'S
POLICIES THAT WE MAY HAVE AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE BOTH THE SOME MEMBERS
THAT NAY GARCIA AND CHRIS
HOLDEN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
ADDRESSING THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. FOR NOW THE
CALIFORNIA AR ENTIRE COUNTRY
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING. AS
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. WE
ACTUALLY HELD AT WELL ACTUALLY
AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON API AFFAIRS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE H. I.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WHICH I
CURRENTLY CHAIR. WHICH SHE HELD
A HEARING BACK IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN. AT THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION WE
TALKED ABOUT THE GLASS CEILING
FOR ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS-
THAT PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU AND
WE EXAMINED MANY DIFFERENT
FIELDS AT WHERE. BASICALLY YOU
SAW. API TO- CERTAIN
SUBSEGMENTS AGAIN ONLY IF THE
SIZE WE HAVE A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY CERTAIN SUBSEGMENTS
PERHAPS WERE WELL REPRESENTED
IN CERTAIN FIELDS LIKE
TECHNOLOGY OR MEDICINE AND OR
SOME OTHER FIELDS BUT YET I
NEVER WERE- WHICH TREMENDOUSLY
UNDER REPRESENTED IN SENIOR
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS C. SUITES
AND BOARDS. AND I THINK THAT
THE REASON I BRING THIS UP IS
THAT- YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO'S
WORKED ON PIPELINE PROGRAMS IN
MY CAREER CERTAINLY IN THE
FIELD OF MEDICINE WHICH I'M IN
THEPOSITION- I OFTEN HEAR.
THAT WELL IT'S THE PIPELINE.
AND CERTAINLY I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THERE AREN'T CERTAIN
PIPELINE ISSUES PARTICULARLY
FOR MANY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHERE THERE ARE. THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADVANCEMENT OF STRUCTURAL
RACISM HAS PREVENTED- PEOPLE OF
COLOR FROM BEING ABLE TO EVEN
GET ON TO THE ENTRY RONNING'S
BUT ALSO POINT OUT THAT. FOR
THE API COMMITTEE WHERE FOR
CERTAIN AGAIN ONLY CERTAIN
SUBSEGMENTS- THAT EVEN WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO ASCEND INTO.
SOME OF THOSE YOU KNOW A
PROFESSIONAL POSITION AND SO
FORTH. THAT THE PIPELINE IS NOT
THE ISSUE. AND THAT'S AN EXCUSE.
THE PIPELINE IS THERE SO WHY IS
IT IN MY OWN FIELD OF MEDICINE
THAT WELL WHAT IS THAT WHILE
YOU SEE REPRESENTATION AT LEAST
FOR CERTAIN SUBSEGMENTS AMONG
THE FACULTY. WE LOOK AMONG
MEDICAL SCHOOL DEANS. THE I
THINK WE'VE ACTUALLY FOUND ONE.
RIGHT A LOT OF CREDIT MEDICAL
SCHOOLS IN UNITED STATES. RIGHT
AND THEN LET'S TALK ABOUT
CORPORATE BOARDS AGAIN IN FACT
IF YOU TAKE TECHNOLOGY WHERE
SUPPOSEDLY AGAIN ONLY CERTAIN
SUBSEGMENTS OF THE API
COMMITTEE ARE WELL REPRESENTED.
IN THE TECH FIELD YOU DON'T SEE
THEM IN THE C. SUITES AND THE
BARS AND IN FACT. IT IS AND IF
YOU TAKE OUT THE ONES WHO
ACTUALLY FOUNDED THE COMPANIES
THEMSELVES SO ONCE YOU FIND ARE
OFTEN THE ONES WHO ARE ACTUALLY
THE FOUNDERS OF THE COMPANIES.
THEN THE NUMBERS EVEN WORSE. SO
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF LACK OF
TALENT AND I KNOW OUR COMMUNITY
STRUGGLES WITH THE MODEL
MINORITY MYTH. IT'S NOT LACK OF
TALENT IT'S NOT LACK OF
EXPERIENCE OR SKILL TO THE
DEGREE THAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
AFFORDED OUR COMMUNITIES. IT'S
FRANKLY RACISM. AND SO WE NEED
TO RECTIFY THIS IN OUR
CORPORATE LEADERSHIP IN OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR LEADERSHIP. THIS
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH IN THIS
HEARING IS CERTAINLY A VERY
IMPORTANT. DISCUSSION AND ALSO
THE BILL AB NINE SEVEN NINE WAS
VERY IMPORTANT POLICY STEP TO
BE IN ADDRESSING THAT SO AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIRS AND-
THE SELECT COMMITTEE FOR
DRESSING THIS ISSUE AND FOR
ALLOWING THOSE OF US IN THE
SENATE TO JOIN YOU IN THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR- A. I. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIA BONTA. THIS IS MY FIRST AT
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING AND
I'M THANKFUL THAT IT IS
ACTUALLY SELECT COMMITTEE. ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE MORE DIVERSITY AND OUR
CORPORATE BOARDS AND IN THE
CALIFORNIA. WORKFORCE OVERALL-
AS AND NONPROFIT EXECUTIVE AND
SOMEBODY WHO HAS COME THROUGH.
AT WORK WITH MANY DIFFERENT
CORPORATIONS AND IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW CRITICAL IT IS THAT WE
HAVE. DIVERSITY REPRESENTATION-
BOTH OF WOMEN OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR. I MYSELF GET THE FORTUNE
OF A PARTICIPATING IN THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS THE LATINO
CAUCUS AND THE BLACK CAUCUS.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND-
AND BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE REPRESENTATION IN
OUR IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AS WE
MAKE CRITICAL DECISIONS AT
WHETHER IT BE AROUND HEALTH A-
HEALTH JUSTICE ECONOMIC JUSTICE
HOUSING JUSTICE. AT WORKFORCE
JUSTICE IS REALLY THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE- AT THAT UNDERSTAND THE
PERSPECTIVE AND THE EXPERIENCE
OF WHAT IT MEANS TO NOT BE IN
THOSE ROOMS. FOR FAR TOO LONG
WE HAVE NOT BEEN IN THOSE ROOMS
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE. AT
YOUR LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AND GARCIA AT IN THE
SPACE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. TO HAVE THE
KIND OF DIVERSITY THAT WILL
LEAD TO THE STATE IN IN IN IN A
STRONGER DIRECTION. TOGETHER
THANK YOU. WELL I WANNA SAY.
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
BECAUSE THIS IS- A SENATOR
SKINNER POINTED OUT WHO GRADE
LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN. LAID
OUT THERE WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
AND ABOVE JACKSON'S BILL TE
BILL THAT WE'RE JUST- MODE FOUR
NINE SEVENTY NINE. THERE'S A
NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DIALOGUE AS WE MAKE OUR WAY
THROUGH IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
BILLS AND SO I THINK THIS
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO ALL BE INFORMED- DOCTOR PAN-
AS YOU POINTED OUT. TO REALLY
AWESOME PENETRATING QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF HOW- EQUITY IS ALSO
ADDRESSED IN THIS CONVERSATION
OF DIVERSITY AND I THINK THIS
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY. TO REALLY ENGAGE IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY- WILL ALL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
AFTER EACH PANEL- AND THEN AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE PANELS
WILL OPEN IT UP. FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- ONE QUICK NOTE BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY. SB TWENTY SIX
AND AB NINE SEVEN NINE OR BOTH-
SUBJECT TO PENDING LITIGATION-
THAT IS NOT THE TOPIC OF
TODAY'S HEARING AS THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. WHERE WE
ARE NOT HERE TO WEIGH IN ON ANY
PENDING LITIGATION LITIGATION.
SO IF WE COULD I'D LIKE TO- IN
THE FIRST PANEL. WILL HEAR
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF S.
B. A TWENTY SIX AN EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY NINE- BUT FIRST WE HAVE
A STATEMENT THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE READ BY ERIC GARRIS WHO IS
THE DEPUTY OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. HE IS REPRESENTING OUR
STEAM COLLEAGUE US SECRETARY OF
STATE DR SHIRLEY WEBER- THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AS
A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL AS
THE OFFICE THAT REVIEWS AND
ISSUES REPORTS REGARDING.
CORPORATES CORPORATIONS
COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH BILLS. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU ERIC FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING. OF THE
SECRETARY STATEMENT. YOUR
MENTOR AND MISTER MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PLEDGED TO BE HERE
TODAY AND- ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY WEBER WHEN A THANK
YOUNG FOR ALLOWING ME TO READ
THIS BRIEF STATEMENT- IN HER
STEAD- AS A LIFELONG CHAMPION
OF INCREASED INCLUSION OF
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES IN
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT FROM THE
CLASSROOM TO THE BOARDROOM AND
DIVERSITY IN THE WORKPLACE. THE
SECRETARY SPROUT TO NOW LEAD
THE OFFICE TASKED WITH
ADMINISTERING THE WOMEN AT ON
BOARDS AND DIVERSITY ON BOARDS
PROGRAMS. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENTING THE LAMBETH. WOMEN
ON BOARDS LEGISLATION SINCE IT
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW BY THEN
GOVERNOR. JERRY BROWN IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
WOMEN ON BOARD AFFECT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE HAS
BEEN WORKING ON COMPILING DATA
ABOUT BOARD DEMOGRAPHICS. THAT
WERE NOT PREVIOUSLY COLLECTED
BY OUR OFFICE OR ANY OTHER
STATE AGENCY. DURING THEIR
INITIAL YEARS OF DIVERSITY ON
BOARDS IMPLEMENTATION OUR
AGENCY IS FOCUSED ON EDUCATING
BUSINESSES ABOUT CORPORATE
DISCLOSURE STATEMENTS AND
DIVERSITY ON BOARDS
REQUIREMENTS RATHER THAN
REGULATION AND PENALIZE ATION.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
MAILED INFORMATIONAL LETTERS TO
OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
POTENTIAL CORPORATIONS
IDENTIFIED THROUGH SECURITIES
AND EXCHANGE COMMISSION. AND
SECRETARY OF STATE DATA- LEARN
THEM TO THE REVISED CORPORATION
CORPORATE DISCLOSURE STATEMENT
FORMS AND DIVERSITY ON BOARDS
FILING REQUIREMENTS. OUR OFFICE
CREATED A DIVERSITY- BOARD
WEBSITE WHICH INCLUDES PREVIOUS
WOMEN ON BOARDS REPORT
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
REGARDING STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. AS WELL AS LINKS
TO EXTERNAL RESOURCES FOR
INCREASING GENDER DIVERSITY ON
CORPORATE BOARDS. IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE PUBLISHES SECOND
ANNUAL WOMEN ON BOARDS REPORT
WHICH SHOWED AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN ON THE BOARDS
OF PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATIONS
FACING CALIFORNIA. IN THE
MONTHS SINCE PUBLISHING THE
SECOND REPORT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
EXAMINING THE DATA IN
CONSIDERING VARIOUS MECHANISMS
TO INCREASE REPORTING RATES.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
RECENTLY INCORPORATED THE
CORPORATE DISCLOSURE STATEMENT
INTO A SNOWY FORMS ONLINE TOOL
SO THAT FAMILIES CAN BE
SUBMITTED TO OUR OFFICE
ELECTRONICALLY. MARCH TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE WILL PUBLISH
THIS FIRST REPORT ON UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ON
BOARDS IN ADDITION TO WOMEN ON
BOARDS REPORT. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE LONGSTANDING
LACK OF DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
EDUCATE CORPORATIONS AS WELL AS
TO SIMPLIFY THE PLANNING
PROCESS FOR THE CORPORATE
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT WILL
RESULT IN THE HIGHER REPORTING
RATES UP FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AGAIN THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO PROVIDE
THE STATEMENT OF BEHALF OF
SECRETARY WEBER AND THE OFFICE
OF SECRETARY OF STATE. THANK
YOU AND GIVE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE OUR REGARDS AND
APPRECIATION THAT SHE IS IN
THIS POSITION AND WE KNOW THAT
SHE'LL DO A DILIGENT JOB AND-
AND FORCING BOTH OF THESE
IMPORTANT. BILLS THANK. THANK
YOU THANK NEXT WE HAVE MR I
GILERA FROM THE LATINO
CORPORATE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WILL PRESENT. SHE HAS WORKED IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS WITH THE
NATION'S MOST ACCOMPLISHED
LEADERS FROM CORPORATE AMERICA
THE U. S. CONGRESS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THE NOT
FOR PROFIT SECTOR. DRAWING UPON
THIS UNIQUE CROSS SECTION OF
EXPERIENCE SHE IS A SOUGHT
AFTER THOUGHT LEADER WHO HAS
DELIVERED NUMEROUS SPEECHES AND
PRESENTATIONS FOR DIVERSE
AUDIENCES SHE ALSO WRITES ON
SUBJECTS OF BOARD DIVERSITY AND
ORGANIZATIONAL EFFECTIVENESS
AND HIS GUEST COLUMNISTS AND
NUMEROUS PUBLICATIONS. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT ESTHER
AGUILERA AND THE LATINO
CORPORATE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL AND PROVIDING
UP TO DATE DATA ON THE RACIAL
COMPOSITION OF BOARDS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LCDA CONTINUES
TO TRACK OUR STATE'S PROGRESS
AS WELL AS PROGRESS ON
DIVERSITY EFFORTS FOR LATINOS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THANK YOU
ESTHER FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION.
OKAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA COURT
CHAIRS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CORPORATE CORPORATE BOARD IN
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DIVERSITY.
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
JOINING THE SELECT COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME. TO BE PART OF THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FIRST
OFF MY NAME IS ESTRELLA I GREW
UP IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
CITY OF SAN FERNANDO. AND AFTER
I'M THE DAUGHTER OF A LANDSCAPE
LABOR AND A GARMENT WORKER.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM
OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE I AM MOVED
TO WASHINGTON DC TO IMPACT
PUBLIC POLICY. MY PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL PURSUITS I'M BEEN
TO ELEVATE LATINOS TO POSITIONS
OF POWER- BOB AND TAKE OUR SEAT
AT THE TABLE BECAUSE WE ARE BY
ANY MEASURE THE LEAST
REPRESENTED- ON BOARDS AND VERY
INFLUENTIAL POSITIONS. SO ARE
ASSOCIATION I CURRENTLY SERVE
AS CEO OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
SERVICIOS THE LATINO CORPORATE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT OUR WORK IN
MONITORING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF BOTH S. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX
AND A. B. NINE SEVEN NINE.
FIRST OUT WE BEGAN MONITORING
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX AND WE PUBLISH THE
FIRST STUDY OUT FIFTEEN MONTHS
AFTER PASSAGE OF. EIGHT TWENTY
SIX OUGHT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
WOMEN. AND THE COMPOSITION OF
WOMEN THAT WERE BEING APPOINTED
TO CALIFORNIA COMPANY BOARDS
AND THE FIRST ANY FOUND THAT OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN
APPOINTMENTS MADE. AFTER
FIFTEEN MONTHS. 78% OF THE
APPOINTMENTS WERE WHITE WOMEN.
11% ASIAN WOMEN. 5% BLACK WOMEN
AND ONLY 3% LATINAS AGAIN THESE
WERE NEW APPOINTMENTS MADE
AFTER PASSAGE OF THAT BILL. WE
CONTINUED OUR RESEARCH BECAUSE
CLEARLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO OUR
ADD WOMEN TO THE BOARD. BUT WE
ALSO FOUND THAT BECAUSE THEY
WERE- MAINLY WHITE WOMEN THAT A
LOT OF THE BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA
REMAINED ALL WHITE AND IN JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
PUBLISHED ANOTHER STUDY. ARE OF
THE SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
PUBLIC COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
WERE ALL WHITE THAT IS 35% OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPANIES OUT WE
WERE VERY PLEASED TO LEARN AT
THAT TIME THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND OTHERS WERE LOOKING
AT. INTRODUCING. EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN NINE FIRST BOTH OF THESE
LAWS HAVE BEEN GROUNDBREAKING
AND CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
TRENDSETTING IN THE
INTRODUCTION OF BOTH BILLS- WE
HAVE FOUND THAT SINCE
INTRODUCING NINE SEVEN NINE WE
ARE SEEING A BIT MORE WOMEN OF
COLOR ADDED TO BOARD SO IT HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS UP ASSET AND
INFLUENCE. I'M GONNA GO TO SOME
SLIDES AND PRESENT YOU WITH.
OUR LATEST FINDINGS. THIS IS
FROM OUR. MORGAN REPORTS SO
WHEN EIGHTY NINE SEVEN NINE WAS
INTRODUCED WE ARE PRODUCING
REPORTS EVERY QUARTER TO
MONITOR- HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL IS GOING HOW
COMPANIES ARE COMPLYING AND WHO
IS BEING APPOINTED TO
CALIFORNIA BOARDS AND IN THIS
FIRST SLIDE YOU WILL SEE THE-
BOASTS THAT DEMOGRAPHICS OF
CALIFORNIA'S OP POPULATION YOU
CAN GO TO THE PREVIOUS SLIDE
PLEASE THANK YOU THIS IS
PERFECT SO IN THIS SLIDE YOU'RE
SEEING THE COMPOSITION OF
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES BY
GENDER RACE AND ETHNICITY. AND
THIS IS ADDS- Q. TWO OF. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO WHAT YOU SEE
HERE IS FIRST LATINOS ARE THE
LARGEST SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION WITH THIRTY NINE
POINT 4% THIS IS THE LATEST
TWENTY TWENTY DATA YET WE'RE
THE LARGEST DEMOGRAPHIC LARGER
THAN ARE WHITES WHITES
REPRESENT I NEARLY 35% ASIANS
ARE NEARLY 16% AND- BLACKS ARE
UP FIVE POINT 5% BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THE BOARD COMPOSITION OF
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES DO NOT
REFLECT ITS DEMOGRAPHIC AND ITS
STRENGTH OF ITS- POPULATION IN
TERMS OF BOARD APPOINTMENTS.
LATINOS ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
BY ANY MEASURE OF THOSE SERVING
ON BOARDS. AS OF Q. TWO OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONLY TWO
POINT 5% OF ALL BOARD SEATS OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COMPANY
BOARDS ARE HELD BY LATINOS. BOB
WHITES CONTINUE TO HOLD THE
LION'S SHARE OF BOARD SEATS AT
82% ASIANS HOLD 12% OF THE
SEATS AND BLACKS ARE FOUR POINT
3% THE PURPLE COLUMN HERE IS
WOMEN ARE THE PERCENTAGE OF
FEMALE SEATS HERE AGAIN LATINOS
ARE THE LEAST REPRESENTED EVEN
THOUGH. THEY ARE 20% OF ALL
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA A HOLD ON
THE ONE POINT 1% OF ALL
CALIFORNIA COMPANY SEATS AND I
ASK MYSELF HOW DOES THIS HAPPEN
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
AMERICA. SO WE ABSOLUTELY WANT
TO SEE SOME CHANGE WE CAN GO TO
THAT THE NEXT SLIDE. SO IN
ADDITION TO LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE COMPOSITION OF WHO'S ON
CALIFORNIA COMPANY BOARDS WERE
ALSO MONITORING NEW
APPOINTMENTS. SO THESE TWO
GRAPHS SHOW YOU THAT NEW
APPOINTMENTS MADE TO CALIFORNIA
BOARDS BETWEEN JULY ONE. AND
TWENTY TWENTY AND JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
THREE OINTMENTS MADE DURING
THAT PERIOD. OF THESE NEW
APPOINTMENTS. 70% 69% OR NINE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE OF THOSE
APPOINTMENTS ARE. WERE SEIZED
BY WHITES THE SECOND LARGEST
SEGMENT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE SEATS OR 18% OF THOSE NEW
APPOINTMENTS IN THAT PERIOD OF
WERE SEIZED BY ASIAN AMERICANS
ARE LACKS SEES 10% OF THE SEATS
A HUNDRED FORTY. AND LATINOS
WERE ONLY TAPPED FOR FORTY NINE
SEATS OR THREE POINT 5% THIS
BOTTOM PORTION OF YOUR ODDS
SLIDE HERE THE SLIDE LOOKS AT.
THE GENDER BREAKDOWN. FOUR THE
GENDER BREAKDOWN OVER ALL OF
THE APPOINTMENTS MADE BETWEEN
THIS PERIOD. 60% R. WHERE ERE
ASSIGNED TO MEN. WERE APPOINTED
AT TO WHITES THAT'S UP NUMBER
IS. IT'S SEVENTY IS 63% OF THAT
TOTAL. ASIANS GARNERED HUNDRED
TEN SEATS OR 19% AND BLACKS
GARDNER 13% OF THE SEATS
LATINOS LIKE DENIES IN THIS
CASE- GAINED 5% AGAIN OF THE
WOMEN OF THE APPOINTMENTS MADE
TO TWO WOMEN- I WILL MAKE A
NOTE AND COMPARING OUR FIRST
DATA. WITH WHERE WE ARE TO DATE
WHEN WE FIRST MEASURED. WHO ARE
THE WOMEN THE COMPOSITION OF
WOMEN GETTING ON BOARD- BACK IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BOB WHITE
WOMEN AGAIN OR 70% OF THE SEATS
IT WENT DOWN TO SIXTY THREE
PERCENT. IT'S STILL ARE LARGER
THAN THEIR SHARE OF THE
POPULATION SO WAS THAT A
NEGATIVE FIFTEEN. OP AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN ARE WENT FROM
11% 219% THE LAW HAD AN IMPACT.
WITH AN INCREASE OF PLUS 8% OF
OUR BLACK WOMEN GETTING ON
BOARDS OB AND FOR I'M SORRY
THAT WAS ASIAN WOMEN ASIAN
WOMEN GAINED AT EIGHT PERCENT.
OUT BLACK WOMEN WERE 5% OF
BOARD SEES BEFORE THIS LAW
AFTER THE LAW. OUT THERE ARE
13% OF THE SEATS SO THAT WE
HAVE SEEN WOMEN OF COLOR
INCREASE FOR LATINOS. BEFORE
THE LAW. FOUR SEVEN NINE SEVEN
NINE OUT. THERE WERE THE CARD
OR 3% OF SEATS AFTER NINE SEVEN
NINE THEY GARNERED 5% OF SEATS
ON INCREASE OF TWO PERCENT.
AGAIN LATINAS AND LATINOS BY
ANY MEASURE ARE STILL AT LEAST
REPRESENTED OF ANY DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUP AND WE HAVE THE WIDEST
GAP TO CLOSE COMPARED TO OUR
SCIENCE IN THE STATE'S
POPULATION. WE GOT TO THE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. THIS A SLIGHT
GIVES YOU SOME TREND DATA. OF
THE DIFFERENT QUARTERS WHERE WE
ARE MEASURING APPOINTMENTS THE
NEW APPOINTMENTS THE PURPLE
SHOWS YOU THAT APPOINTMENTS
MADE BETWEEN JULY ONE IN
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE. AT THE
NEXT THAT TIAN IS OUR Q. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATA AND THE
GREAT IS. UP Q. TO THE LATEST
DATA SO YOU SEE HERE BOB WHAT
THE TRENDS HAVE BEEN FOUR WHITE
ASIAN BLACK AND LATINOS- IN
TERMS OF CORNERING SEATS. WE
SEE CLEAR. STRONG NUMBERS FOR
WHITE FOR WHITES OVER ALL
ASIANS IN THE LAST QUARTER
INCREASED THERE ARE
APPOINTMENTS SIGNIFICANTLY-
SOME FOR BLACKS AND LATINOS
CONTINUE TO HAVE A VERY LOW
NUMBER OF APPOINTMENTS I'M IN
THE PROCESS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE METHODOLOGY
AT THE TIME OF THEIR QUEUE TO
REPORTS THERE ARE SEVEN HUNDRED
NINE PUBLIC COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WAS A TOTAL OF FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE SEATS. STILL TODAY
NEARLY 23% OF CALIFORNIA
COMPANY OUR BOARD SEATS ARE ALL
WHITE THEY DON'T INCLUDE RACE
ARE RACIAL OR ETHNIC INDIVIDUAL
ON THE SEATS THEY MAY INCLUDE
WHITE WOMEN BUT WE STILL HAVE A
WAYS TO GO FOR CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES TO OP AD REYES AND
ETHNICITY- EIGHTY TWO POINT 7%
OF CALIFORNIA COMPANIES. VAST
MAJORITY DO NOT HAVE A SINGLE
LATINO OR LATINA ON THE BOARD.
WITH THIS JOB MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND- THE AUDIENCE- WE
HAVE A MADE SOME PROGRESS THAT
BILL NINE SEVEN NINE HELPED TO
INCREASE SOME DIVERSITY FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR ON THE BOARDS
BUT THERE STILL REMAINS A GREAT
DEAL OF BARRIERS FOR ODD
LATINAS AND LATINOS IN
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO MEASURE. ALL
THE U. S. DEMOGRAPHICS OF
LATINOS ON BOARDS AND
CALIFORNIA- IS AT THE TOP OF
THE LEAST WITH THE LEAST NUMBER
AND PERCENTAGE OF LATINOS OF
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY
WE ARE AS THE LATINO CORPORATE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
PERFORMED BY LATINO DIRECTORS.
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ARE LOW AND
WE KEPT HEARING EXCUSES THAT
YOU CAN FIND THEM I WILL TELL
YOU THAT THERE IS AMPLE TALENT
FOR THE BOARDROOM OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS INCREASING
THREEFOLD- ALMOST ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AND SO REALLY THERE IS NO
EXCUSE FOR CONTINUES TO BE. A
STRUCTURAL RACISM ALL. FOR
LATINOS IN THE PIPELINE IN THE
C. SUITE AND THE BOARDROOM AND
IN EVERY SECTOR OF THE COUNTRY.
LATINOS ARE NATIONWIDE. R. TWO
IN TEN AMERICANS WE CONTRIBUTE
28% OF THE NATION'S GDP GROWTH.
OUR MARKET SHARE IS INCREASING
70% HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER GROUP
AND WE CONTRIBUTE 72% OF NEW
ENTRANTS TO THE WORK FORCE
INVESTING IN PROMOTING LATINOS
FOR POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP AND
POWER WILL ONLY HELP THE
ECONOMY AND THE STATE. I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR DATA. THANK YOU
ESTHER ARM HI I THINK WHEN I
WHEN WE STARTED THIS I WOULD
SAY THAT WE WOULD HAVE-
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL- SO. JANET LONG IF YOU
COULD GIVE US JUST A MOMENT AND
WE WILL COME TO YOU AND
INTRODUCE YOU UNLESS. THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT WANT TO BE HELD
WHERE WE'RE AT. WE'LL DO IT
TOGETHER OKAY- ASSISTED US TO
RAISE A LOT OF INTERESTING. THE
ISSUES THAT I THINK WERE
CAPTURED US IN THE MOMENT BUT
WILL HOLD AND I WILL NOW
INTRODUCE. OUR NEXT PRESENTER-
JANET S. HUANG FROM THE DIVERSE
CORPORATE DIRECTORS COALITION.
AND WOMEN CORPORATE DIRECTORS
AS LONG AS AN INDEPENDENT BOARD
DIRECTOR. FOR PUBLICLY LISTED
COMPANIES INCLUDING TWO HEADED
HEADQUARTERED IN THE SILICON
VALLEY. SHE IS A LONGTIME
VOLUNTEER AND ADVOCATE FOR
WORKPLACE DIVERSITY ESPECIALLY
IN THE CORPORATE BOARD ROOM.
SHE REPRESENTS THE PAN ASIAN
COMMUNITY ON THE DIVERSE
CORPORATE DIRECTORS COALITION
SHE IS A MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S
CORPORATE DIRECTORS AND
VOLUNTEERS AS AN EXECUTIVE
ADVISOR TO ASCEND THE LARGEST
ASIAN PERSON PROFESSIONAL
BUSINESS ORGANIZATION IN NORTH
AMERICA. DURING HER TIME
MEDICINE SHE SERVED AS A LEADER
OF A SEN PENTACLE IT'S NETWORK
OF EXPERIENCED AND ASPIRING
CORPORATE BOARD DIRECTORS. SHE
ALSO SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE 30% COALITION
WORKING TO INCREASE DIVERSITY
IN CORPORATE BOARD ROOMS ACROSS
THE U. S. LIKE TO THANK YOU MS
ONE FOR JOINING US TODAY. WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING A PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HOLDEN AND
GARCIA TWO OF THE KEY SPONSORS
OF AB NINE SEVEN NINE AND CO
CHAIRS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS OTHER- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE TODAY FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN IMPROVE ON
CORPORATE BOARD DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S A GREAT
PRIVILEGE AND A PLEASURE TO
PARTICIPATE ON THIS PANEL WITH
MR ERIK GAS AND WITH ESTHER AG
ALERA ESTHER IS NOT ONLY A CO
ADVOCATE OF CORPORATE BOARD
DIVERSITY BUT ALSO A FRIEND. OF
SO I MET IN THE UNIQUE POSITION
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN SAID
WHERE I AM A CORPORATE BOARD
DIRECTOR CURRENTLY SERVING ON
THE BOARDS UP FOR PUBLIC
COMPANIES INCLUDING TWO WITH
HEADQUARTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE JUST TO SHARE THE
DIVERSITY OF BOTH OF THESE
COMPANIES WORK FORCE IN THE
BOARD ROOM BECAUSE THEY ARE
GREAT EXAMPLES OF BOTH SB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX AND AB NINE SEVEN
NINE. SO WE CAN PUT UP THE
FIRST SLIDE- LAST SEPTEMBER I
WAS ELECTED TO. THE BOARD OF
LUMENTUM. A TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN
GO THE NEXT SLIDE THANK YOU. A
TECHNOLOGY MANUFACTURER THAT'S
HEADQUARTERED IN SAN JOSE I
STRONGLY MET THEIR SKILLS
MATRIX FOR THIS NEW BOARD SEAT.
AND I'LL IT ALSO ENABLED
MOMENTUM TO ME SB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX AS AT THE TIME THEY HAD TWO
WOMEN. BOARD DIRECTORS BUT
WANTED TO ADD A THIRD WOMAN
MEMBER AND THEY ALSO WANTED O
ADD SOME RACIAL DIVERSITY TO
REFLECT THEIR EMPLOYEE WORK
FORCE. OF THE COMPANY AND AS
YOU CAN SEE FROM THIS GRAPHIC
THIS IS. ACTUALLY THE WORK
FORCE TODAY R. AS OF AUGUST
THIRTY ONE IN CALIFORNIA AND IT
SHOWS THAT OVER 60% OF THE WORK
FORCE IS ASIAN. OUR RECENTLY
LUMENTUM ADDED A SUPPLY CHAIN
EXPERT TO ITS BOARD WITH THE
WELL QUALIFIED DIRECTORS WHO IS
AFRICAN AMERICAN SO NOW THE
BOARD CONSISTS OF. EIGHT IN
TOTAL WITH THREE WOMEN- ONE
WOMAN OF COLOR AND A MALE OF
PERSON THE COLOR. SO IF WE CAN
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE LUCID IS AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE MANUFACTURER
ALSO HEADQUARTERED IN SILICON
VALLEY I JUST RECENTLY OF WAS
DISTINGUISHED TO BE THE FIRST
ELECTRIC CAR TO RECEIVE A FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILE EPA
RATED RANGE ON A SINGLE CHARGE.
I JOINED ITS BOARD OF THIS PAST
JULY WHEN THE COMPANY BECAME
PUBLICLY LISTED ON THE NASDAQ
AND FROM THE GRAPH IN THE UPPER
RIGHT HAND CORNER YOU CAN SEE
THAT LUCID IS A FAST GROWING
COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA IN YEAR
TO DATE HAS ADDED OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY JOBS IN THE
STATE. L'USAGE TRULY HAS ITS
HEART IN CALIFORNIA WITH NOT
ONLY ITS HEADQUARTERS HERE BUT
ALSO FOR FIVE RETAIL SHOW ROOMS
SO FAR IN THE STATE. AND WHERE
IT'S INTERIOR CAR DESIGNS I
REALLY LIKE THIS OUR NAME WITH
CALIFORNIA THEMES SUCH AS SANTA
MONICA IN TAHOE. IT CURRENTLY
HAS A BOARD OF NINE DIRECTORS
WHICH INCLUDES THREE WOMEN OF
WHICH TWO ARE WOMEN OF COLOR.
AN ASIAN AND AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN. AS YOU CAN TELL I'M
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT BOTH OF
THESE COMPANIES AS THEY NOT
ONLY HAVE AND SUPPORT A DIVERSE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THESE
COMPANIES ARE BUILDING THE
FUTURE OF DIVERSE LEADERS
THROUGH THE DIVERSITY OF THE
EMPLOYEE WORK FORCE AND
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT. IF WE CAN GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE. UP ESTHER HAVE
PROVIDED A GREAT UPDATE ON THE
IMPACT TO THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
ON CALIFORNIA BOARDS- THAT ARE
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
NUMBER OF PORTS SEATS HELD BY.
OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
NUMBERS- AND NO SHE POINTED OUT
HOW LOW THE LATINO- OF.
REPRESENTATION IS ON BOARDS
AGAIN ASIANS ARE ALSO DOWN AT
THE AT THE LOW PERCENTAGES OF
THAT GROUP AS WELL. SO IN STATE
OF FOCUSING MORE ON THE NUMBERS
I WANTED TO SHARE SOME THOUGHTS
ON HOW. WE AND THE LEGISLATURE
COULD FURTHER IMPROVE ON THE
STATISTICS OF BOARD DIVERSITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND. SO ON THIS SLIDE JUST
WANTED TO MOVE. UP THIS
EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
BOARD DIVERSITY DISCLOSURE. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
DIVERSE CORPORATE CORRECTORS
COALITION OF WHICH THAT LATINO
CORPORATE DIRECTORS IS ALSO A
MEMBER RELEASED A CALL TO
ACTION FOR GREATER BOARD
DIVERSITY. AND ONE OF THE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS CALL TO
ACTION WAS FOR COMPANIES
ESPECIALLY PUBLIC COMPANIES TO
REPORT OR DISCLOSE INFORMATION
ON THE MAKE UP OF THEIR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS SO IN EFFECT A
CALL FOR TRANSPARENCY. ARE
THOUGHT AT THE TIME AND STILL
TODAY IS WHAT GETS MEASURED
GETS DONE YOU KNOW WE CAN SEE
THAT WITH OF THE NUMBERS THAT
ESTHER WENT THROUGH THAT. THERE
HAS BEEN SOME MOVEMENT WITH
BOTH OF THE CALIFORNIA LAWS BUT
OBVIOUSLY MORE BRING- TO
IMPROVE ON BOARD DIVERSITY.
RECENTLY KPMG BOARD LEADERSHIP
CENTER WHO SUPPORTS THE DC DC
RELEASED TOOLS TO HELP
COMPANIES DISCLOSE THEIR BOARD
COMPOSITION INFORMATION AND YOU
CAN FIND THAT ON THEIR WEBSITE.
ALL WE HAVE SCENES DAY COLDER
CALLS CONTINUE TO GROW OR
DISCLOSURE OF BOARD DIVERSITY
HOWEVER DISCLOSURE PRACTICES
ARE NOT CONSISTENT ACROSS
COMPANIES FOR EXAMPLE SOME
COMPANIES REPORT ONLY THE
AGGREGATE NUMBER OR PERCENTAGE
OF DIVERSE BOARD MEMBERS AND
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN LESS LIKELY
TO REPORT THE DIVERSITY OF
INDIVIDUAL BOARD MEMBERS SO WE
CAN GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. WE
BELIEVE WITH MORE DETAILED
DISCLOSURE ABOUT BOARD
DIVERSITY IT WILL PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT EACH DIRECTOR
BRINGS TO THE BOARD ROOM TABLE.
I MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
DC DC CALL TO ACTION AND THE
EXAMPLES IN THAT CALL TO ACTION
IT ALSO PROVIDES A TEMPLATE FOR
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THEIR
DIVERSITY INFORMATION SO WE'RE
SEEING A LOT MORE TOOLS TO
HELP. COMPANIES DISCLOSE THEIR
BOARD DATA. IF WE GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. SLIDE IS A GRAPHIC
REFLECTING THAT LARGER
COMPANIES IN THE S. AND P. FIVE
HUNDRED INDEX ARE MORE LIKELY
TO PROVIDE DIVERSITY DISCLOSURE
INFORMATION THEN COMPANIES IN
THE BROADER RUSSELL THREE
THOUSAND INDEX SO NEARLY THREE
QUARTERS OR 71% OF S. AND P.
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES. BOB
DISCLOSE THEIR RACIAL AND
DIVERSITY MAKE UP COMPARED TO
ONLY A THIRD OR 34% OF THE
RUSSELL THREE THOUSAND. INDEX
SOME COMPANIES ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING BOTH AGGREGATE AND
INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION HOWEVER
THE NUMBER OF COMPANIES AND THE
PERCENTAGE ARE NOT AS LARGE FOR
EXAMPLE 19% OF COMPANIES IN THE
S. AND P. FIVE HUNDRED ARE
PROVIDING BOTH THE AGGREGATE
AND INDIVIDUAL BOARD
INFORMATION AND ONLY 5% OF THE
RUSSELL THREE THOUSAND ARE
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION. SO
WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. BOB
THIS JUST GIVE SOME FURTHER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AGGREGATE
DISCLOSURE WHICH AGAIN IS LESS
INFORMATION UP IT IS INCREASING
SOAK UP BOARDS ARE COMPANIES
ARE PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION
ON THEIR BOARDS. OF IN FACT THE
NUMBER OF COMPANIES IS MORE
THAN DOUBLE FROM JANUARY TO
JULY OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
SO AGAIN HOPEFULLY WE WILL SEE
THAT TREND CONTINUE TO GET
BETTER. IF WE GO TO THE NEXT
SLIDE. THIS REFLECTS COMPANIES
THAT ARE PROVIDING INDIVIDUAL
DIVERSITY DISCLOSURE WHICH
AGAIN PROVIDES MORE DATA MORE
INFORMATION. OF THE PERCENTAGE
OF COMPANIES THAT ARE PROVIDING
THE INDIVIDUAL RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY DATA HAS ALSO
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY DURING
THE SAME TIMEFRAME JANUARY TO
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN FACT
IT'S MORE THAN DOUBLED FROM
JANUARY WHEN IT WAS 16% TO JULY
OF THIS YEAR WHERE IT'S NOW
THIRTY FOUR PERCENT. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE RUSSELL THREE
THOUSAND COMPANIES DISCLOSING
INDIVIDUAL DIRECTOR DATA THE
NUMBERS TRIPLE HOWEVER IT
STARTED WITH A SMALLER NUMBER
IN JANUARY AT 5% AND NOW IT'S
15% OF THE RUSSELL THREE
THOUSAND. THAT ARE DISCLOSING
THE INDIVIDUAL DATA. SO WE CAN
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE- CAN WE
BACK UP ONE SLIDE BACK TO THE
OTHER ONE JUST WANT TO INDICATE
THAT THERE IS GREATER SUPPORT
FOR BOARD DIVERSITY DISCLOSURE
INCLUDING NASDAQ'S BOARD
DIVERSITY ROLE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING REMARKS THIS RULE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SEC AND AUGUST
pINCLUDES A DISCLOSURE STANDARD
REQUIRING COMPANIES LISTED ON
THE U. S. EXCHANGE TO PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE THEIR BOARD LEVEL
DIVERSITY STATISTICS. AND THE
HAVE OR EXPLAIN WHY THEY DO NOT
HAVE AT LEAST TWO DIVERSE
CORRECTORS ON THEIR PORCH IN IN
ON THE NASDAQ'S WEBSITE THEY
ALSO PROVIDE AN EXAMPLE OF A
GOOD DIVERSITY DISCLOSURE SO
I'VE MENTIONED THREE NOW THAT
DC DC KPMG'S BOARD LEADERSHIP
CENTER AND NASDAQ THAT ALL HAVE
EXAMPLES. FOR DISCLOSING MORE
DIVERSITY DATA. IF WE CAN GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE. THIS IS MY-
LAST SLIDE AND WHAT I'M
REFLECTING HERE IS AN EXAMPLE
OF INDIVIDUAL- DIRECTOR
DIVERSITY DATA. AND THIS IS FOR
LUMENTUM THE COMPANY THAT I
SERVE ON ITS BOARD AGAIN IT'S A
MID CAP COMPANY. THIS IS IN
THEIR PROXY THERE- SHAREHOLDER
MEETING IS COMING UP IN
NOVEMBER SO THIS IS JUST
RECENTLY RELEASED DATA BUT
THERE ARE DISCLOSURE NOT ONLY
SHOWS A SKILLS MATRIX X. FOR
EACH DIRECTOR ON THE BOARD. BUT
IT ALSO SHOWS WITH AT THE VERY
BOTTOM OF THE PAGE THAT
DIVERSITY- GENDER RACIAL MAKE
UP OF EACH DIRECTOR SO AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THERE ARE
THREE WOMEN- ONE WOMAN OF COLOR
MYSELF AND ONE OF MALE. SAY
AFRICAN AMERICAN. SO I THINK
THAT THIS REPRESENTS A GOOD
EXAMPLE AND I JUST WANTED TO
BOB DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER- STATE OTHER ENTITIES NOT
JUST STATE A CALIFORNIA STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS DEFINITELY
BEEN A LEADER. IN BOARD
DIVERSITY- WE CAN SEE NASDAQ
TAKING A LEAD THERE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS I HAD A NEW LAW
REQUIRING COMPANIES WITH THEIR
EXECUTIVE OFFICES IN THE STATE
OF ILLINOIS TO DISCLOSE THE
MAKE UP OF THEIR CORPORATE
BOARDS- THE SEC IS ALSO
CONSIDERING DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS. THERE'S A LARGE
FOCUS FOR COMPANIES TO- REPORT
AND PROVIDE ESG INFORMATION AND
THAT SORT OF PART OF THAT YES
IN THE ESD. OF THERE'S A FOCUS
NOW ABOUT DISCLOSURE OF BOARD
INFORMATION I THINK THE KEY
WILL BE. THAT DUMB IF WILL GET
CONSISTENCY IN THE INFORMATION
REPORTED SO I DEFINITELY THINK
THERE IS A MOVEMENT IN GREATER
BOARD OF. DISCLOSURE IN SUMMARY
THE DIVERSE CORPORATE DIRECTORS
COALITION AS WELL AS OTHER
SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONS YOU
KNOW RECOMMENDS THAT THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND THE EGISLATORS
LEGISLATURES SUPPORT INDIVIDUAL
BOARD DIRECTOR DIVERSITIES
DISCLOSURE ESPECIALLY FOR
COMPANIES HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY BEEN A
LEADER IN CORPORATE BOARD
DIVERSITY AND I THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT. SO THAT CONCLUDES MY
FORMAL REMARKS AND I LOOKED FOR
CHEAP QUICK QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS. THANK YOU AS LONG WAS-
APPRECIATED PRESENTATION VERY
THOROUGH I WILL TURN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTION I KNOW THAT- OF VICE
VERSA COCHAIR OF GARCIA HAS A
FEW QUESTIONS AND I'LL AND THEN
DOCTOR DOCTOR PAN. I THINK IN
IN THE QUESTIONS FOR BOTH OF
YOU WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND THE
DATA OFFER A HELPFUL EARLIER-
MAKING MISS HUANG SAID THAT
WILL GETS MEASURED. GETS DONE-
AND I THINK I WONDER. I'D ADD
TO THAT WE'LL GET MEASURED
PUBLICLY. GETS DONE AND HE GAVE
HIS ONE RECOMMENDATION AT THE
END OF YOUR PRESENTATION- TO DO
THE INDIVIDUAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS DIVERSITY INFORMATION
PUBLICLY. OUT THERE TO HELP
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD- WHEN WE
WERE HAVING THE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND AB NINE SEVEN THE NINE
THE DISCUSSION OF EQUITY
SOMETHING THAT MR HOLDEN AND I
KEPT GOING BACK AND FORTH ON
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE SIGN PRUDENT THAT WE SIDE
EQUITABLY ACROSS ALL.
MARGINALIZED GROUPS AND NOT
JUST ONE GROUP OR THE OR THE
VERSUS ANOTHER OUT THERE AND AT
THE DATA THAT AS A PRESENTED TO
US LET'S NOT THAT THAT CONCERN
IS REAL AND WE NEED TO FIND
WAYS TO ADDRESS THAT EQUITY
ISSUE. SO IN ADDITION TO
INDIVIDUAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS
EVERSON INFORMATION THAT YOU
RECOMMEND THAT YOURSELF OR MISS
AND LARA I HAVE ADDITIONAL
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WILL HELP US GET TO A MORE
EQUITABLE- SITUATION AS A AS A
LATINA. AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS- YOU KNOW I TAKE
A BRIEF MOMENT TO BE THANKFUL
FOR THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE BUT
I THINK FOR THE MOST PART STILL
PRETTY ALARMED AFFORDABLE OF
WHERE WE'RE AT AND HOW SLOW THE
CHANGES HAPPENING FOR. THESE
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND SO I DO
LIKE- ADDITIONAL IDEAS THAT YOU
THINK WE NEED TO DO TO. TO
CREATE MORE EQUITY IN IN THESE
NUMBERS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GARCIA I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
START I'M SURE JANET BALL
TRYING MAN. JANET IS THAT AN
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE AND I'M ONE
OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF. THAT
DIVERSE CORPORATE DIRECTORS
COALITION. THAT INCLUDES. THE
BLACK DIRECTORS CONFERENCE THAT
SAID TENTACLE AB AND WHEN
CORPORATE DIRECTORS- ASCEND.
PINNACLE AND THE OUT QUORUM
WHICH IS THE L. G. B. T. Q.
DIRECTORS- PART OF WHAT JANET
MENTIONED IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
DISCLOSURE. WE HAVE TO DO A LOT
OF INDIVIDUAL- MEASURING
COMPANIES TO COME UP WITH OUR
DATA SO THE DISCLOSURE REALLY
WOULD. MAKE IT A LOT MORE
PUBLIC AND I WHICH STRONGLY
URGE- TO DISAGGREGATE THE DATA
OUT. I THINK SOMETIMES
COMBINING DIVERSITY DATA OR
PEOPLE OF COLOR DATA DOES NOT
GET. TO THE INDIVIDUAL MEASURES
THAT WE NEED. SO DISAGGREGATE.
BY LATINO ASIAN AND BLACK WOMEN
AND EVEN FOR THE NUMBER OF
WOMEN SOMETIMES WILL GIVE
HERE'S HOW WOMEN ARE DOING BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO DISAGGREGATE.
ARM THE NUMBER OF WOMEN AS WELL
BECAUSE AND WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE'RE DOING
BOTH. IN THE GENERAL POPULATION
FOR ALL. AND HOW WE'RE DOING
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND- CONCUR
WITH THE. ACCIDENT REPORT THAT
JANET GAVE. THANK YOU ESTHER
MAYBE I CAN JUST ADD A LITTLE
BIT ON TO THAT ALL BECAUSE YEAH
I AM A FIRM BELIEVER YEAH WHAT
GETS MEASURED GETS DONE SO TO
THE EXTENT PEOPLE- SEE THOSE
STATISTICS ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
GET EXAMPLES OF. LIKE IN THE
STATE OF BOTH THE LATINO AND
ASIAN COMMUNITY ARE VERY LARGE
POPULATION WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT HOLD VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGES OF THE BOARD SEAT
SO I THINK THAT DISCLOSURE
HELPS. I THINK ANOTHER WAY THAT
THIS CAN BE DONE- IS JUST THE
AWARENESS AND BY HAVING THIS-
FORUM TODAY. YOU KNOW THAT JUST
HELPS DEMONSTRATE WE'RE GIVING
AN UPDATE AND WE SHOW SOME
PROGRESS BUT THERE'S STILL ROOM
FOR MORE IMPROVEMENT SO JUST
HAVING THE DISCUSSIONS AND
BRINGING OUT THAT THERE IS THE
ISSUE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF.
THE GREATER BOARD DIVERSITY I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL. THANK YOU
DR PAN. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS I DO
JUST WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
BRIEFLY- KNOWLEDGE. A SECRETARY
OF STATE AND ACTUALLY ERIC
KARROS WAS MY FIRST LEDGE
DIRECTOR SUMMER I'LL GET TO SEE
HIM BACK- SO AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS OF OUR SECRETARY OF
STATE- TO- TRYING TO GATHER
DATA AND MONITOR THIS DATA. AND
SO I DO HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
BOTH- MISS AG ALERA AND- AND IN
THIS ONE AS WELL I THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS-
THAT STATE SO MUCH SO I GUESS
MY FIRST QUESTION FOR THE
SECULAR- IN IT AND I JUST WANT
TO. AND I HEARD YOU SAY THIS
BUT I JUST WANT AND PERHAPS
HAVE YOU REPEAT THIS- I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
STATE. DESPITE OUR VERY LARGE
LATINO POPULATION ACTUALLY HAS
THE LOW IS THE LOWEST OF ANY
STATES IN TERMS. OF CORPORATE
BOARD REPRESENTATION FOR
LATINOS. THAT HEAR THAT RIGHT.
YES THAT IS CORRECT- AND I
WOULD JUST I MEAN AS YOU KNOW
THE CHANNELS ARE NOT ONLY A
LARGE SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION WE ARE THE PLAN THE
REALITY LARGER THAN ANY OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC. CALIFORNIA IS
DISTINCT IN THAT WAY- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE OVERALL CALIFORNIA
STATISTICS LATINOS HOLD TWO
POINT 5% OF THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD SEATS NATIONWIDE THIS IS-
NATIONWIDE IT'S CLOSER 23% AND
SO UP NATIONWIDE WE ARE 20% OF
THE POPULATION COMPARED TO
FORTY SO IF WE WERE. TO MEASURE
EQUITABLY. COMPARED TO THAT
NATIONWIDE IT SHOULD BE CLOSER
TO FOUR PERCENT- BUT WE DO HAVE
DATA BROKEN OUT BY STATE IN
TERMS OF HOW MANY BOARDS
COMPANIES ARE IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW MANY HAVE. THAT YOU KNOW
DIRECTORS AND CALIFORNIA
MEASURE. OUR FIFTIETH IN TERMS
OF. I WOULD SAY FIFTIETH IN
TERMS. OF THE STATE THE LARGEST
CALIPH LATINO POPULATION MAYBE
NOT OUT OF ALL FIFTY OF THE TOP
ALL STATES WITH LATINO
POPULATION BUT TINA- CALIFORNIA
IS AT THE BOTTOM OKAY ALL
RIGHT. YOU SEE VERY TROUBLING
STATISTIC BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AND HAVE YOU
REPEAT THAT SURE I HEARD IT
CORRECTLY- AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION ACTUALLY RELATED
TO DATA COLLECTION AND I ALSO
WILL HAVE A QUESTION FOR THIS
ONE ABOUT THIS AS WELL. BUT
JANUARY SO IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO COLLECT THIS DATA GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU THINK WE NEED
TO DO SO THAT SO I GUESS SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT. YOU KNOW HOW MUCH EFFORT
IT TAKES TO COMPILE THIS
INFORMATION AND WHAT SHOULD WE
DO TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR GROUPS
LIKE YOURSELF TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO- TO GET THIS
INFORMATION AS WELL AS OF
COURSE BEING ABLE TO. HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RESULTS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. WELL WE TEAMED UP
WITH AQUILO ARE WHICH IS BASED
IN CALIFORNIA. AND DAVID CHIU
ON IS THE CEO. AND IT'S A
PLATFORM THAT TRACKS ALL
DIRECTORS AND- SENIOR
EXECUTIVES AND COLLECTS DATA
THAT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. AND
IT'S A MASSIVE DATABASE AND WE
STARTED. WORKING WITH THEM
ALONG WITH OTHER. RACE ETHNIC
GROUPS TO IDENTIFY WITH IN THE
EKWALL OUR NETWORK. WHICH OUT
DIRECTORS ARE IDENTIFIED AS
LATINOS AND WHICH DON'T. AND WE
HAVE A METHODOLOGY FOR DOING
THAT WE DO RESEARCH- ON HOW
THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS. NOT ONLY
YOU KNOW WE DON'T ONLY LOOK AT
THE NAME BUT ARE THEY A U. S.
LATINO OR LATINA. VERSUS I'M
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T RESIDE IN
THE COUNTRY NOT- REALLY
CONNECTED WITH THE U. S. THAT
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES SO WE GOT
TO THAT. STAFF TO COME UP WITH
THESE NUMBERS- SO THAT IT IS A
LOT OF WORK. OUT ONE- MODELS.
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN LOOK AT.
THERE IS LARGEST. THAT WAS
INTRODUCED IN THE U. S. HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES IT ACTUALLY
PASSED AT THE HOUSE AT THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
LAST CONGRESS. THIS YEAR IT
ALSO PASSED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THERE IS-
LEGISLATION UP IN THE HOUSE AND
IT'S PENDING ON THE SENATE ON
THE SENATE SENATOR MENENDEZ
INTRODUCED A- COMPANION BILL.
IT HAS NOT MOVED BUT WHAT THAT
BILL IT IS A DISCLOSURE BAIL
AND IT'S- A REASONABLE MEASURE%
IT'S NOT ONEROUS BUT IT CALLS
FOR YOU KNOW COMPANIES. FOR
DIRECTORS TO SELF DISCLOSE AND
THE COMPANY TO REPORT AS PART
OF THEIR SEC REPORTING. WHAT
THE COMPOSITION IS OF THE BOARD
GENDER- RACE ETHNICITY AND
VETERAN STATUS- SO THAT IS- YOU
KNOW ONE WAY TO DO IT IS JUST
FOR DIRECTORS TO SELF IDENTIFY
IF THEY FEEL THAT YOU WANT TO
DO IT IT'S NOT REQUIRED BUT- I
THINK THAT'S- A REALLY GOOD
MODEL FOR WHITE THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN DO. ANYTHING JANET ALSO%
MENTIONED THAT ILLINOIS I AT-
PASSED A DISCLOSURE BILL AS
WELL BUT I THINK WE'RE- WORKING
WITH THEM AND I THINK THEY'RE
STILL TRYING TO ACT. IT KIND OF
PUT TOGETHER HOW TO PROCEED FOR
NEXT STEPS OKAY AND THEN
ANOTHER QUESTION I HAVE
ACTUALLY ITS PRICE FOR BOTH YOU
AND- THIS ONE IN TERMS OF- I
SAW IN TERMS OF DAILY TALK
ABOUT NEW DIRECTORS AND OF
COURSE WERE ELECTED OFFICE SO
WE KNOW ABOUT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
BEING ELECTED AND THEN RE
ELECTION AND SO FORTH. SO WE
SAY NEW DIRECTORS IS- DOES THAT
EXCLUDE PEOPLE WHO SAID SHE ARE
BEING RE APPOINTED FOR ANOTHER
TERM AND SO FORTH AND THEN I
GUESS THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
AND THAT IS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
DIRECTORS IF YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW
ACTUALLY TURNED OVER IN ANY
TIME SO IN OTHER WORDS IF WE'RE
JUST LOOKING AT NEED. AND
OBVIOUSLY NEW DIRECTORS WHERE
YOU LOOK FOR THE TRENDS. BUT
HOUSE. SLOW HIS IS GOING TO BE
IF THERE'S NOW A LOT TURN YEAH
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH TURNOVER
THERE IS A CORPORATE. NO AS
WELL SO- SO IT CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK TO YOUR DATA RELATED TO
NEW DIRECTORS AND THE PACE AT
WHICH- THE FOR MAINLY LOOKING
NEW DIRECTORS- THAT. THAT YOU
KNOW HOW HOW. WHAT TO WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF BOARDS IF YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO SEE TURN OVER
TO START WITH SO ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE VERY TINY PERCENTAGE
OF. BOARD SEATS SIMILAR LOOKING
AT NEW DIRECTORS. YES I'M HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT NEW APPOINTMENTS.
ARE MADE DURING IT OUT A
CERTAIN PERIOD DOES OUR NEW
APPOINTMENTS NOT NECESSARILY.
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T HAVE A BOARD
SEAT BEFORE WELL WE ARE-
TRACKING NATIONAL DATA- SO FOR
EXAMPLE JUST TO CLARIFY SO WHEN
YOU SAY NEW APPOINTMENTS DOES
COULD BEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THE BOARD BEING APPOINTED FOR
ANOTHER TERM. CORRECT OKAY NO
NO MEANS IT IS- LET'S SAY YOU
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE JANET SHE'S
ALREADY ON ONE WARD IF SHE GETS
NOMINATED TO ANOTHER COURT.
THAT IS GOING ON OKAY SO. NEW
APPOINTMENTS BUT IT COULD BE
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD A POSITION
BEFORE IN ANOTHER SHOULD. IN
THE SAME PERIOD SHE CAN HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED TO TWO BOARDS
AND THAT IS A NEW COURT
APPOINTMENT TO NEW BOARD
APARTMENTS IN NAP HERE YET- NOW
WE ARE LOOKING AT- SOME TRENDS
REGARDING. OUT HOW MANY YEAH
WOMEN IN LATINAS ARE IN WOMEN
OF COLOR ARE BEING APPOINTED AS
WELL AS FIRST TIME DIRECTORS
FIRST TIME DIRECTOR NUMBER IS
AN IMPORTANT ONE TO FOLLOW.
BECAUSE IT'S RAINING- IN THE
PAST. ORDS REALLY PRIORITIZE
ADDING CEO COO CFO IS AND ISN'T
AS MUCH DIVERSITY WITHIN THOSE
FIELDS WE'RE SEEING A TREND IN
OPENING THE APERTURE OF THE
SKILL SET AT BEING ADDED TO THE
BOARD TO OTHER C. SUITE LEVELS
CHIEF HUMAN RESOURCE OFFICERS
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICERS AND
OTHER AS VP LEVEL SO IT HASN'T
COMPLETELY WE WERE TRENDING
THERE I THINK THERE COULD BE A
LOT MORE. MORE INCLUSION. CHECK
IT IS TODAY ARE DEALING WITH
SOME OF THE MOST COMPLEX ISSUES
GIVEN OUR TECHNOLOGY GIVEN
RESCUE GIVEN CYBER THAN WE'VE
EVER HAD I ALWAYS SAY THERE ARE
ALMOST. YEAH GOING TO PROVIDE A
GREAT DEAL OF VALUE IN THE
BOARDROOM. COMPARED TO SOMEONE
WHO IS IN A C. OR FORTY YEARS
AGO I'M JUST GIVING AN EXAMPLE
OF COURSE AND IT WOULD BE
VALUABLE TO BUT THERE IS- SOME
TRAINED TO LOOK AT OTHER- SKILL
SETS ARE WE'VE BEEN ON IN SOME.
THE DATABASE IS NATIONWIDE
WE'RE SEEING- AN INCREASE OF
LATINO APPOINTMENTS IN OTHER
YOU LOOK AT ALL THE STATES. AND
OF THE NEW APPOINTMENTS THIS IS
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS OR TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR- 40%
OF THE APPOINTMENTS FOR LETTING
US. WHICH IS HIGHER THAN IT'S
TRENDING HIGHER AND 43% OR
FIRST TIME DIRECTORS SO THERE'S
SOME. PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED THAT
WHAT ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON BOARDS GETTING. TO
ANOTHER ANOTHER. WE ARE SEEING
A TREND IDENTIFYING FIRST TIME
DIRECTORS. IN TERMS OF OVERALL
TURNOVER EXCEEDS. THERE IS NOT
SOME REPORTS LIKE HEIDRICK AND
STRUGGLES MEASURES MEASURES IS
THAT THEIR SEARCH FOR ALL AND
OTHER SEARCH FORUMS MEASURE.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY APPOINTMENTS
OPENED UP AND TURNED OVER IN A
SINGLE YEAR AND THE AND THEY
BALK AT THE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED OF THE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED IT ENDS UP BEING- YOU
KNOW. PROBABLY IN THE RANGE OF.
THREE HUNDRED FOUR HUNDRED
SEATS OF ALL OF THE THOUSANDS
OF SEATS REPRESENTED BUT I
THINK THOSE TWO REPORTS A FEW
OF THOSE REPORTS WOULD GIVE YOU
A GOOD MEASURE OF HOW MANY
SEATS TURN OVER. IN FACT I
THINK IT'S VERY MUCH ACTUALLY
THIS ONE DID YOU WANT TO
COMMENT AS WELL THE QUESTION.
YES I WANTED TO ADD TO ESTHER'S
RESPONSE I THINK. I SEE A LOOK
A DIFFERENT SIDE OF IT BEING A
CORPORATE DIRECTOR AND-
PARTICIPATING WITH OTHER BOARD
COLLEAGUES AND FORUMS. AND FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW BOARDS
ARE ACTUALLY ADDING SEATS TO.
INCREASE AND HAVE A DIVERSE
CANDIDATE IF THEY DON'T ALREADY
HAVE ONE OR ADD MORE DIVERSE
DIRECTORS. YOU HAVE SEEN THAT
PERSONALLY WITH OF ONE OF. OF
THE BOARD'S ACTUALLY TWO OF THE
BOARDS THAT I'M ON A ADDED A
SEAT AND WE'RE SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING FOR SKILL SET. AS WELL
AS SOMEBODY WITH. A RACIAL
DIVERSITY BACKGROUND. AND IT
GOES BACK TO I THINK THE
COMMENT MADE. EARLIER IN THE
OPENING- LIKE WE KNOW THERE
ARE. VERY HIGHLY QUALIFIED.
PEOPLE OF. OF DIVERSE NATURE.
THAT CAN. SIT ON A BOARD. AND
SO THAT IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE HELP EMPHASIZE BOTH THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ESTHER AND I
WORK WITH THE- ASCEND AS WELL
AS LATINO CORPORATE DIRECTORS
HAVE. SORT OF BORED READY-
OUR SENIOR EXECUTIVES THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR BOARD SERVICE. ALSO
AGAIN I'VE SEEN ADDITIONAL
BOARDS ADDED I'VE SEEN WHERE
COMPANIES THAT ARE GOING PUBLIC
AND NOTE YOU NEED TO HAVE A
BOARD. OF YOU KNOW THEY'RE
PAYING ATTENTION TO LAWS SUCH
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVEN
IF THEY AREN'T IN THE STATE.
AND LOOKING TO HAVE DIVERSE
DIRECTORS AS PART OF THEIR
BOARD MAKE UP. AND ONE FINAL
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THE
PATIENCE OR TEARS- THIS ONE.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE AGGREGATE
DISAGGREGATED DATA BUT IN THE
H. I. COMMUNE DISAGGREGATION IS
NOT IS ALSO ABOUT THE SAGGING
WITHIN THE API CATEGORY RIGHTS
ARE NEAR POINT PACIFIC
ISLANDERS OFTEN GET JUST GET
LUMPED IN. AND DAY OUT I DON'T
THINK THEY'VE DONE IT AND SO
THEY GET LOST IN THAT- WE HAVE
TREMENDOUS DIVERSITY WITH THEIR
API COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW IT'S A
AND INTO MY OPENING REMARKS
ONLY CERTAIN SUBSEGMENTS AND SO
WHEN WE SAY API WE OFTEN GLOSS
THAT OVER BECAUSE ONLY CERTAIN
SUBSEGMENTS. OF OUR COMMUNITY-
ACTUALLY AT LEAST HAVE SOME
REPRESENTATION- MORE ENTRY
LEVEL PROFESSIONAL TECHNICAL
POSITIONS- CAN YOU SPEAK ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIS
AGGREGATING AT LEAST CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE API COMMUNITY AND
FOR OTHER GROUPS MAY HAVE WANT
TO DO THAT AS WELL. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST LUMPING.
EVERYBODY IN LARGE UMBRELLAS.
YES I AGREE I'VE- WITH MY
VOLUNTEER ROLE WITH THE SAND I
STARTED HELPING WORK ON
RESEARCH AND PUBLISHING REPORTS
ON. DIVERSITY WELL I WITHIN
COMPANIES AND THAT WAS YOU KNOW
ALWAYS WHAT WAS SO DIFFICULT IS
THAT WE HAVE ONE CATEGORY FOR
ASIANS WHICH INCLUDES A LOT OF
COMPONENTS INCLUDING. THE SOUTH
ASIAN COMMUNITY. AND SO WE- IN
OUR BOARD DISCLOSURE MAKE UP-
YOU KNOW CONSIDER THAT AS WELL
I THINK IT WILL BE HELPFUL.
BECAUSE IN SOME RESPECTS. I
THINK UP. PEOPLE ESTIMATOR GAS
THAT THERE'S MORE
REPRESENTATION BY BOARD
DIRECTORS THAT ARE SOUTH ASIANS
BECAUSE THEY SEE LARGE
COMPANIES SUCH AS MICROSOFT AND
GOOGLE. YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
WHERE THEY'RE CEOS ARE SOUTH
ASIAN SO I THINK THAT IS A
GREAT POINT SENATOR PAN- IS FAR
AS- REPORTING YOU KNOW EVEN.
MORE INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION BY
ALL RACIAL GROUPS. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BYE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK IT AFTER TEN.
AT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION I THINK WHAT THAT
REALLY IS HIGHLIGHTED FOR ME IS
THAT IT BE IT IT'S NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A DIVERSITY IN
REPRESENTATION. ON OUR BOARDS
BUT ONCE A WE HAVE THAT
REPRESENTATION THAT IT ACTUALLY
HAS AN IMPACT ON THE POLICIES
AND PRACTICES OF THE COMPANIES
THAT PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES
TO DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION PRACTICES THROUGHOUT
THE COMPANY. I'M WONDERING IF
EITHER OF THE PANELISTS HAVE
THAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT OR HAVE BEEN TRACKING.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH- THERE'S
BEEN A SHIFT IN POLICY AND
PRACTICE IN A BROADER DIVERT.
BURGER POLICIES AROUND
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION IN
THE COMPANIES AS THEY ARE ALSO
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF BOARD
MEMBERS. WHO ARE AT FROM AT
FROM DIVERSE. FROM DIVERSE AT
COMMUNITIES. YEAH I CAN I CAN
START IF YOU WOULD LIKE BECAUSE
AGAIN I HAVE A PERSPECTIVE.
SITTING ON FOR COMPANY BOARDS
AS WELL AS INTERACTING WITH A
LOT OF OTHER DIRECTORS FROM. IN
A C. D. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CORPORATE DIRECTORS WOMEN
CORPORATE DIRECTORS XTERRA AND
THERE IS AN INCREASED FOCUS I
THINK WE ALL FOUR OF MY BOARDS
WE DO SPEND TIME AT THE BOARD
MEETINGS ON. DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY AND- VERY MUCH OF
SUPPORTING OUR COMPANIES AND
HELP THEM IN GROWING THAT
PIPELINE YOU KNOW SPECIFICALLY
FOR MY TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES YOU
KNOW THERE IS. A LACK OF- BLACK
AND LATINOS ESPECIALLY IN THE
TECHNICAL AREAS AND SO.
COMPANIES ARE LOOKING AT
PROGRAMS WORKING ACTUALLY WITH
OTHER COMPANIES AS TO HOW DO WE
ATTRACT MORE PEOPLE INTO STEM A
SPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR. SO
AGAIN I THINK COMPANIES THAT
HAVE A STRONG CULTURE TO- YOU
KNOW DEVELOP A WORK FORCE NOT
JUST AT THE BOARD LEVEL ARE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN B.
AND HELP. US CONTINUE TO BUILD
A PIPELINE OF SENIOR LEVEL
PEOPLE THAT CAN BE FUTURE BOARD
DIRECTORS. I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
WEIGH IN ARE YOU DON'T EAT IT
LARGE INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS
AND PENSION FUNDS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS AREA- IS
JANET MENTIONED WE CHEN I BOTH
SERVE ON THE BOARD. OF THE 30%
COALITION AND IT BRINGS
TOGETHER A LOT OF THE LARGE
INVESTORS AND PENSION FUNDS NO
INCLUDING CASTERS AND NEW YORK
STATE CMMONS AND ALL OF THEM
WHO HAVE BEEN COALESCING. ARE
TOO BRIGHT TO COMPANIES AND
LEVERAGING. OUR SHAREHOLDER
RESOLUTIONS AND THE PROXY
VOTING TO- ADVOCATE. FOR MORE
ADVANCEMENT AND BOARD DIVERSITY
SO IT WILL BE POSSIBLE IN THE
SHAREHOLDER RESOLUTION AND IF.
YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF YEARS OF
TALKING TO THE COMPANY OF THEIR
NOT SEEING RESULTS THEY WILL
REQUIRE. REQUESTED NO VOTE FOR
THE CHAIR OF THE NOMINATING
COMMITTEE OR THE FULL BORDER
JUST CHANGE IN THE BOARD
COMPOSITION SO IT'S BEEN
HELPFUL TO SEE INVESTORS
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
SHAREHOLDERS OF THESE COMPANIES
AND THEY KNOW. THAT MORE.
DIVERSE VOICES AND THE SKIT
STRONG SKILL SETS AROUND THE
TABLE ARE GONNA LEAD TO BETTER
RESULTS- THE OTHER'S TRENDS
WITH- THE INVESTORS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND HEARING IS THAT
INVESTORS ARE ALSO. CALLING ON
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THEIR
IASI DATA AND THE WORKFORCE
DATA ACROSS. THE BOARD AND
AGAIN FROM WHEN YOU'RE SITTING
AT THE STATE AS A SHAREHOLDER
THE BOARD IS ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS. THAT'S WHEN YOU
KNOW THERE ARE ALSO PAYING
ATTENTION I THINK- YOU KNOW
CALLING FOR DISCLOSURE OF. THE
THEIR WORK FIRST DATA PLUS THE
BOARD DATA IT WOULD HELP IN ALL
OF THIS AND TRACKING AGAIN BACK
TO WHAT GETS MEASURED GETS
RESULTS- YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE
A BIG HELP ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
CERTAINLY- HAVING THE
SHAREHOLDERS ADVOCATE AS WELL
HAS BEEN A GOOD TREND SO WHAT
WE'RE TELLING COMPANIES IS LIKE
YOU NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
BECAUSE YOUR FIRST FOUR HOLDERS
ARE YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING
FROM THEM. LAST MARCH- PROXY
AND- LIGHT I ASSESS THE
INSTITUTIONAL SHAREHOLDER
SERVICES THE ADVICE ALL
SHAREHOLDERS FOR HOW THEY CAN
VOTE ON DIFFERENT JOB. PROXY
VOTING AND THEY'RE ALSO WRITING
TO COMPANIES ABOUT A- LACK OF
RACE ETHNICITY ON THE BOARD-
AND SAYING. KIND OF WARNING
THEM HEY WE'RE GONNA RECOMMEND
ALONG WITH GIVE SHAREHOLDERS A
NO VOTE ON CERTAIN PERFORMANCE
IT FOR NOT SEEING MORE
DISCLOSURE MORE DIVERSITY IN
THE BOARDROOM AND DISCLOSURE OF
THE WORK FORCE- DEMOGRAPHICS.
THANK YOU- I DO WANT TO. JOIN
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND SHOW
APPRECIATION FOR BOTH OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS IN THE DEPTHS. OF
THE SUBJECT AND HOW YOU OF SORT
OF UNPACKED SOME OF THIS FOR US
AND AS YOU CAN SEE. WE PROBABLY
COULD HAVE HAD THE HEARING JUST
ON THE TWO OF YOUR
PRESENTATION- BUT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TRANSITION TO THE TO
THE NXT PANEL BUT IN DOING SO-
JUST A ONE WORD A ONE WORD
RESPONSE YES OR NO- WHEN S. B.
BY A TWENTY EIGHT. WHAT A
TWENTY SIX AND NINE AND AB NINE
THREE NINE. AT THE ONSET OF
THOSE BILLS WHEN THEY WERE
BEING PRESENTED IN WORKING
THROUGH THE PROCESS THERE IS A
LOT OF THOSE WHO CHOSE TO
OPPOSE THE BILLS. SAID THAT IT
WAS GOING TO DRIVE BUSINESSES
OUT OF CALIFORNIA. I'M SORT OF
READING FROM YOUR PRESENTATIONS
IN YOUR NUMBERS THE THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING BUT IF YOU CAN JUST
GIVE A- ONE WORD. IS THAT THOSE
WORST FEARS. PLANED OUT IT IS
NOT HAPPENING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN BECAUSE THEY'RE ALSO
HEARING FROM NEAR THE SEC
APPROVED NASDAQ'S RESPONSE AND
I'M JUST GONNA HAVE JUST VERY
QUICKLY SHARE THAT SUPPLY IS
NOT THE ISSUE THEY KEEP SAYING
WELL WE CAN'T FIND QUALIFIED
THIS OR THAT OUR ORGANIZATIONS
OUR ORGANIZATION IS A RESOURCE
TO TAP QUALIFY THE TEAM KNOWS
IT EVERY INDUSTRY AND SO WE'RE
HERE TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
LET'S NOT LET THEM HAVE THE
EXCUSE THAT THEY CAN'T FIND THE
TALENT THERE IS TALENT. AND CAN
JUST QUICKLY TO ADD ON TO
ESTHER'S COMMENT YEAH I AGREE
NO IT'S NOT DRIVING COMPANIES
AWAY I JUST GAVE A GREAT
ILLUSTRATION OF. LUCID WHO IS
CONTINUING TO GROW AND ADD
PEOPLE AND PURPOSELY- HAVE KEPT
THEIR HEADQUARTERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW
STARTED THEIR BOARD WITH THREE
PEOPLE THAT TO HELP IT MEET
THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY SIX AND AB
NINE SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU I'LL
TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
HOLINESS AND PANEL TO. THANK
YOU TO THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
OUR SPEAKERS AND PANEL ONE FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE BALLING US
REMOTELY ONE REMAIN THE ABOUT
THE HASHTAGS AB NINE SEVEN NINE
CORPORATE CITY AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL THAT WE COULD CONTINUE
TO TRACK THIS CONVERSATION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA OUT THERE DO
APPRECIATE THAT FOR A SECOND
PANEL WILL DISCUSS BEVERAGE THE
FIND THE PUBLIC SECTOR. HIS
PANEL FOCUS ON INCREASING
OUTREACH TO UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES FOR CONTRACTING AND
CREATING ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE
NOT THAT NOT ONLY EMBRACE
DIVERSITY BUT ALSO ACTIVELY
REDUCE BARRIERS TO UPWARD
MOBILITY. OUR FIRST PANELIST IS
ANGELA SHALL ANGELES SHALL WAS
APPOINTED DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE PROCUREMENT DIVISION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND CHIEF PROCUREMENT OFFICER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON
NOVEMBER FIRST TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. IN YOUR CURRENT ROLE
ANGELES RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING THE STATE'S PURCHASE
OF GOODS AND SERVICES. VITAL TO
STATE DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS
THAT SERVE THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS INCLUDES
DEVELOPING AND A WARNING
STATEWIDE LEVERAGE PROCUREMENT
AGREEMENTS DELEGATING
PURCHASING AUTHORITY DEVELOPING
STATEWIDE POLICY AND TRAINING
IDENTIFYING SUSTAINABLE
PROCUREMENT METHODS AND
PRODUCTS AND CERTIFYING SMALL
AND DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE. THANK YOU MICHELLE
FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY YOU MAY
PROCEED. AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR
INVITING DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES TO SPEAK ON DIVERSITY
IN SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT
DURING TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING TOWARD GREATER
DIVERSITY IN BOTH THE SMALL
BUSINESS AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
THOSE VENDORS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY CERTIFIED BUT WHO
HAVE INTEREST IN CONTRACTING
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RELATED TO OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS A LONG
ESTABLISHED OFFICE OF SMALL AND-DISTANT BUSINESS SERVICES THAT
FOCUSES ON CERTIFICATION OF
THESE BUSINESSES AND OUT REACH
ON STATE CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SUCH AS ETHNIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE PROCUREMENT AND
TRAINING ASSISTANCE CENTERS
PUBLIC AGENCY CONSORTIUMS
VETERAN BUSINESS CENTERS AND
THE WESTERN REGIONAL MINORITY
SUPPLIER DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ESTABLISHED
OVER THIRTY OF THESE STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS AND PROVIDES
FUNDING ANNUALLY SPECIFICALLY
FOR OUTREACH EVENTS AND MEDIA
COMMUNICATIONS THAT INCORPORATE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO GET
CERTIFIED AND HOW TO COMPETE
FOR STATE CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT ATTENDED A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO EVENTS WITH
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY SEVEN
HUNDRED IN ATTENDANCE THESE
INCLUDED WORKSHOPS WEBINARS
BUSINESS MATCH MAKING AND
PANELS THAT PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INTERESTED
BUSINESSES TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
STATE OPPORTUNITIES. DGS WILL
BE PRESENTING ON STATE
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES
ALONGSIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AT NEXT WEEK'S
INSURANCE DIVERSITY SUMMIT. IN
ADDITION TO ITS OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES WITH ITS STRATEGIC
PARTNERS SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER AND THE
NATIONAL LATINO WOMEN BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS OWNERS DGS ALSO WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH BUSINESSES THAT
NEED ASSISTANCE UNDERSTANDING
STATE CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS
AND WE DO THIS THROUGH STAFF
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE INTERPRETER SERVICES.
AS WELL AS USE OF A STATE WIDE
CONTRACT FOR THIS SPECIFIC
SERVICE TRANSLATING DOCUMENTS
INTO OTHER LANGUAGES SUCH AS
SPANISH. UP HOSTING OUR ONLINE
TRAINING VIDEOS IN OTHER
LANGUAGES SUCH AS SPANISH ON
RGS WEBSITE. AND OFFERING
DIRECT ONE ON ONE COUNSELING TO
BUSINESSES ON NAVIGATING STATE
PROCESSES. IN AN EFFORT TO
UNDERSTAND OUR OUTREACH
EFFECTIVENESS AND- IN
UNDERSERVED AND DISADVANTAGED
AREAS AND INFORM OUR STRATEGIES
MOVING FORWARD WE'VE RECENTLY
DEVELOPED WHAT WE'RE CALLING
THE CAL SOCKS TOOL THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA SB DVP ATLAS'S. THAT
OVERLAYS ARE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PLUS CERTIFIED FIRMS
GIS LOCATION ALONG WITH THEIR
PROCUREMENT DOLLARS USING THE
CAL EPA DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CAL ENVIRO SCREEN
MAPPING TOOL. CALAVERAS IN
SKEWS ME CAL ENVIRO SCREEN USES
DOT C. O. ECONOMIC FACTORS
FACTORS- FOR EXAMPLE HIGH
POVERTY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
REALISTIC ISOLATION SEVERE
HOUSING BURDEN LOW EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT ALONG WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
FACTORS IN DETERMINING IF A
COMMUNITY IS DISADVANTAGED SO
WERE USING THAT. PARTICULAR
DEFINITION. THIS IS AN IDEAL
TOOL TO INTEGRATE WITH OUR
CERTIFICATION AND OUTREACH DATA
GIVEN OUR LIMITATIONS DUE TO
PROP TWO OH NINE SO WHILE IT
DOESN'T EXPLICITLY INCLUDE RACE
AND ETHNICITY INDICATORS THE
TOOL DOES COME WITH A
COMPLIMENTARY RACE ETHNICITY
AND AGE ANALYSIS. CONCLUDING
THAT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE
PREDOMINANTLY OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR SO USING THE CALLOUS THAT
MAP WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE
WHERE WE NEED TO INTENSIFY OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS AND SEEK
ADDITIONAL STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS TO ENSURE WE REACH
OUT. IN THOSE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES. IN TWENTY TWENTY
DGS ALSO BEGAN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH ITS AGENCY GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS TO ESTABLISH A
MINORITY FOCUSED TASK FORCE
THAT INCLUDES MINORITY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND ETHNIC
CHAMBERS TO IDENTIFY REAL TIME
ISSUES IMPACTING THESE
BUSINESSES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER THE GROUP HAS EXPANDED
AND MEETS MONTHLY TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING FEEDBACK ON THE NEEDS
OF MINORITY SMALL BUSINESSES.
ONE PRACTICAL EXAMPLE OF THIS
INITIATIVE- WASN'T PPD CONTRACT
THAT WAS A STATEMENT CONTRACT
ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH THE PARTNERS ON
THIS TASK GROUP- THAT ALLOWED
US TO AWARD. ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTS TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
AS WELL AS DISADVANTAGED I'M
SORRY- DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES- SO THIS
IS THIS WAS A GREAT EFFORT AND
WE ATTRIBUTE OUR SUCCESS BACK
TO THE ASSISTANCE OF THE-
MINORITY FOCUSED TASK GROUP.
RELATED TO OUR DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS THE STATE DOES
COLLECTED VOLUNTARILY SUBMITTED
DATA ON THE ETHNICITY RACE
GENDER AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF BUSINESS OWNERS. TO DATE THE
RESPONSE RATE IS VERY LIMITED
BUT WE AREN'T WORKING ON WAYS
TO INCREASE IT. ACCORDING TO
PARTNERS ARE REQUIRED TO SEND A
VOLUNTARY STATISTICAL DATA
SHEET EVERY BUSINESS OWNER WHO
WAS AWARDED A STATE CONTRACT.
DEPARTMENTS CONTINUE TO REPORT
THAT MANY FORMS ARE NOT
RETURNED BY BUSINESS OWNERS
WITH ONLY 40% OF THE
DEPARTMENTS HAVING DATA TO
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY WHICH WAS A SLIGHT
DECREASE WHEN COMPARED TO THE
PRIOR YEAR. AGAIN THIS IS
VOLUNTARY INFORMATION TO HELP
FACILITATE BETTER REPORTING OF
THIS INFORMATION DGS IS
EMBARKING ON AN EFFORT TO
DEVELOP AN ONLINE A VOLUNTARY
ETHNICITY GENDER AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION SURVEY USING THEIR
FISCAL SYSTEM FOR OWNERS OF
BUSINESSES THAT ARE CONTRACTING
WITH THE STATE. OUR HOPE IS
THAT THE ONLINE SURVEY PORTAL
WILL BE. MORE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
FOR BUSINESSES AND IT WILL
PRESERVE THE CONFIDENTIALITY
COP CONFIDENTIALITY OF
RESPONSES AND THEN ALSO AGAIN
REMOVE ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS FROM
REPORTING ON THIS INFORMATION.
DGS USES THE LIMITED
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
REPORT TO ENSURE CONTINUED OUT
REACHED ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING THE GROUPS
IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT. DGS
DOES NOT CURRENTLY COLLECT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON SMALL
BUSINESS OR DVB OWNERS THROUGH
ITS CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS ONLY
THROUGH THE VOLUNTARY REPORTING
PROCESS WHICH IS AGAIN TIED TO
CONTRACT AWARDS. WE ARE
CONSIDERING ALLOWING STATE
VENDORS TO VOLUNTARILY PROVIDE
DEMOGRAPHIC. BOARDING IN BOTH
THEIR VENDOR ANSWER
CERTIFICATION PROFILES THAT ARE
CONTAINED WITHIN THE STATE'S
TO VOLUNTARY REPORTING. UP WITH
RESPECT TO THE DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM- I
CAN'T ANSWER SOME BASIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CALTRANS
DVD PROGRAM BUT IT IS SPECIFIC
TO FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION
DOLLARS- IF THE COMMITTEE
DESIRES- THE DVD PROGRAM IS
BASED ON SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE STATUS WITH SIX
CATEGORIES CONSIDERED UNDER
THAT- SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
AND IT INCLUDES WOMEN AGAIN
THIS IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT
IS NOT A STATE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. AND IT IS ONLY USED ON
CONTRACTS THAT HAVE FEDERAL
FUNDING TIED TO THEM. FINALLY
RELATED TO THE STATE'S SMALL
BUSINESS AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAMS IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY THE STATE CHIEF JUSTICE
UNDER ITS 25% SMALL BUSINESS
SCHOOL AT TWENTY THREE POINT
SEVEN PERCENT. BUT WE CHEAP
THREE POINT 87% AGAINST THE 3%
DVB EAGLE WILDFIRE AND COVERT
SUPPORT OPERATIONS NECESSITATED
A LARGE GROWTH IN EMERGENCY
SPEND DOLLARS IN WHICH SMALL
BUSINESSES AND DVDS HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD LIMITED
PARTICIPATION. WITH ONE OF THE
EMERGENCY SPEND DOLLARS THE
STATE WOULD HAVE ACHIEVED
THIRTY SIX POINT 27% FOR SMALL
BUSINESS AND FIVE POINT 54%
FOURTEEN VP. SO TO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE FIRMS
TO PARTICIPATE IN EMERGENCY
PROCUREMENTS TODAY DGS IS
LAUNCHED LAUNCHING AN ONLINE
EVE URGENCY REGISTRY TOOL THAT
WILL ALLOW SMALL BUSINESS AND
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE FIRMS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THEIR SPECIFIC
CAPACITY. TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES. OUR STATE BUYERS
WILL USE THIS TOOL TO IDENTIFY
AVAILABLE FIRMS TO CONNECT WITH
FOR CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES
AGAINST SPECIFIC TO THAT
EMERGENCY NEED. BERMAN BELIEVES
THE USE OF THIS TOOL WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO INCREASE THE DEBT
PERSONALLY BUSINESSES USE
DURING EMERGENCY OPERATIONS AND
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
BUSINESSES TO EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH STATE CONTRACTING
PROCESSES. THAT ULTIMATELY
ALLOWS THEM TO ENHANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPETE ON FUTURE
NON EMERGENCY PROCUREMENTS. AS
OF SEPTEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE UC AND DGS HAVE
ENTERED INTO A RECIPROCITY
AGREEMENT WHERE THE UC WILL
ACCEPT THE GSS S. B. A D. V. B.
E. CERTIFICATIONS AS PART OF
THE UC SMALL BUSINESS FIRST
PROGRAM. DGS RECIPROCITY
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UC
FORMALIZES THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE UC PROGRAMS BENEFITS TO OUR
ESPYS AND DVB. THIS PARTNERSHIP
STREAMLINES THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS FOR THESE BUSINESSES
AND PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES WITH
THE GOAL OF INCREASED DOLLARS
GOING TOWARD CERTIFIED FARMS.
DGS WILL MARKET THIS ADDITIONAL
ATTRACTING OPPORTUNITY TO ITS
STRATEGIC PARTNERS AS WELL AS
DURING ALL OF ITS OUTREACH
EVENTS SO THAT THE ATTENDEES
ARE AWARE OF THIS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. AND LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ESTABLISHED A
NEW EXECUTIVE LEVEL POSITION
WITHIN THE PROCUREMENT DIVISION
TITLE THE STATE WIDE SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAM MANAGER WHO
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE POLICY
STRATEGIES AIMED AT IMPROVING
EQUITY AND ACHIEVING GREATER
DIVERSITY IN THE SUPPLY STATE
SUPPLIER BASE. THESE ARE JUST
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE ACTIVITIES
THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
ENGAGING IN TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S BUSINESS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND DIVERSITY THROUGH
PROCUREMENT OPERATIONS AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA HOLD OFF-
FOR QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL. NEXT WE HAVE. ATRIA
JENKINS JONES CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
ON AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
APPOINTED ADRIAN JENKINS JONES
AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES. AND WAS REAPPOINTED
BY GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. JENKINS JONES
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS CHIEF OF
THE SELECTION DIVISION WHICH
OVERSAW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CIVIL SERVICE EXAMINATION
PROCESS FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
STATE DEPARTMENTS. BEFORE
JOINING KYLE H. R. JENKINS
JONES SERVED IN SEVERAL
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FROM 1-991-220-0015
INCLUDING CHIEF OF HUMAN
RESOURCES. ASSOCIATE PERSONNEL
ANALYST EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT
CHIEF OF RECRUITMENT AND
SELECTION ASSISTANT PERSONNEL
IDALUS THAT SERVICE ANALYST AND
EXAMINATION TECHNICIAN THANK
YOU FOR MAKING TIME TO THEN YOU
MAY PROCEED. HEARING GREETINGS
SHARE GARCIA HOLDEN IN OP FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU ON THE BEHALF OF
CALLING CHAR TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CORPORATE BOARD IN
CALIFORNIA'S ADVERSITY OR FOR
STAFFERS CITY KALINJAR STRIVES
TO EMPLOY A WORKFORCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND MARKETS
ITS DIVERSE POPULATION. DURING
GOVERNESSES JUNIOR HE CONVENE
MEETINGS FOR EXECUTIVE BRANCH
LEADERS TO DISCUSS HOW THE
STATE EMPLOYER CAN ACHIEVE THE
STATE WORKPLACE THAT IS DIVERSE
EQUITABLE HE REFLECTS THE
VALUES OF CALIFORNIANS WILL
CALL THIS INITIATIVE IS KNOWN
AS CALIFORNIA LEADS FROM THESE
MEETINGS TASK FORCE WORKS
DAMPENS TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ADDRESS PAY EQUITY AND THE
ELEVATION OF PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES THAT. IMPACT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. THOSE TWO
WRECKED WILL BE FINALIZED IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. KALINJAR
IS FULLY EQUIPPED TO MEET
STATEWIDE HUMAN RESOURCES NEEDS
IN SOME AREAS IN OTHER AREAS
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS FURTHER
SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAMS AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO FULLY
ACHIEVE DESIRED OUTCOMES. FOR
THIS REASON KALINJAR IS
EXPLORING IDEAS TO MEET THE
GOALS OF THE CALIFORNIA LEADS
INITIATIVES. ALLEN CHAU WAS
ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS THE FOLLOWING WORK FOR
STAFF VERY CITY TEENS GROUP IN
AND RETAINING A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE IMPORTANCE OF
COLLECTING DEMOGRAPHIC DATA.
CREATING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION POLICY SPECIFICALLY
IN REGARDS TO RACIAL AND GENDER
IDENTITY. ON THE WAGE GAP.
BEFORE I SPEAK OF A SPECIFIC
TOPICS I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL CONTEXT BASED
ON THE MOST RECENT POPULATION
DATA WHICH WAS CALCULATED USING
DATA FROM THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY ONE YEAR
ESTIMATES COMPARISON PROFILES.
FOR THE CALENDAR YEARS. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
POPULATION INCREASE FROM 38%
239% FROM. TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN WHILE THE LATINO
POPULATION FOR CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INCREASE FROM TWENTY
TWO PERCENT. 28% FOR THE SAME
YEARS. LIKEWISE THE ASIAN
POPULATION INCREASED FROM 13%
215% WHEN THE ASIAN STATE CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INCREASED
FROM FIFTEEN PERCENT. 20% THE
STATE'S BLACK POPULATION REMAIN
THE SAME AT SIX PER TO SET FOR
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN HOWEVER THE POPULATION
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY FOR
STATE CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
DECREASED FROM 11% 29% LIKEWISE
THERE WAS A DECREASE IN THE
STATE WHITE POPULATION FROM 40%
236% AS WELL AS IN THE WHITE
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
POPULATION FROM FORTY EIGHT
PERCENT. 44% THE POPULATION
IDENTIFIED AS OTHER REMAIN THE
SAME AT 4% FOR TWENTY TEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK INCREASED
ONLY BY ONE PERCENT. FOR STATE
SALES SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
RECRUITING AND RETAINING A
DIVERSE WORK FORCE BASED ON THE
POPULATION DATA THERE HAS BEEN
A SLIGHT INCREASE IN DIVERSITY
IN THE STATE'S POPULATION AS
WELL AS IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEE POPULATION. KALINJAR
RECOGNIZES THAT DIVERSITY IS AN
INTEGRAL PART IN TODAY'S
WORKPLACE CULTURE AND THAT
THERE IS A GROWING SIGNIFICANCE
PLACED ON CREATING DIVERSE
ENVIRONMENTS THAT INCLUDES IN
CONSIDERATION OF RACE ETHNICITY
AGE GENDER DISABILITY VETERAN
STATUS. I SURE OF A DIVERSE
WORKPLACE THAT IS FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION FOR ALL IS
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A MODEL
IN SLOW HERE THE PEOPLE THAT IT
SERVES. KALINJAR IS CURRENTLY
EXPLORING NEW IDEAS TO SUPPORT
IMPROVED HIRING PRACTICES AND
PROCESSES. FOR EXAMPLE
INCORPORATING AN ANONYMOUS
ANONYMOUS OR BLIND HIRING
INITIATIVE WHERE CANDIDATES
APPLICATIONS PROTECTED
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS HIDDEN FROM
THE RESPECTIVE SELECTION IN
HIRING PATTERNS. IT IS OUR HOPE
THAT BY IMPLEMENTING THIS
INITIATIVE WE LESSEN THE-
CONSCIOUS BIAS INHERENT IN THE
HIRING PROCESS. IN ADDITION WE
CONTINUE TO TRAIN AND EDUCATE
LEADERSHIP AND WORKFORCE ON HOW
TO RECOGNIZE UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
IN THEMSELVES IN THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND HOW TO
MITIGATE IT AS WELL AS OTHER
FORMS OF BIAS. THIS CURRICULUM
IS MANDATORY FOR ALL NEW TO
ROLL SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS.
THERE OF COURSE IS ALSO
AVAILABLE TO THE GENERAL
WORKFORCE AND KALINJAR IS
CONTINUOUSLY VETTING NEW
COURSES TO ADD TO THE TRAINING
CARILLO. COLLECTING KIDDING
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS VERY
IMPORTANT ONE OF KELLY GEORGE
GRANULOSA CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE IS TO REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE'S
RESIDENTS WE SIR. KALINJAR
BELIEVES WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS
BY CONTINUING TO MONITOR THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE AND LEVERAGE THAT
DATA TO MAKE TARGETED DATA
DRIVEN THE CREW RECOMMENDATIONS
AND DECISIONS. CONSISTENTLY
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA MAINTAINING IT
AND CREATING DASHBOARDS FOR
USERS WILL FURTHER BRING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO THOSE EFFORTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT OUR SUCCESS
WILL BE SEEN WHEN THE DATA MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THAT HAVE
PERSONALLY OF THE RESIDENTS OF
THE STATE. ADDITIONALLY
KALINJAR. WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION HAS WORKED WITH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO
PRODUCE ONE DEMAND MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION RETRIEVAL SYSTEM
RECORDS SO THAT DEPARTMENTS CAN
MORE EASILY MORE REGULARLY AND
MORE ACCURATELY DRAW THEIR OWN
WORKFORCE DATA TO ANALYZE THEIR
DEPARTMENTS DEMOGRAPHICS RACE
ETHNICITY GENDER DISABILITY AGE
DATA AND GAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL WORK FORCE MAKE UP.
ROOT MEAN OPPORTUNITIES AND
RISKS THIS INFORMATION WILL
ALSO SERVE TO GUIDE THEIR
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
AS WELL AS OTHER IMPORTANT
WORKFORCE PLANNING FACTORS SUCH
AS CAREER DEVELOPMENT RETENTION
AND TURNOVER AS WELL AS
SUCCESSION PLANNING MANAGEMENT.
NEW DEMOGRAPHIC DATA COLLECTION
CATEGORIES SUCH AS GENDER
IDENTITY AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND OTHERS CURRENTLY DO NOT
EXIST WITHIN STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND A MECHANISM FOR COLLECTING
SUCH DATA IS NEEDED. ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMMING A STATE DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEMS WILL BE AN
EXTENSIVE PROJECT REQUIRING
RESOURCES AND SIGNIFICANT TIME.
CREATING DIVERSE INCLUSION
POLICIES. THE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY IS TO BE AFFORDED
TO ALL APPLICANTS AND EMPLOYEES
WITHOUT REGARD TO AGE ANCESTRY
COLOR DISABILITY MENTAL OR
PHYSICAL ENGAGING IN A
PROTECTED ACTIVITY GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY OR EXPRESSION
GENETIC INFORMATION. MARITAL
STATUS MEDICAL CONDITION
MILITARY VETERAN STATUS
NATIONAL ORIGIN POLITICAL
AFFILIATION HI MISSY RACE
RELIGION SEX SEXUAL ORIENTATION
KALINJAR IS OFFICES OVER RIGHTS
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON THE ROLL.
OUT TO ALL STATE DEPARTMENTS IN
ANNUALLY RECEIVES EACH
DEPARTMENT'S WORKFORCE ANALYSIS
AND ACTION PLANS TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE UNDER REPRESENTATION.
EACH STATE AGENCY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
NONDISCRIMINATION POLICIES
PROCEDURES AND PRACTICES AND
ENSURING THEY ARE INTEGRATED
INTO EVERY ASPECT OF EMPLOYING-
POINTING POWER OF EACH AGENCY
IS REQUIRED TO APPOINT THE
MANAGERIAL LEVEL IN E. O.
OFFICER WHOSE PRIMARY ROLE IS
TO OBJECTIVELY MONITOR AND
ASSESS AGENCY PERSONNEL
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. WELCOME
ME INTO MINISTRY CHANGES TO
PREVENT DISCRIMINATION AND TO
CONTINUOUSLY FACILITATE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY THESE
POSITIONS ARE REQUIRED BY
GOVERNMENT CO TO REPORT.
CORRECTLY TO THE DIRECTOR OF
EACH STATE DEPARTMENT. THE WAGE
GAP KALINJAR IS STATUTORILY
OBLIGATED TO REQUIRE
DEPARTMENTS TO UPHOLD THE
STATE'S MERIT BASED HIRING
PRINCIPLES. STATE SALARY RANGES
ARE SET BY DUKE'S BASE SALARY
ANALYSIS THAT ARE BLIND TO
GENDER THE GENDER PAY GAP IS
THE SALARIES BETWEEN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE FEMALE AND MALE
WORKERS. ANNUALLY THE MEDIAN
SALARY OF MALE EMPLOYEES IS
COMPARED TO THE MEDIAN SALARY A
FEMALE EMPLOYEE. THIS DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE IS CONVERTED TO A
PERCENTAGE DIFFERENCE OF THE
FEMALE LEAD TO THE MAIL ME.
HISTORICALLY AND PRESENTLY
GENDER BASED OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION CONTRIBUTES TO THE
PAY GAP BECAUSE FEMALE
DOMINATED WORK PAYS LESS
OVERALL THAN MALE DOMINATED
WORK. THE TYPE OF WORK WOMEN
PERFORM DETERMINES YOUR SALARY
LEVEL INFLUENCES THE GENDER PAY
GAP. ALL THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE GENDER PAY GAP FOR FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES IN CIVIL SERVICE
WAS IT 17% THIS IS A DECREASE
FROM THE TWENTY SIXTEEN GENDER
PAY GAP OF NINETEEN POINT 5%
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN ANNUAL
CENSUS OF THE EMPLOYEES IN
STATE CIVIL SERVICE SHOWS THAT
NEED MADE UP 50% OR MORE OF ALL
SALARY RANGES ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE RANGE
WITH THE HIGHEST PROPORTION OF
NEED SIXTY FIVE POINT 6% WAS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. WOMEN MADE A 50% OR
MORE OF ALLTHE SALARY RANGES
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
ALLOW. THE FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR IN ABOVE RANGE CONTAINS
THE HIGHEST. OR SHOULD OF WOMEN
AT FIFTY EIGHT POINT 1% THE
MEDIAN EARNINGS OF WOMEN
WORKING IN CIVIL SERVICE WORK
83% OF THE MEDIAN EARNINGS OF
MEN WORKING IN CIVIL SERVICE.
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL SERVICE
GENDER PAY GAP WAS LOWER THAN
THE NATIONAL LABOR FORCE FIGURE
OF NINETEEN POINT 3% AS
RECORDED BY THE UNITED STATES
CENSUS BUREAU IN THEIR AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY DATA OUT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. KALINJAR IS
WORKING ON A NEW APPROACH TO
ANALYZING THE STATE'S JUNIOR
AND WAGE DATA. IN ADDITION TO
USUAL COMPARISON OF MEDIAN
MONTHLY PAY BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN. A MORE DETAILED ANALYSIS
BY BARGAINING YOU. OCCUPATIONAL
LEVEL IN CLASSIFICATION LEVEL
WAS CONDUCTED. THE NEW APPROACH
ALLOWS THE STATE TO DRAW
CONCLUSIONS AND MAKE TARGETED
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT MAY BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL IN MARY THE PAY
GAP OVER TIME. IN CLOSING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY TO
DISCUSS COUNTY CHOICE KERN IN
PERSPECTIVE EFFORTS ON
WORKFORCE CENTERS TODAY AS YOU
CAN SEE KALINJAR IS WORKING ON
DIFFERENT FRONTS TO ENSURE THAT
STATE WORKFORCE WITH SLACKS AND
DIVERSE CITY IN THE STATE. THIS
IS ALWAYS MORE THAT THE STATE
CAN DEAR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR IDEAS AND YOUR INPUT ON
THESE EFFORTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- NEXT MS JENKINS- THANK YOU
AND WE WILL ASK QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF THE PANEL WE HAVE A
FEW MORE SPEAKERS. NEXUS FOR
REYES WHO DART MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF GLOBAL EQUALITY
INITIATIVES FOUR OUT OF FOUR
OUT LEADERSHIP IN HIS CAPACITY
LEVERAGES THE POWER ABOUT
LEADERSHIP MEMBER COMPANIES FOR
SOCIAL CHANGE GLOBALLY HE ALSO
LEADS QUORUM AN INITIATIVE TO
INCREASE REPRESENTATION OF
LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE ON CORPORATE
BOARDS. REESE IS A MEMBER OF
LORI L. GLOBAL DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION ADVISORY BOARD. FOR
BREEZE ARE HOW THE ART WAS
PREVIOUSLY HUMAN RIGHTS OFFICER
AT THE UNITED NATIONS IN NEW
YORK FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY. REWARD THEM
FREE ANY QUAL AND UNPRECEDENTED
UNITED NATIONS CAMPAIGN FOR
LGBTQ PLUS EQUALITY. HE CO
AUTHORED AND LED THE UNITED
NATIONS GLOBAL LGBTQ PLUS
STANDARDS OF CONDUCT FOR
BUSINESS. THE LARGEST CORPORATE
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
INITIATIVE IN THE LGBTQ PLUS
ISSUES IN THE WORLD. FROM
200-012-2000 SIXTEEN FOR BREES
WITH SENIOR COUNTRY OFFICER AT
THE WORLD BANK. AT THE BANK YOU
AUTHORED ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ANALYSIS ANALYSIS OF YEMEN-
BECAUSE THEN. I JUST KIND AND
TUNISIA AND PROVIDING AID AND
PROVIDED THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. GEN
THE WILL DEVELOPMENT REPORT AND
THE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN COMPLEX
SECURITY. AND DEVELOPMENT R. D.
THANK YOU MISTER WHO DART FOR
SHARING YOUR EXPERTISE AND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CITY YOU MAY
PROCEED. VIEW OF THE WORLD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I FROM YOU
MORE MEMBER OR DONE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GASSED UP OR
WIND COMING MEANING THESE
COMMITTEE- I UNFORTUNATELY I
COULDN'T I COULDN'T PRETEND
THAT YOU CAN HEAR FROM MY
ACCENT LIKE MY FRIEND IT'S TELL
YOU THEIR ODDS OF THEM NEED TO
YOU'VE- FROM. BUT I AM DID YOU
NEED TO YOU'RE- A GOOD FRIEND
TO THE STATE. AND BEFORE I
STOPPED THINKING ABOUT PUBLIC
CONTRACTING BECAUSE THAT THAT
THE TOPIC OF THESE. OF THESE
FIFTY BONTA. I WANTED TO- I CAN
ALLEGE ENJOYING MY UP MY
COLLEAGUES IF DIAGHILEV. AND
JANET WOUND. IN THINKING-
CALIFORNIA AWFUL LAST SEEN AB
NINE SEVEN NINE. ON-
REPRESENTATION OF MIND IN THE
BOARDROOM. I WOULD MENTION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING IT
DOESN'T GIGANTIC IMPACT NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ON YOUR
ENTIRE WORLD. I MEAN **** EVEN
THOUGH THE NASDAQ PROPOSAL TO
YOU THAT YOU THE MOST ABUSE
DEVELOPMENT- LATELY. I'VE IF
MENTIONED DAVID SO GIVE THAT
PASSED CONGRESS AND NOW IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM THE FIT THE
FINANCIAL CONDUCT AUTHORITY
EITHER STILL CONSIDERING HAVING
A. SIMILAR REGULATION. SOME OF
THAT THIS THE BEGIN. OF GREGORY.
OF LGBTQ PEOPLE IN THE
BOARDROOM- WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
ON YOUR IN- IN THE EVENING THAT
COULD EIGHTEEN DID TALK ON THAT
G. D. CHIU PLUS PEOPLE IS
DIFFICULT. BUT OUR MY
ORGANIZATION- GUIDO SHEEP I'M
SURE WHEN. PREVIOUSLY VOTE OUT
OF FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEATS IN FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY. ONLY
TWENTY FIVE I WILL PROVIDE BY
OPEN YET JIMMY CHOO PLUS
PEOPLE. ARE WHICH SHOULD NOT BE
SMALL REPRESENTATION AND OF
COURSE IT'S NOT SURPRISING
BECAUSE MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY
OR NEED TO SIGNIFICANT TEAMS IN.
A FIFTEEN THE BOND. BUT ON THIS
NOTE THAT I WILL I LOVE AND SHE-
TO MY- ON THE IMPACT OF THE
THROUGH THE KILLED. BUT GET ON
IN PART BECAUSE- ON THE- PLUS
COMMUNITY IN SEARCH IF YOU
DON'T MIND OF YOUR IF YOU SLIDE
I'M NOT GOING TO PRESENT ORDER
THEM BECAUSE EACH WOULD
PROBABLY BE BORING FOR THE
ORIGINS BUT I WILL. I WILL
FOCUS ON SOME OF THEM- I'M
AFRAID THAT ALL OF MY SLIDES
WE'RE GOING TO DO NO COULD BE
BETTER THAN MINE OKAY THIS IS
IT- SPOKE TO BRIEFLY I WOULD
LEADERSHIP EITHER ACCORDING
SHOWN OFF BLUCORA COMPANIES
MOST OF THEM IN THE UNITED
STATES. THAT ARE PUSHING FOR
GREATER EQUITY G. FOUR GB CHIU
PRESS BE PUTTING THE BOLD- WE
YOU KNOW WE ARE COURSE ARE OF
THE- IF YOU CAN YOU SHOULD
MENTIONED TROOPS BARBARA.
CALLED BUT WHO STILL UP WILL-
DONE MENTION IT SHOULD SHE- TO
TRY TO BRING THE BY. OF
BUSINESS LEADER OF THAT IGBT Q.
PLUS PEOPLE THAT CAN TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. R. IN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES AND AN ADVENTURE. AS
YOU CHIU PLUCKING CREDIT YOU.
LOOKING AT THE PHONE- UNIT OKAY.
ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
LGBTQ. PLUS PEOPLE. I'M WHICH
REPRESENTS FOUR POINT 25% OF
THE POPULATION OF THE STATE BUT
REPRESENT FIFTEEN PERCENT. OFF
OR THE JIMMY CHOO CHOO PLUS ARE
DIVERGING THE UNITED STATES.
AND YET AND YOU PROJECT YOUR
BREATH REPORTER DO NOT
EXPERIENCE PROSPERITY AT THE
SAME PACE. THEN THEY DON'T
THINK JORDAN AND FUTURE GENDER
PO'S. AND THE REASON WE KNOW
THAT YOU THINK SHOULD BE SIGNED
TO A THINK TANK. BASED IN LOS
ANGELES- THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE
AND IF YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND
MAYBE WE COULD SHIFT. TO US
LIKE NUMBER FOUR. CALIFORNIA I
WAS THIS UNIQUE ASSET IN THE
WORLD WHICH SHE THAT THERE YOU
ARE A GROUP OF ECONOMIES THAT
AND SISTER TO GENE THERAPY
INSTEAD YEAH JIMMY CHOO PLUS
PEOPLE AT UCLA. AND EVEN THOUGH
A LOT OF THE DAY THANK YOU
GLOBAL IN FACT A WALK WITH
PROFITS ONLY BUDGET. OVER THE
WILLIAMS INSTITUTE ON STUDYING
THE COSTA FROM FORGOT WENT OVER
THAT THE WORLD BANK. THE
WILLIAMS INSTITUTE I'VE BEEN
LOOKING BACK TO COLOMBIA A
CALIFORNIA AND SO IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A LEGAL VOID MAY SHOWN.
ABOVE COULD YOU BE TEACHER PLUS
PEOPLE ON THE ECONOMY AND
SOCIAL OUTCOMES THAN IN THE
REST OF THE WORLD. AND ARE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THE WILLIAMS
INSTITUTE DEED. IS THAT THE
DEFENSE THE MEESE OKAY AFTER
THAT. YOU KNOW HE'S THE I. D.
THE DEMAND I NEED YOU COULD YOU
PRESS PEOPLE ON ON IN GENERAL
ORDER ON AVERAGE I WILL SKIP
AND BETTER YOU GET THIRDS
INVEST TRADE PO. WELL YOU KNOW
IT IT LOOKS LIKE IN IT'S NOT
THE CASE AND IN FACT IT SHOULD
BE TO PRESS PEOPLE HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF POGO SEE. THEN
THAT IT WAS THE CHORE OF CIDA
GENDER PO'S- AND SOMETHING THAT
I MUST NOTE- AND THIS IS WHY I
LOVE THE FACT THAT THE WHERE
PRESENTATION FROM IS THE U.
ZERO ON JAN IT'S GOING-
PREVIOUSLY. I HAVE TO SAY THAT
THE PROPOSAL TO YOUR PROJECT
YOU TO PRESS PEOPLE IN VERY
OFTEN. COMPOUNDED BY WAS A
FACTOR SINCE I'VE REYES- GENDO
YOU KNOW BEING FULL
INCARCERATED TO BEING
DELIVERED- COMING FROM THE WEST
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE CLASS.
AND THIRTEEN BOOKED INTERNODES
ODD BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU I
DID GET THE POGO SHE OPENED UP
TWO TWO PLUS PEOPLE HERE SO I
DID GET THE PROGRAM JOB ALSO-
MARGINALIZED GROUPS. AND AND
THROUGH THE CONCLUSION OF THE
WILLIAMS INSTITUTE YOU KNOW I
WILL GO TOWARD OF THE STUDIES
BUT- BUT THE CONCLUSION IS THAT
NOT. ONLY THE OHIO INCIDENTS OF
PROGRAM. INCLUSION AND IT DOES
BEING BUSTING A LOT OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAVE LED TO.
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS ON THE G.
CHIU PLUS ECONOMIC INCLUSION.
HOWEVER I YOU KNOW THE BOND OR
EQUITY G. WHO IS GETS HIGHER
AND SO YOU KNOW WE IT'S NOT
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
DOING SO WELL THAT IT SHOULD
STOP THERE. AND IN FACT IT CAN
TAKE MORE AND MORE YOU SHOULD
TEAMS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS.
A TRUE EQUITY T. IN SOCIETY.
I'M I X. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE TO
WORK LIKE FOR- IT IS A GOOD
FLIGHT FIVE NEEDS TO GET. WHO
IS BEING OF FALL FOR. OF AND
YOU KNOW IT IN NINETY SIXTY SIX
ANGELES THE FIRST GET THE TEAM
IN THE INTO. TO A MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEE PUT THINKS AGAIN. BUT
ON SEXUAL IN AT THAT POINT WHEN
YOU. INSTANCE JUMP ARE YOU BEEN
WITH HUGE. AND AND THAT YOU
KNOW INFO. THE STATE AND CITY.
I'VE BEEN GIVING ACCESS TO A
GYM. GROWTH BUSINESS TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. AND OUT TREATMENT.
IMPACT ON THE G. G. G. PLUS
PEOPLE- A NEW PRODUCT WILL HIGH
SO OF THE RE WHY HE DOESN'T TO.
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY DOES IT. THAT
ACCESS TO GOING TO GO FOR
GETTING AND BUT I THINK THAT
SEEKS WOULD YOU BE CHIU PRO
BUSINESS AND THEFT PROVEN. TEND
STRENGTHEN YOUNG HEAD SHOULD BE
CHIU COME. BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
DISPROPORTIONATE T. EDGY CHIU
PLUS PEOPLE AND SO WHEN- WHEN
YOU GIVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTING AND IN FACT TO A
PRIVATE STUDIO BILL EVEN IF THE
PROGRAMS. TO EDUCATE YOU TO
PRESS OWN BUSINESS IF YOU TEND
TO RELEASED A NEW INTO YOUR AND
YOU BE TEACHING PLUS A
COMMUNITY. AND THEN THERE IS
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT IS LESS
TANGIBLE BUT I SEEM TO HAVE SIX
TRULY IMPORTANT WHICH IS THAT
WOMEN SHOULD BE DID YOU PRESS
PEOPLE. TO SUCCESSFUL. WHEN
THEY DON'T FEATURE THE- OF A
NEWSPAPER OF BEING THAT. YOU
KNOW SEEM OF. KERR YOU KNOW CAN
FOR AND A HEAD MOST UP- THAT WE
WOULD JUST CELEBRATE THE DAY
NEW OF. THE DIRECTION OF THE-
AND EVERY IN THE- IT SAID YOU
KNOW- AND THE G. TO PUT. LIKE
JIM COO. I'VE EITHER STUDENT
SUCCESS. I THINK WE'LL THE-
CONTRIBUTE. TO BETTER SO SHOULD
PROMOTION PUT ON TEN OF AVE GB
CHIU PEOPLE. AND ANY NOT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW. A SUSHI TO
THAT YOU CHOOSE TO THEN JIM YOU
PUT PEOPLE ARE. WITH EXTREMELY
FIVE OR IN. AND IN THIS WAY YOU
CAN LEARN SO. THEIR THE
OUTCOMES MENTIONED EARLIER SO
CHEN ACTS YOUR CATION BECAUSE
OF THE REASON WHY A LOT OF
ENERGY TO PRESS PEOPLE. DRAW
OUT FROM SCHOOL AND OUT OF.
FROM- FROM. YOU KNOW GRADUATE
DEGREE OR UNDER TO DO FIFTY
THEY DO NOT FEEDING TO. AND-
AND THE YOU DISAGREE AGAINST.
SO YOU KNOW I YOUR- YOUR WE CAN
THREE. MAYBE TO SLIDE NOW.
EIGHT YOU KNOW ALL OF THE OTHER
THE HEAD OF FOLK APPROACHABLE
IN JUST MENTION ALREADY. YOU
KNOW. DEPLOY YOUR DIGESTIVE YOU
PROGRAM. I'M NOT TO STOP YOU
KNOW- I THINK I'M JUST SAID
MENTION. THAT SOMETIMES IS
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY. EIGHT GB
PLUS OF A BUSINESS AND- BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE CONTINUE
TO MAKE A FULL END ANY YOU
THREE D. TO FLY. NUMBER NINE D.
STUDENT OVER THE THAT ARE
JOAQUIN. TO ENSURE. LGBT TRUE
PLUS OR BUSINESS THE RICHEST
THEMSELVES. THAT THEY FIND WAYS
TO ACCESS. OUR CONTRACTS. YOU
KNOW ANY COULD OFFER BECAUSE
TRUCKS. SO I WOULD I WILL COME
BY ROOM BY YOU READY REGION
AGAIN- MY- AND MY SON THIS OF.
FOR CONTINUOUSLY I BEING TAKEN
IN THE PAST FIFTY YEARS OF.
OPTIONS IN LEGISLATION THAT
ENSURE THAT THEN YOU BEGIN TO
PRESS PEOPLE I'LL BE GOING TO
BE COMPULSORILY G. AND THEY ARE
GOING TO PUT UNITY TO LIVE A
LIFE OF DIGNITY IN WHICH A
GETTING STEPS AND FELL INTO
SITES. OF IT ARE THEY MENTION
OF EUROPE WE CANNOT ALWAYS DO
WE CAN ALWAYS DO MORE ALL SO
THAT THE GAP. BETWEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT EXPERIENCE OKAY
JIJU PLUS PEOPLE ON THE REST OF
THE POPULATION DECREASE OVER
TIME. AND I WOULD SAY THAT
RECENT LEGISLATION SUCH AS ANY
NINE SEVEN NINE THAT. THAT THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GASKET OUT
CHAMPION ARE WE STRENGTHENS THE
FOUNDATION OF AN INCLUSIVE
CALIFORNIA- ONE THIRTY IN
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND LEGAL.
EQUITY G. AND SO I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE IN THE STORE PRESENTATION I
KNOW HE DOES SHE STAND READY TO
SUPPORT THE STATE YOU NEED A
FOR TO BREED A. MOWING CREW THE
SOCIETY. THANK YOU MISTER WHO
DOT FOR THAT. OUR NEXT. HELLO I
FOR THIS. WE HAVE ALREADY
INSURANCE RICARDO LARA IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE THAT'S
DIRECTOR MICHAEL MIGHTINESS
PRESSURE LOTTE HAS BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT OVERSEES THE LARGEST
INSURANCE MARKET IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THE FOURTH LARGEST
INSURANCE MARKET IN THE WORLD
WITH ANNUAL DIRECT PREMIUMS OF
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS. SINCE TAKING OFFICE IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN YES
ACTED TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL WHILE PRESERVING A
COMPETITIVE INSURANCE MARKET HE
ALSO HAS ACTIVELY WORKED TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CITY WITHIN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR HIS
APPOINTMENT THE OFFICE DOESN'T
ANNUAL DIVERSITY ANALYSIS
ENSURE THAT FOR EACH FOR THE
COMMISSION R. O. POINTS OUT
THAT THE EACH FOR THE
COMMISSIONER POINTS TO THERE'S
AT LEAST ONE APPOINTEE FROM AN
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITY.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ IS CURRENTLY
SENIOR DEPUTY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. HE
COLLATED COMMISSIONERS LAST
MESSAGE AND EFFORTS LEADING UP
TO THE COMMISSIONERS ALLOWED US
WEARING IT ON JANUARY SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. MICHAEL
OFFICERS OF THE COMMISSIONERS
PRIMARY THIS THING ME ON THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE ATHORITY
GOVERNING BOARD AND A
CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHE RESPONSE
COUNCIL HIS PASSWORD VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE AND A PAST
MEMBER OF THE STANFORD ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND THE L. G. B. T.
Q. VICTORY FIVE NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN BOARD. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER LOTTE AND MR
MARTINEZ FOR YOUR TIME YOU MAY
PLEASE BEGIN YOUR REMARKS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY-
CULTURES HOLDEN AND MY GOOD
FRIEND THIS WOMAN GARCIA GOOD
TO SEE YOU. AND MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CORPORATE
BOARD AND CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DIVERSITY. IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU WITH YOU'LL UNDERSTAND JUST
CONGRATULATIONS ON FINISHING.
ANOTHER TREMENDOUS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION- AS YOU MENTIONED ON
THE CAROLINA SERVICE
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. FOR THE NATION'S
LARGEST INSURANCE MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO PROVIDE
SOME BRIEF REMARKS BEFORE I
HEAD BACK TO HOSTING OUR
WESTERN ZONE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS AND INSURANCE
CONFERENCE WITH. SEVERAL OTHER
COMMISSIONERS I'M JOINED AGAIN
HERE AS YOU MENTIONED
CHAIRWOMAN ARE. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ MEISSNER DEPUTY FOR
OUR SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
ALLEGED THAT DIRECTOR WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF. OUR DEPARTMENT WHEN
A JUMP BALL I. WANT TO HELP
FIRST. NOT SURE- A BEIGE. SINCE
ELECT- I AIMS REALLY ENVISION
THAT THE MISSION BE HIGH MY TO
LONGSTANDING. INITIATIVES NOT
ONLY OUR SHIFT MINDSETS BUT
TRANSFORM THE CULTURE OF THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY FROM THE
INSIDE OUT GIVEN THE WAY FORMER
EXPERIENCES AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO CONTINUE
PUSHING FORWARD POLICIES THAT
REALLY CENTER AROUND CONSUMER
PROTECTION THROUGH THE LENS OF
EQUITY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. AS
A REGULATOR THIS MEANS-
REFINING OUR IMPACT AND PUSH
FOR EQUITY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
ALL AT BOTH THE LOCAL AND
NATIONAL LEVELS ULTIMATELY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY NEEDS TO
REALLY REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
THE PEOPLE IT SERVES.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MOST DIVERSE
STATE IN THE UNION IN ORDER FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN THE INDUSTRY
NEEDS TO GET VERY COMFORTABLE
SPEAKING THE LANGUAGE OF
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN HOW- HOW
PURPOSE TRANSLATES INTO
POLICIES WITH LAWS LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST BOARD GENDER
DIVERSITY LAW AS YOU KNOW SB
EIGHT TWO SIX IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND- THAT WAS PRETTY
SPEARHEADED BY A FORMER
COLLEAGUE. CENTER HANNAH BETH
JACKSON AND OUR FIRST DIVERSITY
CORPORATE DIRECTOR LAW ARE WE
COST. THIRD- BUT OUR I WAS
EAGER HOLDEN. YEAH HELLO I'M
SORRY SERVER CHU AT AND-
EARLIER THIS THIS WEEK THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED CENTER BROWN S.
B. C. PERFECT. ORANGE ADVERSITY
BILL WHICH I PROUD TO SPONSOR-
AND SOLD WE HAVE TO ACT WITH.
INTENT WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW LEAD
WITH THIS POLICY SO THAT THE
INDUSTRY COMMAND FOLLOW AND
IMPLEMENT- AS WE CONTINUE TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE FUTURE- THAT
IS MUCH MORE DIVERSE THAN
SPEAKS MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND
I'M CERTAIN THAT OUR AND
HOPEFUL THAT OUR COLLECTIVE
EFFORTS WILL NOT ONLY TRANSFORM
THE POLICY LANDSCAPE BUT ALSO
THE EXTENT TO- THE CULTURAL
LANDSCAPE OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AS WELL SO ONE HOUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AND FOR
THE WORK THAT THE SELECT.
COMMITTEE IS DOING. NOW
COMPRISES TO MY MACHINE. AGAIN
YOUR TIME AND ALLOW ME TO SHARE
A FEW AND WORDS THANK YOU COULD
COMMISSION BEFORE YOU- AND I'M
AND LOOK FORWARD TO- MARTINEZ
IS PRESENT. I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
DIVERSITY YOU'VE YOU'VE
ARTICULATED THAT WELL BUT I CAN
SAY THAT EARLIER THIS YEAR YOU
HOSTED IN MADE VERY SPECIFIC
AND INTENTIONAL. EFFORT TO
RAISE DIVERSITY AMONGST THOSE
COMPANIES THAT MAY NOT FALL
UNDER NINE SEVENTY NINE BUT
FALL CLEARLY UNDER YOUR
JURISDICTION- TO MAKE IT MAKE
THEM AWARE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A DIVERSE WORKFORCE BUT
ALSO LEADERSHIP ON THEIR BOARDS
OF DIRECTORS AS WELL AND YOU'RE
SO YOUR I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE PUBLICLY YOUR-
CONTINUED EFFORT THOUGHTFUL
LEADERSHIP- WEATHER WAS HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. OR AS YOU'VE
NOW TAKEN A VERY IMPORTANT
NATIONAL PRESENCE AS AMONGST
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS TO
BRING TO LIFT THIS PROFILE
HELPS MAKES OUR JOB A LITTLE
BIT EASIER AS WE TRY TO
COMMUNICATE AS WELL SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT. MISTER
MARTINEZ MAY CONTINUE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOTH
CULTURES HOLDEN AND GARCIA AND
THANK YOU CULTURE HOLDING FOR
YOUR ADJUSTER YOUR KNOWLEDGE
MEANT RIGHT NOW AND IN SUPPORT
OF THE COMMISSIONERS LEADERSHIP
I WILL NOW BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MORE ON THAT- IMPORTANT
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AT THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF COMMISSIONER LARA. CURRENTLY
THE DEPARTMENT'S DIVERSITY
INITIATIVES COLLECTING.
PUBLICLY DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION ON CORPORATE BOARDS
AND SUPPLY CHAIN DIVERSITY IN
ADDITION TO. BE A COMMUNITY
INVESTMENTS AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES ALL OF WHICH WERE
MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF
SUCCESSFUL LEAD LEGISLATION
BACKED COMMISSIONER LOT OF
SPONSORED SINCE COMING INTO
OFFICE. AMONG THEM IN TWENTY
TWENTY A NEW LAW WAS ENACTED
WHICH EXPANDED OUR ABILITY TO
COLLECT DATA ON HOW MUCH MONEY
INSURANCE COMPANIES STAND WITH
LGBTQ PLUS. AND THEN TURN OWN
BUSINESSES MOM EXISTING
CATEGORIES OF BUSINESSES SUCH
AS THOSE OWNED BY WOMEN.
DISABLED VETERANS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AS COMMISSIONER LOT OF
MENTION WE ARE VERY PLEASED AND
THRILLED IN FACT THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM CIDER SPONSORED
INSURANCE DIVERSITY BILL SB SIX
FIFTY FIVE JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS THIS NEW
LAW WILLBUILD UPON THE SUCCESS
OF OUR DIVERSITY PRIORITIES. BY
EXPANDING THE POOL OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES REQUIRED TO REPORT ON
THE DOLLARS SPENT WITH THE
STATE'S DIVERSE BUSINESSES OR
SUPPLIERS. I MISS BEING THAT IF
THE COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO CALL
TO COLLECT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN PREMIUMS FROM CALIFORNIANS
FROM CALIFORNIANS. AND IT'S
ONLY FAIR THAT THEY ALSO
CONTRACT. WITH A SMALL AND
DIVERSE BUSINESSES BETTER
BACKBONE OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND IT'S REALLY GOOD TO HEAR
THAT OTHER STATE AGENCIES- THE
ONES ESPECIALLY THAT SPOKE
BEFORE US ABOUT THE WORK THAT
THEY ARE ALSO DOING. I LOVE THE
SYNERGY THAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
ALL COME TOGETHER TOWARDS THE
SHARED GOAL IT'S WHY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE CO FOUNDED. THE
STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
COALITION FOR DIVERSITY
INITIATIVES ALONGSIDE OTHER
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I'M GONNA
TRANSPORTATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND OFFICES. HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. WE
CREATED THIS COALITION BECAUSE
TOGETHER OUR PURPOSE IS TO POOL
OUR RESOURCES ARE BEST
PRACTICES AND FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO PROPEL MORE PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL AND
DIVERSE DIVERSE BUSINESSES.
THESE EFFORTS REALLY ALIGNED
WITH THE VISION AND GOALS OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE. WE CREATE ANNUAL
STRATEGIC PLANS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR INSURANCE DIVERSITY
TASK FORCE WHICH IS AN ADVISORY
BODY OF THE COMMISSIONERS
APPOINTEES COMPRISED OF
COMMITTEE REPRESENTATIVES
BUSINESS LEADERS AND INSURANCE
INDUSTRY EXECUTIVES. IN THE FOR
THE PANDEMIC IT WAS CRITICAL
FOR COMMISSIONER A LOT OF TO
SEE THAT INSURANCE COMPANIES
CONTINUE TO REINVEST AND UP
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
DO BUSINESS AND- AT OUR
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY LANDSCAPE WITHIN OUR
STATE'S INSURANCE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WE LEGISLATED A LAW IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH WITH YOU ALL
THAT REQUIRES COMPANIES TO
REPORT TO US. PUBLICLY BY
EDITOR CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
DIVERSITY SURVEY AND WE MAKE
THE RESULTS OF OUR ANALYSIS
PUBLICLY INSTRUCT ACCESSIBLE WE
KNOW THAT TRANSPARENCY FEELS
ACCOUNTABILITY. MANY INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES THAT EVEN ONE
CONTRACT. FOR DIVERSE SMALL
BUSINESS CAN BE LIFE CHANGING.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN DIVERSE
BUSINESSES COLLECTIVELY
SUPPLIED TWO POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A SIXTEEN POINT 7%
INCREASE SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IN GOODS AND SERVICES TO
INSURANCE COMPANIES. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT NEARLY HALF
APPROXIMATELY 46% OF THOSE
CONTRACTS WENT TO WOMEN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES. WELL LESS
THAN A PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
CONTRACTS WERE AWARDED TO
BUSINESSES OWNED BY LGBTQ PLUS
PEOPLE. SO ONE OF OUR GOALS HAS
BEEN TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSE
SUPPLIERS TO MAN CONTRACTS
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
COMPANIES WHICH WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO WITH A SERIES OF.
BUSINESS MATCH MAKING IT AND
CONNECTION EVENTS WHICH WE HOST
OUR EFFORTS ARE HAVING A
TANGIBLE IMPACT WE BELIEVE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE BUSINESS
OWNERS WELL PROCUREMENT FROM
DIVERSE SUPPLIERS STILL DOESN'T
REFLECT THE REALITY OF THE
DIVERSE LANDSCAPE IN OUR STATE
YET. THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY IS
HEADED IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION
FOR SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
PROCUREMENT BUT STILL WE HAVE A
WAYS TO GO. IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE SPAN
OF ITS OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEAR HISTORY. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS WHICH
IS- THE NATION'S- ASSOCIATION
OF CHIEF INSURANCE REGULATORS.
FOR ALL FIFTY STATES PLUS
UNITED STATES TERRITORIES WHICH
COMMISSIONER LIVE IS A LEADING
MEMBER. TREATED A SPECIAL
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE ON GRAYSON
INSURANCE. TO FOCUS ON RACE AND
DIVERSITY AND THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. THEY'RE LOOKING TO
CURTAIL DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES IN ART IN THIS
INDUSTRY TO CREATE POLICIES.
THAT ARE MUCH FAIRER MORE
INCLUSIVE. OUR DEPARTMENTS
PROGRAMS TO ADVANCE DIVERSITY
ARE BEING LOOKED UPON AS A
NATIONAL MODEL AND BY THE SAME
TOKEN WE ARE SEEING HOW EACH
REGULATORS ACTIONS WITHIN THEIR
RESPECTIVE STATE JURISDICTIONS.
ARE CREATING A RIPPLE EFFECT
ACROSS THIS INDUSTRY. AND
KNOWING THAT THIS WORK IS A
LONG TERM COMMITMENT
COMMISSIONER A LOT OF REMAINS
LASER FOCUSED. ON PUSHING
FORWARD BOLD PUBLIC POLICIES
THAT CENTER THE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUITY. BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE WE
CAN'T DO THIS ALONE AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OF LEADERS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO. IN CHANGING THE
STATUS QUO. NEXT FRIDAY AT OUR
DEPARTMENT'S ANNUAL DIVERSITY
SUMMIT COMMISSIONER LOTTO WILL
BE HOSTING. EIGHT CONVERSATION
WITH LEADERS. FROM NASDAQ
INCLUDING ALSO CALIFORNIA'S
SECRETARY OF STATE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER TO DISCUSS. THE FUTURE OF
BOARD DIVERSITY AND HOW
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK MORE
DIVERSITY LOS. HAVE ESSENTIALLY
SHAPED THE LANDSCAPE OF
NATIONAL POLICIES. DESPITE OUR
COMMITMENTS IN THE STRIDES WERE
MADE CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
INDUSTRY NEEDS TO EVOLVE TO
MEET THE EXPECTATIONS OF OUR
CONSUMERS. LUCKILY FOR US
HINDSIGHT IS TWENTY TWENTY
VISION AND- AND BASED ON OUR
WORK WE LEARN ABOUT WHAT STEPS
WE SHOULD BE TAKING NOW AND WE
HAVE A FEW. OF THOSE- OF THOSE
STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING ONE.
SET MEASURABLE GOALS YOU CAN'T
MEASURE WHAT YOU DON'T TRACK SO
I GREW WITHOUT WHAT CO CHAIR
GARCIA HAS STATED AND SHASTA
INCLUDED PUBLICLY YOU CAN'T
MEASURE WHAT YOU DON'T TRUST
PUBLICLY. WE AGREE THANKS FOR
NOTHING THERE'S PUBLIC POLICY
MORE THAN DATA. AND WITHOUT
DOUBT RELIABLE DATA IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST. THE
DATA THAT WE OBTAIN FROM OUR
DEPARTMENTS INSURANCE DIVERSITY
SURVEY. CONTINUES TWENTY FOUR
ARCHY PROGRAM AND POLICY
INITIATIVES. SECONDLY SHARE
RESOURCES FOR SUCCESS DESPITE
YEARS OF COLLECTING DATA WE ARE
STILL SEEING INSURANCE
COMPANIES TELL US. THAT THEY
SPEND NOTHING WHAT THE WHAT
DRIVERS SUPPLIERS IN THE STATE.
WHETHER IT'S THE RESULT OF THE
REPORTING SYSTEMS ARE LACK OF
INTENTIONALITY. THAT REMAINS TO
BE SEEN BUT REGARDLESS WE ARE
HERE TO HELP. AS WELL AS GUIDE
AND PUSH. AS WE LOOK
220-202-0222 OUR DEPARTMENT
WILL BE WORKING WITH OUR
DIVERSITY TASK FORCE. TO
BRAINSTORM WORKABLE SOLUTIONS
AND HOW TO HELP. AND PUSH
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO MOVE
BEYOND THE ZERO MARK AND TO THE
SAME EXTENT CONTINUE WORKING
WITH DIVERSE SUPPLIERS. ON
ACCESSING. BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THESE
COMPANIES. BUT I DO WANT TO A-
HIGHLIGHT. THAT WE DID HAVE A
WHOLE BOARD ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGN
WHERE COMMISSIONER LOT ISSUE
THE CALL TO ACTION. TO
INSURANCE COMPANY EXECUTIVES
FOR THEIR OWN BOARDS TO SET
INTERNAL GOALS TO ADD A DIVERSE
BOARD DIRECTOR OR SHARE THEIR
PLANS. TO DIVERSIFY AND WITHIN
A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD 1100% OF
THOSE INSURANCE COMPANIES CEOS
RESPONDED- TOLD US THAT THEY
HAD MADE OVER CLOSE TO MAKING
PROGRESS WITH THOSE GOALS THAT
WE SET OUT FOR THEM. CURRENTLY
SUPPORT LONG TERM SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENTS ONE OF
THOSE MOVES IN DIFFERENT WAYS
TO DIRECTLY IMPACT ONE'S
ECONOMIC LIVELIHOOD IS THROUGH
COMMITTEE INVESTMENTS THE
PANDEMIC AS WE HAVE ALL SEEN
HAS DEEPENED WELL DISPARITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. AS YOU MAY
KNOW FIRMS OWNED BY WOMEN OR
PEOPLE FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
MANAGED LESS THAN ONE POINT 3%
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY SEVENTY
TRILLION WITH A T. TRILLION IN
ASSETS UNDER MANAGEMENT. AND
JUST LAST YEAR JULY TWENTY
TWENTY COMMISSIONER LARA
ANNOUNCED A NEW INVEST IN OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE
AS PART OF OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZED INVESTMENT
NETWORK PROGRAMS THAT WILL
IDENTIFY WOMEN VETERANS LGBTQ
PLUS. AND HISTORICALLY-
UNDERREPRESENTED INVESTMENT
MANAGERS LOOKING DIED SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENTS OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES TOWARDS
CAPITAL READY ENFORCEABLE
HOUSING. SMALL BUSINESS
RECOVERY ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND LASTLY WE
NEED TO BUILD THE PLOT OF
PIPELINE MUST STRENGTHEN OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
RECRUITING AND PROMOTING
DIVERSE CANDIDATES THAT REFLECT
OUR DIVERSITY AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH PPORTUNITIES TO SUCCEED
AT NEXT WEEK'S DIVERSITY SUMMIT
WE WILL WE WILL BE HOSTING A
WORKSHOP. ON PROPELLING TO
PROPELLING DIVERSITY ONSTAGE
ADVISORY BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
ALONGSIDE OUR APPOINTEE
APPOINTMENTS CALLING FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
MITCHELL FROM ST SOMEBODY. SO
IN CLOSING. WE HEAR THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF COMMISSIONER LARA- WE WANT
TO SEE A CULTURAL SHIFT AND
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
LANDSCAPE. AND THAT NEEDS TO
START WITH PUBLIC POLICIES AND
LEADERSHIP WE RECOGNIZE THAT
CHANGE TAKES TIME BUT WE'RE
ALSO PUSHING AND WE'RE SEEING
PROGRESS IN A KEY PART OF THIS
IS COMING FROM YOU. FROM YOUR
COLLECTIVE HANDS LEGISLATORS
AND POLICYMAKERS AND HELPING
CREATE STATE POLICIES THAT
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES THIS
IS WHERE WE ARE SEEING THE
HIGHEST COUNTRY CONCENTRATIONS
OF REST AND SUFFERING
ESPECIALLY THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC. SO REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU BOTH OUR CULTURES
HOLDEN GARCIA. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING UP ITS
MISSION A LOT OF NINE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
ON THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
AND THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP. THANK
YOU AND AS WE SAID WE
APPRECIATE. THE COMMISSIONERS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA AND
CERTAINLY OF THE SUPPORT THAT
HE GETS FROM YOU AND HIS TEAM
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU AS YOU'VE A
LINE GOING FORWARD THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT AREA- THAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO GIVE LIFE
TO IN THE- HENCE WHY THIS
COMMITTEE THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WAS ESTABLISHED. A LET ME ALSO
THANK THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
PANEL AS WE TRANSITION INTO OUR
LAST PANEL FOR TODAY. CLEARLY
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
OF PUBLIC SECTOR DIVERSITY-
THERE'S ALWAYS A MORE OF A
HIGHER BAR TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
WITH THE ADVENT OF PROP TWO OH
NINE AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT. LEADERSHIP WITHIN.
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION-
GIVES A KNOWLEDGE MEANT TO THE
ISSUES OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND HIRING A
DIVERSITY MANAGERS IS VERY
IMPORTANT- FOCUSING ON IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING IS VERY IMPORTANT
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP AND SO WAS THAT WAS
BROUGHT OUT BY A NUMBER OF OUR
PANELISTS TODAY WE WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU AS WELL. WE
WILL NOW TRANSITION TO OUR
THIRD PANEL AND CONCLUDING
PANEL WHICH WILL FOCUS ON THE
FUTURE OF DIVERSITY INCLUSION
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA. FIRST
JONATHAN CENTERVILLE FROM THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN BOARD
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE. WILL
SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUILDING THE PIPELINES AND HOW
BEST TO SUPPORT BLACK
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS OF COLOR. AS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF A A. B. L.
I. HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LEADING AND SCALING OPERATIONS
AND GEOGRAPHIC FOOTPRINT
NATIONALLY WHILE PROVIDING
SOLUTIONS AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CORPORATIONS
GRANT MAKERS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS INDIVIDUALS AND
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES COMMITTED
TO DIVERSITY EQUITY. AND
INCLUSION. I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY MR
SANDOVAL AND PLEASE PROCEED AND
LET ME JUST ALSO SAY. TO THIS
PANEL WE APOLOGIZE FOR. THE
FACT THAT WE'RE JUST NOW
GETTING TO YOUR PANEL BUT AS
YOU SEE WE WERE AMBITIOUS IN
TRYING TO COVER A LOT OF ISSUES
AND AREAS THAT- THERE IS A LOT
OF CONCERN AND THOUGHT AROUND
AND SO- I DON'T WANNA SAY WE
BIT OFF MORE THAN WE CAN CHEW
BUT WE HAVE A LOT TO DIGEST
TODAY SO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WILL TURN TO YOU
NOW FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. NO
WORRIES AT ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AND THE
SELECT- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THIS TIME BOB.
ACTUALLY THE PRESENTATION AT DO
YOU WANT TO SHARE BUT BASICALLY
IT'S MY INTENTION TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT ABLY. ASK
MARTIN BOARD LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTE WHAT WE DO AND HOW
WE'RE RESPONDING TO OUR
NATIONAL CALL TO ACTION
RECOGNIZING A CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING THE WAY WITH THE RECENT
PASSAGE OF EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
NINE. I ALSO WANT TO SHARE HER
ORGANIZATION CAN HELP TO CREATE
A PIPELINE OF AFTERMARKET
PROFESSIONALS TRAINED BY US
WHAT GOVERNANCE. IF WE CAN GO
TO SLIDE NUMBER TWO PLEASE.
I'LL SKIP CHRISTMAS LIGHTS.
NEXT. ONE AND THE NEXT LOOK.
OKAY SO I MISSION IS QUITE
SIMPLE OUR GOAL IS TO
STRENGTHEN NONPROFIT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS TO
RECRUITING AND PREPARING AND
ASSISTING WITH THE PLACEMENT OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS ON A BROAD
RANGE OF GOVERNING BOARD SO WE
DO THE SCHOOL CORPORATIONS WE
DO IT FOR FOUNDATIONS WE DO IT
FOR GOVERNMENT COMMISSIONS-
ABLY WAS ESTABLISHED OVER A
DECADE AGO WHICH SETS US APART
FROM A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE POPPING UP WE'VE SEEN.
THE ADVENT ROMANIZATIONS AFTER
A MASTECTOMY THIS PROPOSAL TO
THE SEC ORGANIZATIONS ARE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING TO DO RECRUITMENT
RETENTION BUT WITH THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN BOARD LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTE WE ARE AND DECADE TO
OF SERVICE. I'M SORRY I'M OUR
SECOND DECADE OF SERVICE. AND
THERE'S A LEVEL OFTEN THAT
COMES WITH THAT THAT'S A LEVEL
OF TRUST WERE HIGHLY RESPECTED
BASED IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
WE WORK WITH A NUMBER OF
CORPORATIONS. FOUNDATIONS AND
THEN GOVERNMENT ENTITIES SO WE
WERE FOUNDED BY VIRGIL ROBERTS
AND YOU BETCHA INGRAM IN A
GROUP OF CONCERNED CITIZENS WHO
HAD SERVED ON BOARDS THEY SERVE
ON BOARDS. THEY HAVE SERVED AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF NONPROFIT
AND PHILANTHROPIC AND
PHILANTHROPY THEY WERE
EXECUTIVES AND THEY SAW THE
NEED FOR THIS ORGANIZATION TO
EXIST A DECADE AGO. BECAUSE OF
THE UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS ON GOVERNING
BOARDS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
OVER THE LAST DECADE WE'VE
TRAINED OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
PROFESSIONALS TO SERVE ON
GOVERNING BOARDS EVEN IMPACT
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
OFFICIALS THROW PROGRAMMING.
AND MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
CURRENTLY SERVE ON NONPROFIT
BOARDS WHEN GOVERNMENT
COMMISSIONS AND ALSO ON OUR
CORPORATE BOARDS NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO ABLY IS OUR
PIONEERING IN THIS REGARD WE'VE
EXPANDED OUR OPERATIONS
NATIONALLY WE'RE ENTERING THE
SECOND DECADE OF SERVICE AS
I'VE MENTIONED WE'RE COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING RESOURCES AND
SERVICES TO CORPORATIONS SO
THAT THEY CAN MEET THE MANDATE
THAT SPINS. BEFORE DOWN BY
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY NINE SO WE
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CORPORATIONS
WE DO IT FOR GRANT MAKERS AND
FOR NON PROFITS AND GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND- REALLY THE FUTURE
OF DIVERSITY IS ABOUT THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND SOLUTIONS WITH
AN ORGANIZATION LIKE. EBELING
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO WE TAKE
THIS AS WE SEE THIS AS A- AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN ANSWERING THE
NATION'S CALL TO ACTION WE HAVE
BEEN WILL BE. CONTENT TO BE A
PART OF THIS MOVEMENT FOR
CHANGE WHAT THE RISE OF SOCIAL
UNREST IN TWENTY TWENTY MANY
CORPORATIONS WERE FORCED TO
STATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
DIVERSITY WITH THEIR WITHIN
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS. EMILY WAS
ONLY PLANTED AND ITS WORK TO
BRING ABOUT CHANGE SO OUR
DIVERSITY ACCORDING TO SOME
THIS WORK PROVIDES CONFIRMATION
OF WHAT RESEARCHERS THAT'S
PERFECT YOU KNOW OUR BACK. ON
BUSINESS RECENT PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENTS
DOESN'T ALWAYS TRANSLATE INTO
LONG TERM STRUCTURAL CHANGE CAN
BOARD MEMBERS HIRING AND
RECRUITMENT RETENTION POLICIES
THAT'S. WHERE OUR WORK COMES TO
PLAY. NEXT LIKE WEEKS. WHAT WE
SKIP TO. GO UP A FEW SLIDES.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WELCOME TO
SLIDE NUMBER. EIGHT SO THIS IS
KEY BECAUSE EXACTLY ONE YEAR
AGO THE GOVERNMENT ISN'T SIGNED
LANDMARK LEGISLATION WHICH
REQUIRES DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS- WE'RE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE VISION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND US NUMBER- RACE
AND ALSO SENATOR BEN YOU STILL
FOR CO AUTHORING. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. NETWORK. SO IS A SINGLE
ASCO CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW SO DO
DOES THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING- BASED UPON THIS
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP SEEMS
STATES LIKE ILLINOIS AND
WASHINGTON AND HAWAII AND
MASSACHUSETTS AND OTHERS OR
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA'S LEAD BUT
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO THE
FUTURE FOR DIVERSITY AS WE SEE
IT ABLY IS HOW WE HELP
CORPORATIONS ACHIEVE THIS
MANDATE THIS LAW THAT'S BEEN
SET BEFORE THEM AND WE BELIEVE
IT'S STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS
WITH. JEFF MARTIN WE SHOULD
INSTITUTE NEXT SLIDE. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO WHAT I LIKE TO
SHARE SOME OF OUR PROGRAMMING
AND HOW WE HELP CORPORATIONS
ARE SIGNATURE PROGRAM IS THE
BOARD LEADERSHIP PROGRAM AND WE
TRAINING- INDIVIDUALS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THE
PROGRAMMING IS DONE VIRTUALLY
NOW DUE TO COLDER IRATE SAP
THROUGH THE LAST COHORT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME THROUGH-
OUR PLP PROGRAMMING IN AUGUST
AND- IT'S A RIGHT TO HEAR THE
STORIES THAT CORPORATIONS AND
FOUNDATIONS AND- GOVERNMENT
EMISSIONS CAN'T FIND QUALIFIED
PEOPLE OF COLOR I WITNESSED
FORTY EIGHT PEOPLE. WHO WENT TO
THE PROGRAM IN AUGUST THERE
WERE DOCTORS LAWYERS P. H. D.'S
NBA'S ALWAYS FAN CALIFORNIA AND
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
INDIVIDUALS WHAT SERVED ON
BOARDS INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD NOT
SO YOU REALLY CREATE A SPECIFIC
TRAINING PROGRAM BECAUSE
THERE'S- JUST BECAUSE WHAT
WORKS FOR MAJOR CORPORATIONS
OR- ISN'T EXACTLY WITHIN A
MAJOR FOUNDATION DOES NOT MAKE
THEM QUALIFIED TO SERVE ON THE
BOARD HOWEVER HAVING THE
TRAINING AND LEADERSHIP FROM.
CULTURALLY COMPETENT LEADERS
WHO HAVE SERVED ON BOARDS AND
THROUGH THE CURRICULUM AND
TRAINING THAT WAS DEVELOPED
WITH OUR FACULTY WELCOME TO
MEET THOSE. NEEDS NEXT MARKETS.
ONE OF OTHER PRO IS ALREADY
LEADERS SERIES. AND WE ARE WITH
OVER THE FOR ARE PROFESSOR
DEVELOPMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
GO THROUGH A BORN LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS WORKSHOPS AND FORUMS
AND EVENTS. AND LIFELONG
LEARNING FOR ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
ALUMNI NETWORK NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. WE HAVE A CORPORATE
DIRECTORS INITIATIVE WHICH IS
WEBINARS ARE ONLINE RIGHT NOW
ON YOUR COLD BUT THEY'RE PACKED
WITH INSIDER PERSPECTIVES THAT
CAN HELP INDIVIDUAL BOARD
MEMBERS- WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
THE CORPORATE BOARD. JOIN THOSE
BOARDS WITH CONFIDENCE WITH THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE
BUT TALKING CHECK OTHER. BOARD
MEMBERS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WE
ALSO HAVE A PUBLIC BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS WARM- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDERS PARTICIPATE IN
ONE OF THOSE AND BASS WE USE
THAT AS OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND- THE
VARIOUS APPOINTMENTS THAT MIGHT
GET A LITTLE DOWN AFTER PURSUE
CORPORATE BOARD SO WE HAVE
BETTER COMMISSIONERS. WILL
SHARE THEIR INSIGHTS AND TO
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU CAN BECOME
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC BOARDS NEXT
MONTH'S. SO THERE'S VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT ABLE IS
GOING TO WORK WITH CORPORATIONS
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS- WE
PROVIDE A SOLUTION THAT'S
NEEDED FOR CORPORATIONS TO.
BEGIN TO DO THIS WORK AND ALSO
TO HAVE BEEN NUMBERS OF TEENS
LIKE TO. DEBATE WHAT SHE NEXT
LOGS. SO ONE EXAMPLE OF OUR
WORK IS A PARTNERSHIP WITH
TOYOTA WOULD BE DEVELOP
CUSTOMIZED TRAINING FOR TOYOTA
TO- TRAINS MOTHER CORPORATE
EXECS ANDALSO FOR SOME OF
THEIR MID CAREER STAFF INTEREST
THEIR C. SUITE EXECS SO THAT
THEY COULD SERVE ON- BOARDS AND
THEY COULD SERVE. SERVE ON
NONPROFIT BOARDS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THEIR SERVICE SO
WE DO IT WITH CORPORATIONS FOR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS BUT FOR
THEIR AT THEIR FOUNDATIONS AND
THEIR THEIR- THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS UP THERE SERVE
WITHIN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES. ONE OF WHICH WAS A
TRAINING THAT WE CREATED FOR
TOYOTA BECAUSE NOBLE
CORPORATION IS EXACTLY THIS
THING YOU KNOW THERE'S
DIFFERENT CULTURE WITHIN EACH
ORGANIZATION SO WE CREATE
CUSTOMER TRAININGS. TO SUPPORT.
NEXT LIVES. ANOTHER OF OUR WORK
IN TERMS OF DIVERSITY ACCORDING
INCLUSIVENESS IS A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE WEINGART FOUNDATION
SO- WEINGART FOUNDATION. IS A
PIONEER OR LEADER IN THE SCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY TOLD ORIGINAL
GRANTEE THAT THEY WOULD NOT
FUND THEM UNLESS THEY HAVE
DIVERSE BOARDS SO DIVERSITY
STARTS AT THE TOP SO WE WENT
AND- TO TRAIN WIDER ITS
GRANTEES SO THAT THEIR BOARDS
COULD BECOME. MORE DIVERSE AND
SO THEY CAN RECRUIT AND RETAIN-
INDIVIDUALS TO SERVE ON A
NONPROFIT BOARD. NEXT LEXUS.
AGAIN ACCORDING TO SHIP PROGRAM
WHICH THREE WEEKS INTENSIVE
FOR. CHECK PLACE ON SINCE.
COURTS MEET THEY REVIEW CASE
STUDIES BY TALK WITH ACTUAL-
ARE SITTING BOARD MEMBERS THEY
DISCUSS ISSUES LIKE IMPLICIT
BIAS YOU KNOW YOU LESION. OR
DOES IT LEADERSHIP AND THINGS
THAT WOULD NOT ACTUALLY COME UP
THEY HAVE NOT GOING TO A
SPECIFIC TRAINING THAT WAS
CREATED FOR THEM SO. IT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE BELIEVE
IS KEY TO NOT ONLY HAVE COMPLEX
WELL IF I WAS WITH THE TRAINING
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
READY. SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT.
MAKES US. DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. NO SLIDE SO. I
TALKED NUMBER CUSTOMIZING YOUR
TWENTY FOUR REALIZATION- IT'S A
WITNESS ABOUT HOW DO WE EVEN
TACKLE POSITION SO WE TRAINED
EMPLOYEE RESOURCE GROUPS
RETRAINING C. SUITE EXECS TRAIN
OUR MID LEVEL STAFF SO WHATEVER
THE REASON NEEDS CAN CREATE
THAT PROGRAMMING FOR THEM WE
HAVE A STANDARDIZED TRAINING
AND CUSTOMIZED TRAINING SECOND
STEP WITH THE NEEDS OF ANY
ORGANIZATION SO IT'S ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
IMPACT BE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSIVENESS AMONGST
ORGANIZATIONS IT'S ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE LOOK AT. ELEVATING
LEADERSHIP YOU KNOW LEADERSHIP
IT GOES BOTH WAYS SO THE MID
LEVEL STAFF- MANAGERS DIRECTORS
VICE PRESIDENTS C. SUITE STAFF-
STREAMS ALL AROUND THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO ANY CORPORATION.
AND NEEDS. NEXT LOOKS. BOB
PRESSURE THE COST. WORKSHOPS
ONE RESOURCE MADE WORK WITH-
BLACK AMERICANS A RESOURCE
GROUPS ONCOLOGY B. G. Q.
RESOURCE GROUPS HELPING THEM
TO- DISCUSSED ISSUES WITHIN
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS AND TO
CREATE MORE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN A MORE DIVERSE WORK
ENVIRONMENT. EXCELLENT WE DO
BOARD GOVERNANCE TRAINING AND
THIS REALLY HELPS TO FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR BORDER CITY SUCCESSFUL IN
THEIR ENDEAVORS AND THEIR WORK
AS MORE MEMBERS. MECKLER SAID.
SURE YOU DO BUT IT'S WHAT
TRAINS FOR MID CAREER
DEVELOPMENT- IF WE'RE OUT TO
DEVELOPING THE TRAINING AS
LEADERS NEXT LINE. AND WHAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY KEY IS OUR BOARD
RECRUITMENT PLACEMENT SO- FOR
THESE BILLS INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
TRAIN WE PLACED THEM ON ACTUAL
BOARDS SO ABLY NOW HAS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH NASDAQ NASDAQ
LOOKS TO- FOR THAT. REASON THE
OLDEST ON THE NASDAQ WHEN THEY
HAVE OPENINGS FOR DIFFERENT
WELL- BOARD LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES BAY SURE THAT
WITH US WE SHARE OUR BORDERING
TALENT TO HELP THEM TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN INDIVIDUAL SO AGAIN
IT'S MORE ABOUT A RESOURCE IN
PARTNERSHIP AND THAT'S HOW WE
LOOK TO THE FUTURE TO SUPPORT
NOT ONLY CORPORATIONS BUT
FOUNDATIONS AND- OTHER
ENTITIES. NEXT LAB TO. AND THAT
BRINGS TO THE END OF MY
PRESENTATION TRY TO RUN THROUGH
A VERY QUICKLY AND- YOU HAVE TO
KEEPING. HELLO MY- UP. BUT WHAT
HI SCHEDULE SO IF THE I PUT IS
ON THINGS IT AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME WE THANK YOU AND WE
DO A- THE- SHORT END OF THE
PRESENTATION BUT THE- THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT YOU ARE
PRESENTING. WAS STILL VERY RICH
AND VERY INFORMATIVE AND SO
IT'S APPRECIATIVE THAT. THAT
THAT WAS PRETTY LAID OUT THERE
IN A WAY THAT I THINK IT MAKES
IT HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION IS
BRINGING TO BUILDING THE
PIPELINE AND I THINK THAT WAS
PART OF THE FOCUS OF YOUR
PRESENTATION AND WE SEE THAT
AND WE- LOOK FORWARD TO BRING
YOU BACK AND DRAWING ON YOU AS
A RESOURCE AS WE- CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY GOING FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO INTRODUCE OUR
OUR LOT BUT WE HAVE ONE MORE WE
HAVE ONE MORE. PRESENTER IN
THIS PANEL- AND THEN WLL
RESERVE SOME TIME FOR A FEW
QUESTIONS AT THE CONCLUSION. OF
THE NEXT WE SHIFT OUR ATTENTION
TO THE LEGAL CONCERNS AROUND
INSTITUTING DIVERSITY INCLUSION
POLICIES OR DENY POLICIES IN
THE WORKPLACE PROFESSOR HANNAH.
SHAW FROM GOLDEN STATE
UNIVERSITY WILL ADDRESS SOME OF
THE LEGAL CONCERNS AROUND D.
AND I POLICIES AND WILL DISCUSS
HER PAPER. A RADICAL
RECONSTRUCTION. RE EMBRACING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT. PROFESSOR HANNAH
SHAW IS PROFESSOR OF LAW AND
DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S IN
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS CLINIC. AT
GOLDEN STATE UNIVERSITY LAW
SCHOOL W. E. R. C. ADVOCATES
FOR THE RIGHTS OF LOW WAGE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS THROUGH
DIRECT SERVICE IMPACT
LITIGATION AND PUBLIC POLICY
WORK AND IN COORDINATION WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
IT ALSO SERVES AS LEGAL COUNSEL.
TO THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION HELPING
EXPAND AND ENFORCE WORK PLACE
PROTECTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS PROFESSOR SHAW HAS
LECTURED AND WRITTEN ON THE
PLIGHT OF LOW WAGE AND
IMMIGRANT WORKERS HER
SCHOLARSHIP FOCUSES ON
EXPLORING THE RADICAL RACIAL.
STRATIFICATION OF THE LABOR.
ELECTED YOU FOR SHAW JOIN US
TODAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PRESENT. THANK VERY MUCH
MEMBERS HOLDEN AND COURSE AND
FOR THE MEMBERS IN SPECIAL OF
THE COMMITTEE. HI I HAVE LAW
BEEN INTERESTED IN THE
DIVERSITY OF THE WAY WORK FORCE
FOR ME THROUGH MY WORK AT THE
CLINIC AT GOLDEN GATE
UNIVERSITY WILL ALSO THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER I HAVE REPRESENTED
LOW WAGE WORKERS. AND IT IS NOT
SURPRISING HAT WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN LANGUAGE IN
DISTRICTS. IN MY SCHOLARSHIP
AND MY PUBLIC SPEAKING I HAVE
BECOME INTERESTED IN ADDRESSING
THE RACIAL STRATIFICATION OF
THE LABOR MARKET AND TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO TRULY DIVERSIFY.
GOVERNMENT HAS LONG RECOGNIZED
THAT WITHOUT DISCRIMINATION
EMPLOYERS WORKFORCE SHOULD
REFLECT THE PROPORTIONAL
REPRESENTATION ALONG RACE AND
GENDER. WORKFORCE SO IT'S NOT
JUST A PROBLEM OF
REPRESENTATION AT BOARD LEVEL.
BUT IT SHOULD BE REFLECTED
THROUGHOUT THE LABOR MARKET. WE
KNOW THAT RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
BOTH HISTORICALLY AND THE
CURRENT RIPPLE EVIDENCE WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS DISCRIMINATION IN
THE LABOR MARKET BOTH OVERT AND
IMPLICIT. DISCRIMINATION ALL
AND IT IS STILL VERY PROMINENT.
NORTH PURPLE STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST BLACKS
IS NOT DISAPPEAR OR EVEN
GRADUAL DIMENSION DIMINISHING
LABOR MARKET. IN FACT IN ONE
STUDY A WHITE MALE FELON OUT ON
PAROLE AT A HIGHER CHANCE OF
GETTING EMPLOYMENT THAN A BLACK
MALE WITH NO PROBLEM. I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION BUT ALSO TO
EXPAND THE COMMITTEES
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES ON BET. ON READING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IS GOING TO.
APPRECIATE DURING WARTIME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROHIBITED
DISCRIMINATION IN TRAINING AND
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN DEFENCE
PRODUCTION BY PRIVATE DEFENSE
CONTRACTORS. PRESIDENT KENNEDY
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE EXPANDED
THE PROHIBITION ON
DISCRIMINATION BY MAKING THE
FIRST EXPLICIT REFERENCE TO
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WHEN HE
MANDATED THAT FEDERAL
CONTRACTORS TAKE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION TO ENSURE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. THAT'S AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION MANDATE REMAINS INTACT
TODAY MOST FEDERAL CONTRACTORS
MUST ADOPT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
PLANS WITH DETAILED STATISTICAL
AND NARRATIVE COMPONENTS FOR
EXAMPLE COMPARING THE
UTILIZATION OF WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR TO THEIR AVAILABILITY
IN THE MARKET. AND DEVELOPING
RECRUITMENT OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THESE DEFICIENCIES.
WHAT DOES NOT REQUIRE VOTERS IT
DOES REQUIRE DESIGNING GOALS
TIMETABLES AND PRIMITIVE ACTION
COMMITMENTS TO CORRECT ANY
IDENTIFIABLE DEFICIENCY.
SPECIFIC STUDIES OF THE FOUNDER
FEDERAL MANDATE ON AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND CONCLUDED THAT THE
PROGRAM WORKS SUBSTANTIALLY TO
INCREASE BLACK AND FEMALE
EMPLOYMENT AND CONTRACTING FOR.
BUT THIS PROGRESS WAS SHORT.
CALIFORNIA BECAME THE FIRST
STATE THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE TO BAN
THE USE OF PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BASED ON RACE OR
GENDER IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
CONTRACT. THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT STILL STANDS TODAY.
IN A PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT SECTOR
THE PORT HAS GRAPPLED WITH THE
**** RECONCILING THE PURSUIT OF
A COLOR BLIND SOCIETY BUT THE
HISTORICAL HISTORICAL REALITY
OF RACE THE SUBJUGATION. MANY
OF THE PORTS DOCTRINAL
DECISIONS ON AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
ARE FRACTURED AND DOCTRINALLY
UNSTABLE. DESPITE THE
IDEOLOGICAL PUNCTUATION THE
WORD AND THE LACK OF A MAJORITY
SINCE THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
THE COURT HAS UPHELD THE USE OF
RACE IN NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES
INCLUDING AN EDUCATION TO
CREATE OR MAINTAIN DIVERSITY.
AND BY PRIVATE EMPLOYERS IN
DESIGNING VOLUNTARY AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION PROGRAMS. TODAY HOWEVER
WE MUST PROCEED WITH CAUTION IN
PRESCRIBING REYES OR GENDER
CONSCIOUS DECISION MAKING AS
THE ONLY SOLUTION TO ENSURING A
DIVERSE WORK. THE MAKE UP OF
THE HIGH COURT IS DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT THAN EVEN A DECADE
AGO. AND JUSTICE ROBERTS ALONG
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE WING OF
THE SUPREME COURT ARE STAUNCH
OPPONENTS OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
I FEAR THAT ANY CASE THAT WILL
END UP BEFORE THE COURT MAYBE
AN INVITATION FOR THE WORK OF
FINALLY AND THE CONSIDERATION
OF RACE AND GENDER DECISION.
RECENT DECISIONS ON VOTING
RIGHTS IN OTHER AREAS CLEARLY
POINT TO THE COURTSWHEN HE HAS
TO ABANDON PRECEDENT. IN IMPACT
MOVEMENTS OF THE ONE DIRECTION.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER. WHAT AREA OF
OPPORTUNITY WITH RESPECT TO
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. TOTAL SEVEN
DOES NOT MANDATE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION BUT IT ALSO DOES NOT
PROHIBIT. FURTHERMORE
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE DOES
NOT DEAL WITH PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT. I'M MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THE FEDERAL THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT HAS REINFORCED
THE ABILITY FIVE EMPLOYERS TO
ADOPT NARROWLY TAILORED
VOLUNTARY AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
PLANS. THE KEY IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO INCENTIVIZE COMPANIES
THROUGH TAX CREDITS OR OTHER
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO ADOPT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. TO END TO
ADOPT A PLAN THAT WORKS WITH A
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE WORK. WE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF THE PUBLIC
SECTOR ALL LEADERS INCLUDING
MISS JENKINS JOHNSON THE SHALL
ABOUT THE PUBLIC SECTOR'S
COMMITMENT TO CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE DIVERSITY PLAN.
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS TO SUMMARY ADOPTED
COMPREHENSIVE D. I. PLAN
INCLUDING ALL WHERE THERE ARE.
THERE'S A TRAIT DESPITE WHAT
DOES A PIPELINE THAT'S GREAT AT
ALL AS WELL AS WE- READ.
LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE PROCESS
ON GROUP TRULY CREATED
DIVERSITY IN THE WORK. WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD WORK TOWARDS
CREATING A DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE BY FUNDING
TRAINING PROGRAMS OR
INCENTIVIZING ON THE JOHN
TRAINING BENEFITS IN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES WHERE THERE ARE
RACIAL GENDER DISPARITIES. BUT
I ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
NOT THINK START LEADING A
BINARY FASHION. THE CHOICE IS
NOT BETWEEN COLOR OR GENDER
BLINDNESS AND RECOVERING
TREATMENT. IN EQUITY PERMEATES
EVERY OF THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS FOR RECRUITMENT
RETURN TO PROMOTION TO SUCH.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE JUST
COMES AT THE TAIL END TO FORCE
A CHOICE BASED ON RACE OR
GENDER. HOWEVER WE NEED TO
EMBRACE AND MANDATE THAT
EMPLOYERS ELIMINATE ALL THE-
EXPLICIT AND IMPLICIT IN THE
PROCESS TO TRULY DIVERSIFY
THEIR WORK. I THINK THE ONLY-
JANET WANTS I'LL INDIVISIBLE
GARCIA DECIMATED ATTENDED TO
THIS COMMENT BUT I AGREE WHAT
GET WHAT GETS MEASURED PROBABLY
GETS DONE. SO FOR EXAMPLE.
COMPANIES CAN ADOPT WRITTEN
STATEMENTS OF COMMITMENTS TO
DIVERSITY INCLUSION AND EQUITY
AND MAKE THOSE STATEMENTS
PUBLIC ALL OF THE STATEMENTS
SHOULD INCLUDE ADOPTIONS A
COMPANY WIDE HIRING GOALS TO
ADDRESS ANY INEQUITIES. AND A
COMMITMENT TO REDUCE
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS. THERE'S MUCH MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT COMPANIES
NEED TO DO TO ADDRESS EXISTING
RACE OR GENDER WAGE AND
OCCUPATIONAL DISPARITIES.
DISPARITIES THAT CAN BE
REVEALED BY THE PAY DATA
REPORTS THAT ARE REQUIRED BY SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE. THOSE
REPORTS SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO POST THE
DATA ON THE PUBLIC WEBSITES.
WHERE TO THE DMV EACH POST A
SEARCHABLE DATABASE THAT
REMOVES ANY INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. SB
NINE SEVEN THREE SHOULD ALSO BE
EXPANDED TO APPLY TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS WITH FIFTY OR MORE TO
AGGREGATE P. DATA BASED ON RACE.
GENDER AND OTHER IDENTIFIABLE.
CATEGORIES MISTER JONES ONE
ZERO COPPER CAL MANDATORY
CORRECT TO LOOK TO REDUCE
IMPLICIT BIAS I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATURE CAN
REALLY THINK ABOUT MANDATING
REQUIREMENTS ON THAT ENCOMPASS
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
THE LEGISLATURE ALREADY
MANDATES ARE PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
TO HAVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING FOR THEIR SUPERVISORS
BUT WE NEED EVEN MORE SO ALL IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING TRAINING IN
THE LEADERSHIP TO ELEVATE
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION
THROUGHOUT. A PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
WITH. MORE FOCUS NEEDS TO BE
PLACED ON ENSURING A DIVERSE
APPLICANT WILL BOTHER THEM
FOCUSING SOLELY ON THE ACTUAL
DECISION. THIS MUST DO THE HARD
WORK OF EVALUATING ITS ENTIRE
EMPLOYMENT PROCESS FROM
IDENTIFYING HIRING NEEDS TO
PROMOTION AND RETENTION. BIAS
CREATES BARRIERS TO WALK
ACROSS. THE PAINSTAKING STEPS
OF EVALUATING AND LAMINATING
BIAS IN EVERY STEP OF THE
PROCESS WILL RESULT IN A MORE
DIVERSE APPLICANT POOL. WHEN
SETTING MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE WOMEN
ARE RELUCTANT TO APPLY TO JOBS
AND WHEN THEY DO NOT MEET 100%
OF TE HIRING CRITERIA.
BUSINESSES SHOULD THINK
CAREFULLY ABOUT WHICH SKILLS A
PERSON NEEDS TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT POSITION. OUR ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS COULD ALSO
BE CLEAR ON WHAT INFORMATION
BUSINESS CAN GATHER FROM JOB
APPLICANTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
APPLICANT POOL IS DIVERSE AND
INCLUDES. CURRENTLY THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY IT IS UNLAWFUL TO
IDENTIFY AN INDIVIDUAL ON THE
BASIS OF THE ENUMERATING
ENUMERATED CATEGORIES ALL IT'S
ON WALL. HOWEVER IT'S NOT A
MORE. ELECT A VOLUNTARY BASIS
APPLICANTS WILL DATA AND OTHER
RECORD KEEPING DATA FOR
STATISTICAL PURPOSES. THE DATA
CAN BE USED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE APPLICANT WAS
DIVERTS MORE THOUGHT NEEDS TO
BE- SPENT BY THE LEGISLATURE
I'M THINKING ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
DATA CAN AN EMPLOYEE REVIEWS TO
EVALUATE WHETHER THEY HAVE
TRULY A DIVERSE APPLICANTS.
THESE ARE JUST SOME SUGGESTIONS
THE BUSINESSES IN THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD EXPLORE TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE REFLECTS THE TRUE
DIVERSITY OF ITS POPULATION. I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT TO BE
LEARNED BOTH FIGHT STEPS TO THE
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS HAVE TAKEN.
ACCEPT ORDERS TAKEN AND ALSO BY
THE LEGISLATURES ARE. FOCUSING
ON COMMITMENT TO CREATING A
TRULY DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
WORKFORCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW. TURN TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- TO SEE IF THERE
ANY QUESTIONS BUT IF I COULD
JUST VERY QUICKLY ON THAT LAST
POINT THAT YOU RAISED AROUND
THE PUBLIC SECTOR- WORKFORCE
AND LOOKING AT WAYS OF CREATING
GREATER. DIVERSITY WE DO HAVE A
BILL. I AB ONE OH FIVE THAT IS
BEFORE THE GOVERNOR FOR
SIGNATURE THAT LOOKS AT UPWARD
MOBILITY. FOR WOMEN AND-
INDIVIDUALS OF COLOR OF WHO ARE
LOOKING TO MOVE UP WITHIN
ORGANIZATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE IS YOU TO
CHRIS THESCRIBE OF
ELIMINATING. BIAS IN THE
RECRUITING POOL- BUT ALSO
SITTING IN PLACE. A CLEAR
STANDARD OF HOW THERE COULD BE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
PEOPLE BASED ON WHAT. THEIR
TRUE TALENTS ARE AND GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE UP
AND NOT HAVING ANYTHING THAT
WOULD SORT OF FILTER THEM OUT
BECAUSE IT MAYBE DIDN'T CHECK A
CERTAIN BOX. OF BASED ON A
CERTAIN EDUCATIONAL STANDARD
BUT THEY MAY BE WORK FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY YEARS. FOR THE CIVIL
SERVICE OF SYSTEM SO- I'D I
JUST WANTED THAT OUT THERE
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO SAY
ANYTHING BECAUSE IT'S STILL ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT- YOU
YOU BROUGHT THAT ALSO FOR
PURPOSES OF JUST. LETTING YOU
KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
GOTTEN THEIR ARMS TO SOME
DEGREE AROUND THIS. PARTICULAR
ISSUE- SENATOR YOUR HONOR.
THANK YOU ADJOURNMENTS SO MY
QUESTION ACTUALLY WAS TO MISTER
SANTA ELF- I WONDERED. HOW
SUCCESSFUL YOUR PLACEMENT IN
CORPORATE BOARD TO SPEND AND
YOU EITHER. FIVE HOW MANY-
DIVERSE PEOPLE YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO GET. CORPORATIONS TO POINT
TO THEIR BOARDS ARE HOW MANY
COMPANIES ARE. ACTUALLY
UTILIZING YOUR SERVICES. THIS
IS MICHELLE- I CAN SPEAK TO
ABOUT TWO INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN PLACED- THE BOOK ABOUT
PLACEMENTS HAVE BEEN IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR AND WITH
GOVERNMENT COMMISSIONS BUT WITH
OUR NEW RELATIONSHIP WITH
NASDAQ AND WITH THEM- WELL
FIRST OF ALL WITH THE PUSH.
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY THE- BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNING THIS BILL-
WE'RE SEEING MORE MOMENTUM MORE
RELATIONSHIPS AND MORE MOVEMENT
AS A RESULT OF THAT SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE RECENTLY ASKED ABOUT
THE RELATIONSHIP THAT I MENTION
WITH NASDAQ WHICH ALLOWS US TO.
ENGAGE THERE ARE COMPANIES THAT
ARE LISTED ON THE EXCHANGE AND
WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING FOR BOARD
MEMBERS THEY MAY LOOK TO US SO
THAT'S ONE WAY THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO MOVE THAT NUMBER OF
THE CORPORATIONS THAT NUMBER
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD
PLACE CORPORATIONS. BUT THE
THREE HUNDRED THAT YOU
CURRENTLY SEE MOST OF THOSE ON
THE PRINTER I MENTIONED THAT
BUT ARE ACTIVELY ON BOARDS MOST
ARE GOVERNMENT COMMISSIONS AND
MOST ARE IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR WITH A SMALL. SECTION OF
THAT BEING CORPORATIONS. THANK
YOU SENATOR. SEVERAL NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU PERSONAL THANK YOU TO
THE CULTURES AND THANK YOU TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH
HOUSES OF BEING HERE IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU ALL TWO
WEEKS AFTER SESSION ENDED AND
THANK YOU TO THE WONDERFUL
PANELS PANELISTS- THIS IS A
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR. ALL OF
THE PANELISTS WHO ARE AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW AND WHO ARE STILL
WITH US I- I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED YOUR PRESENTATION
AND IT TAKES SOMETIMES THE ACT
OF LEGISLATURE IN ORDER TO PUSH
A CERTAIN- CHANGE IN THE
CULTURE OF THINKING AND ONCE WEDO THAT IT PRECIPITATES AND
OVER TIME WE SEE OTHER STEPS
TAKE THAT TAKE EFFECT SO THAT'S
THAT'S HOPEFULLY WHAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE. WITH THE A MARGINAL
MOVEMENT FROM FROM OUR
INSTITUTION BUT ASKING THIS
BROADLY TO ALL THE PANELISTS
I'M INTERESTED TO KNOW ALSO
WHAT ARE THE ACHIEVABLE N. OF
PROJECTED DESIRES OF WHAT WE
WANT. TO HAVE SOMETHING TO WORK
TOWARDS WHAT IS IT WHAT NUMBERS
DO YOU THINK ABOUT OUR BOTH
ATTAINABLE AND ALSO GOOD GOALS
WHICH MIGHT NOT BE ATTAINED BUT
GOOD GOALS TO SET FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO WANT TO ACHIEVE OUT BY
A CERTAIN TIME LINE SO IF
ANYONE WANTS TO JUMP IN AND-
OFFER SOME THOUGHTS- ESPECIALLY
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR I'D BE
VERY INTERESTED TO HEAR. WHAT
GOALS BY WHAT TIME LINES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK YOU TO
BOTH CHAIRS. I AM HAPPY TO
START WITH SOME OF THE FEEDBACK
TO THE QUESTION. OF FROM A-
PUBLIC COMPANY BOARD DIVERSITY
PERSPECTIVE I HAD REFERENCED
ARE DIVERSE CORPORATE DIRECTORS-
COALITION CALL TO ACTION WHICH
WAS RELEASED TWO YEARS AGO IN
IN THAT DOCUMENT WE THOUGHT-
WHAT WE WOULD ULTIMATELY LIKE
TO SEE IS A BOARD THAT IS AT
LEAST 50% DIVERSE. WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEGISLATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX AND AB NINE
SEVEN NINE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT HELPS PUT SOME FOCUS ON
BOARD DIVERSITY BUT WE HOPE
OVER TIME TO SEE- YOU KNOW UP
250% A DIVERSE BOARD. WE DIDN'T
PUT A TIME FRAME ON IT. AND
WE'VE MADE SOME PROGRESS AND
WE'RE PLEASED WITH THAT BUT WE
REALIZED IT WILL TAKE SOME
TIME. TO MOVE THE NEEDLE TO
THAT 50% GOAL. THANK YOU. HI
THIS IS KATHY MONERO'S WITH THE
LATINO CORPORATE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ARE LATINOS HAVE
THE FURTHEST DISTANCE TO GO
HERE AND WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT THAT THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE SINCE AB NINE SEVEN NINE
WAS PASSED IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE ETERNALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
FOR THAT HI EXISTENCE. BUT EVEN
WITH THE NUMBERS OF INCREASES
THAT WE'RE SEEING WHICH WHICH
ARE ARE ARE VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGES- WE SEE YOU KNOW
TEN YEARS BEFORE WE CAN EVEN
GET TO YOU KNOW 10% OF SEATS IN
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACCELERATE THE PROCESS WHAT
WE'RE DOING- AND I YOU'VE HEARD
A LITTLE BIT FROM THE OTHER
WERE AT THE OTHER SPEAKERS
TODAY OUT WE WERE DOING VERY
MUCH THE SAME THING WE HAVE
REACHED OUT TO EVERY CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COMPANY. AND WE'VE
WRITTEN THEM ALL- IT IT'S AND
WE HAVE A FORMULA BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE WRITING TO
EVERY FORTUNE ONE THOUSAND
COMPANY AND THAT WE ARE WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THESE MEASURES-
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF AB NINE
SEVEN NOT FIND OUT WHAT WELL
INTRODUCED OUR OUR POOL OF
TALENT TO CORPORATION COMPANY
BECAUSE OF CROSS COUNTRY BUT WE
DO SEE VERY SLOW SLOW PROGRESS
RIGHT NOW. OKAY IF I IF I COULD
I AND MY APOLOGIES- BUT AS WE
SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
YEAR AND WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
TWO O'CLOCK AND WE WANTED TO
TRY TO GET AS MUCH AS WE COULD
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION ON THIS
LAST PANEL SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO MOVE IF WE COULD TO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I'LL HAND IT
OVER TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. YES I KNOW WE WILL OPEN
THE PHONE LINES AND OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE AUDIENCE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THE
COMMON WILL BE LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES PER PERSON. IF YOU ARE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM YOU MUST
WEAR YOUR MASK AT ALL TIMES. IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT BY PHONE. PLEASE CALL
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE.
ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO. ZERO TWO.
THE NUMBERS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND ALSO
APPEARS. ON THE VIDEO FEED. WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM.
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE
PLEASE. CAN I TAKE OUT MY FACE
MASSIVE SPACEFLIGHT. THERE'S
SOME ADDRESSING THIS IS MY
FIRST. PLEASE ON MASS YOU KNOW
LET ME JUST TELL YOU I DON'T
THINK IT'S ON EXCUSE ME YOU
KNOW WELL WE'RE NOT GOING TO
FIRST OF ALL BEFORE YOU SPEAK
AND I'M NOT YOU HAVE YOUR TIME
TO SPEAK WITH THE PERSON I
DON'T KNOW WHO YOU ARE. BUT.
WELL THIS IS NOT A- YOU KNOW
WHAT. WE WERE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE
ABANDONED YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO. YOU HAD
IT YOU NOW HAVE WITH THE PERSON
THE PERSON WHO'S AT THE MIKE
YOU CAN COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS.
YOU DO NOT WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. NO. OKAY ONE MORE
WORD AND YOU'RE OUT OF THE OUT
OF THE ROOM OKAY I'M GOING TO
ADDRESS THE CHURCH- MEMBERS
HERE. OKAY- I'M SORRY WELL MY
MINISTER NOW SO- ADDRESSING THE
TERM MEMBERS HERE SORRY I DON'T
KNOW ALL THEIR NAMES BUT MY
NAME ASSURING A LATCH. AND I'M
HERE TODAY- TO SPEAK ON THIS
TOPIC WHICH I'VE BEEN A BORN
REYES CALIFORNIANS OKAY LITTER
ALL OF MY LIFE. AND I HAVE
LIVED IN VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU MY LOOK
AT ME AND THINK OH SHE'S
CAUCASIAN. BUT GUESS WHAT. I
MIXED- YES INDONESIA AND DIDN'T.
CAREER CAREER INDIA AND RISKY
CONCRETE NATIVE AND CHEROKEE
OKAY RUNS IN MY BLOOD. I'M ALSO-
PORTUGUESE MASO EUROPEAN. I'VE
NEVER IN MY LIFE. WITH FORTY
FOUR YEARS. I HAVE SEEN. MAR
RACE MY CLIENT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ANY OF YOU. NONE OF YOU.
AND I'VE LIVED IN MANY
DIFFERENT PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
OKAY VERY CONCERNED HOW THIS IS
GOING BECAUSE NOT ONE OF YOU.
HAS MENTIONED BY ETHNIC GROUP.
NOT WHAT. SO ARE THESE ARE
THESE BONDS JUST GOING. TO ALL
OF YOU. ARE YOU GOING TO CAST
US ASIDE. BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
OF MY SKIN. THIS IS A QUESTION.
YOUR QUESTION. WE TALK ABOUT.
WE TALK ABOUT. WE ARE BEING
FAIR RIGHT THE QUALITY EQUITY.
OKAY. BUT WHERE YOU'RE LEAVING
OUT. IS THE REST OF US. AS YOU
PURSUE THIS IT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN SEGREGATION.
OKAY I DON'T BELIEVE. AND THE
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW OUR
DISCRIMINATE IS HER NAME GETS
ANYBODY. I WANT TO QUALITY FOR
EVERYONE SURE I DO. BUT THIS.
RACES AGAINST EACH OTHER NEEDS
TO STOP AND STOP. YES I STAND
HERE TODAY I'M ANGRY I'M ANGRY
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU THINK I'VE
HAD IT EASY. I HAVE A MENTAL
CONDITION I'VE CALL I ACTUALLY
CALLED SPINAL STENOSIS
ARTHRITIS IN MY SPINE OKAY I'M
HERE ODAY I'M IN PAIN AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK UP AGAINST
THIS. WHILE YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT YOUR FUNDING AND ALL WE
HAVE TO HAVE ALL THESE
COMMITTEES. WHY NOT FIX THE
COMMITTEES THAT WE'VE ALREADY
HAD. WHY NOT ADD AND THE ENGINE
PLEASE ALL RIGHT THAT WE'RE
APPROACHING TWO MINUTES MORE
DIVERSITY THAT FROM EVERYBODY.
REPORTS ON THIS PANEL. I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT ARE YOU. OKAY
WHERE IS THE ORDER. WHAT IS IT.
ONE OF THE. OKAY TIME IS
EXPIRED. ALL RIGHT WELL I HOPE
YOU LISTEN TO THIS. OKAY
BECAUSE I AM TIRED OF THIS BEEN
A BACK AND FORTH I WORK FOR A
HOSPITAL LAB FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. AND WE HAD MORE PEOPLE I
OF DIVERSE CITY IN NOT IN THOSE
HOSPITALS THEN THERE WERE A
COLLOCATION PEOPLE- YEAH THANK
YOU CHECK OUT CALIFORNIA. WE
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA OVER ON.
PLEASE REMOVE HER NOW SHE'S
BEEN WARNED. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE TELEPHONE OPERATOR. THANK
YOU TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT OVER
THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE HUNDRED ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR THAT FIRST COMMENT.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE. WE DO HAVE THREE LINES IN
Q. WE CAN. BUT WE CAN GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR COMP.
SURE CHAIRED GARCIA AND HOLDING
MY NAME IS WHAT YOU WANTED
SELECT ON BEHALF OF THE NEW
AMERICA ALLIANCE A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF LATINO LATINO
AND DIVERSE INVESTMENT MANAGER
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING.
IN THE WORLD THE BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP FEW THINGS ARE
MORE DETERMINATE OF YOUR
ABILITY TO SIXTEENTH AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF INVESTMENT
CAPITAL IF THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE BUSINESS THAT GROWS
TO BECOME THE NEXT TESLA
FACEBOOK OR GOOGLE. AND THOSE
COMPANIES THAT START SMALL AND
STAY SMALL BECAUSE THEY LACKED
ACCESS TO THE CAPITAL THEY NEED
TO GROW BUT THE HARD TRUTH IS
THAT FOR WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR ACCESSING THE
CAPITAL THEIR COMPANIES NEED TO
FLOURISH AND GROW. IT DIFFICULT
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO DATE ONLY
1% OF VENTURE CAPITAL BACKED
FOUNDERS ARE BLACK AND LIKELY
2% OR LATIN ACT. WOMAN FOUNDERS
IN A COUNTRY WHERE WOMEN MAKE
UP A MAJORITY OF THE POPULATION
RECEIVED A DISMAL TWO POINT 7%
OF VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDING AND
DESPITE BECOMING AN
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE NATION
WOMEN OF COLOR FOUNDERS
RECEIVED LESS THAN 1% POINT 64%
TO BE EXACT. OF VENTURE FUNDING
DISPARITY A SYSTEMIC BUT NOT
SURPRISING WHEN ONLY ONE POINT
3% OF THE SIXTY NINE TRILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT
INDUSTRY THEM TRUSTED TWENTY
BEST KNOWN FIRMS OWNED BY WOMEN
OR MINORITIES. AS THE COMMITTEE
CONTINUES ITS IMPORTANT WORK WE
URGE YOU TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
THE DISPARITIES IN WHO MANAGES
THE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
RIGHT BUSINESS GROW. BECAUSE
THE LACK OF CORPORATE BOARD
DIVERSITY DIVERSITY IS
INEXTRICABLY LINKED TO THE LACK
OF DIVERSITY IN THE FIRMS THAT
INVEST IN THESE COMPANIES AT
THE ARE GETTING STARTED AND GO
ON TO BECOME A MAJOR
CORPORATION IN CLOSING I WANT
TO COMMEND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING AB
EIGHT NINETY A MEASURE THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO REQUIRE.
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO REPORT
ANNUALLY TO THE LEGISLATOR
UNDER UTILIZATION OF DIVERSE
INVEST MANAGERS TO INVEST THE
WALL OVER SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS THAT THESE
FUNDS HAVE. I THANK YOU AGAIN
PRETTY IMPORTANT. DISCUSSION
AND APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
COMING. NEXT OF. COMMON PLEAS
PUBLIC. THE LION AT NINETY ONE
NINE PLEASE GO. OKAY CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES OKAY GREAT. YOU
MAY PROCEED. I DO APOLOGIZE ONE
MOMENT. WE'LL GO BACK LINE
NINETEEN IF WE HAVE TIME LINE
TWENTY ONE. ANYONE YOU ONE OF
THE- OKAY THANK YOU THINK AYE
SAMMY OKAY YES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CULTURE GARCIA CO CHAIR HOLDEN
AND IF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WELCOMING
CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA MY NAME IS TASHA
HENNEMAN AND I SERVICE CHIEF OF
POLICY AND GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR PRC AND I ALSO DIRECT THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WHICH
WAS FOUNDED BY PIERRE ETHIO
FRED ANDREWS. AND ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WE
ARE A COLLECTION OF CALIFORNIA
LEADERS FROM VARIED SECTORS
THAT SEEK. TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS OF BLACK IN MARKHAM.
HELLO YES. IT CONTINUE WITH THE
I HEARD IN THAT- RECORDING THE
HISTORY OF OUR NATION IS
PLAGUED WITH DECADES OF RACIAL
INEQUALITY AND DISCRIMINATION
AND REFINEMENTS MANIFESTED IN
ALL ASPECTS OF OUR SOCIETY AND
SYSTEMIC REFORMS THAT YOU'RE
SUCH AS THIS ONE SUCH AS.
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN NINE. I
NEEDED OVERCOME HISTORIC
INEQUALITIES AND APPEAR THE L.
B. THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
PRAISES THE INTENT THAT THEY BE.
NINE SEVEN NINE TOOK KNOWLEDGE
DIVERSITY AND INSURANCE. I
THINK PATIENT FROM UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AS BUT
PARTLY MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY
RESEARCH OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTS THAT BOARD DIVERSITY
IMPROVES OVERALL BOARD
PERFORMANCE RESULTS IN EMPLOYEE
HIGHER JOB SATISFACTION AND IT
FOSTERS AN OVERALL
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE OF
INCLUSIVITY WITH. LESS GROUP
THINK- AND THINGS THAT DIVERT
FOCUS FROM THE MISSION OF THE
ORGANIZATION I DIVERSITY IS SO
MUCH MORE THAN JUST CHECKING A
BOX IT'S ABOUT HAVING A BROAD
RANGE OF EXPERIENCES PRIORITIES
AND PERSPECTIVES THAT REFLECT
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
ULTIMATELY LEADING TO BETTER
PERFORMING COMPANIES. AND A
CULTURE GARCIA STATED IN HER
OPENING REMARKS UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES DESERVE
TO BE VISIBLE AND TO HAVE A
VOICE THAT THESE DECISION
MAKING TABLES WE LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN ANY WAY ON.
SUPPORTING DEVELOPING
RECOMMENDATIONS OR ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP SPREAD
THE WORD- AND REALLY SEEK
EQUITY AND PARITY ACROSS ALL
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND YOUR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
AND THANK YOU FOR THE HASH TAG
WE WILL SHARE THEM ON OUR
SOCIAL CHANNELS AND TWEET OUT-
HASHTAG. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
OPERATOR THAT WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE. THANK YOU WILL WE WILL GO
BACK TO LINE NINETEEN LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE START AGAIN.
START AGAIN DID YOU HEAR
ANYTHING I SAID. NO SIR PLEASE
BEGIN FROM THE BEGINNING. YOU
DID NOT HEAR ANY OF THAT. OKAY
LET ME SEE IF I CAN REPHRASE
THIS OR PUT IT IN THE SAME TAX.
CONTACT. WOW THAT WAS THAT I'M
TRYING TO GET MYSELF BACK
TOGETHER BECAUSE I HAD ALREADY
GOTTEN THROUGH THIS WHOLE
THING- CAN YOU HEAR ME STILL.
YES YOU CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT DIVERSITY
AND YOU CLAIMING DIVERSITY NEED
TO BEGIN GO THROUGH A PIPELINE.
A PIPELINE CREATES A NARROW
POINT. AND EVERYONE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THAT EXACT SAME SPOT
PROCESS A PIPELINE LEAD YOU IN
ONE DIRECTION THAT WOULD
MERRILEES YOUR POINT OF VIEW
YOU CAN'T LOOK AROUND AND SEE
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE PIPELINE
THAT THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE. OF CONCERN FOR INSTANCE
I'M A MUSICIAN. RIGHT I PLAY
WITH MUSICIANS WHO WANT TO PLAY
WITH ME. I WRITE SONGS I HAVE
CONCERT. EIGHTY FIVE WAITED SO
I HAD TO GET THEM INSURANCE I
CAN'T AFFORD THAT SO YOU JUST
TOOK ME RIGHT OUT OF MY ABILITY
TO DO MY JOB. JUST LIKE YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO TO ALL THESE OTHER
PEOPLE IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND YOU
GOT TO TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY.
THERE'S A BIG BIG GROUP. FOR
RIGHT NOW BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST IN THE STATE. WITH THE
STATE MANDATE. ALL THESE NURSES
AND I KNOW QUITE A FEW WHO
DON'T WANT TO GET THE SHOT. ARE
NOW TERRIFIED BY THE STATE
MANDATING THIS STUFF UPON THEM
WHEN THEY HAVE. THE DAMAGE THAT
THEY SHOT DOES TO PEOPLE AND
YOU'RE TELLING THEM YOU MUST
GET THIS OR BE TESTED WELL
THOSE TANKS. WHAT ESTO OXIDE ON
IT THAT'S NOT EXACTLY. THE CARD
IS GIPSON GONNA BE HAPPY PEOPLE
TO BE TESTED VERY LOW THE THING.
AND YOUR TELLING US THE BETTER
THIS IS NOT A DIVERSE BUSINESS
A DIVERSE GROUP TO WHO IS BEING
SEGREGATED AND DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST CURRENTLY IN THIS VERY
MOMENT. IN THIS VERY MOMENT IN
THE STATE I BELIEVE THAT TODAY
WAS THE DAY THAT THE NURSES
WERE BEING FIRED. FOR NOT.
AGREEING TO A STATE AND THEN
THE POLICE THAT FROM THE MOVIE.
YOU. LOOK LIKE YOU. YOUR HONOR.
THESE GUYS ARE BE FIVE BECAUSE
OF YOU. AND YOUR IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT DIVERSITY IS. WE HAVE
RIGHT. WE DON'T NEED YOUR
PRIVILEGES WE HAVE RIGHTS IN
THIS COUNTRY LIFE LIBERTY AND
THE PURSUIT OF PROPERTY YOU'RE
GETTING IN THE WAY OF PEOPLE
PURSUING THOSE DREAMS AND I'M
GOING TO CONSIDER- OUR TWO
MINUTE DON'T WANT ENOUGH. OKAY
I'M DONE. THANK BANKS WERE UP.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WITHOUT THE
LAST COMMENT. BRACKNELL OTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN TO CLOSE UP TODAY'S
SESSION I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
OUR. OKAY AS WE GET A CHECK UP
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS OUTSIDE
WAITING TO SPEAK. OKAY SORRY
THERE'S A TO PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
WAITING I DON'T ATTEND A
MICROPHONE TO SPEAK IF THEY
COULD PLEASE. COME FORWARD ONE
AT A TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
IF YOU ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
PUBLIC MICROPHONE AND YOU ARE
WISHING TO SKIFF PUBLIC COMMENT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE. STEP
FORWARD AND GIVE YOU A COUPLE
MORE SECONDS. OKAY THANK YOU
SEE NO ONE HAS COME FORWARD
WILL MOVE ON- WE WILL NOW GO
AHEAD AND NOW DO OUR CLOSING
COMMENTS THIS WRAPS UP PUBLIC
COMMENTS. WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE TO THE
AND EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
FOLLOWING TODAY'S HEARING- TO
DISCUSS DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY ON
CORPORATE BOARDS IN OUR WORK
FORCE. OUT THERE. I THERE'S A
LOT TO REFLECT IN TWO DAYS-
PANELISTS HAVE PROVIDED A
WEALTH OF INFORMATION FOR US TO
MOVE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. ONE
OF. A COUPLE REMINDERS SB EIGHT
TO SIX AND A. B. NINE SEVEN
NINE WHICH IS THE BEGINNING OF
THE DISCUSSION AND SHOULD BE
SEEN AS A FLOOR. AND NOT- THE
CEILING OF WHERE WE NEED TO BE
GOING AS THE ONLY SET THE
MINIMUMS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY REFLECTIVE OF THE
TOTAL INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY.
THAT IS WITHIN OUR STATE. IT
WAS CALAVERAS APPLY IS NOT THE
ISSUE. AND SO I WANT TO END
THIS BY. DOING MY OWN CALL OF
ACTION TO COMPANIES OUT THERE
YOU DO NOT NEED TO WAIT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS ANY BILLS.
OR TO HAVE ANY MORE HEARINGS
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE AND
THERE IS AN URGENCY IN THE PACE
MUST BE ACCELERATED. ONE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SHARE THAT
WERE CITY PLANS AND MAKE THEM
PUBLIC. I OUT THERE INTO ALSO
THIS AGGREGATE THE DATA AS OUR
PANELISTS HAVE SO ELOQUENTLY
STATED AS PART OF THE SOLUTION
OUT THERE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED WORK AND I DO
WANT TO THANK- THE STAFF AS
WELL WHO HAS WORKED TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER- TO DATE. WITH THAT I
WILL HAND IT OVER TO MY-
CULTURE. MR HOLDEN. OKAY YOU I
JUST LIKE TO VERY QUICKLY
THANK. MY COACH HERE CRISTINA
GARCIA. AND DAVID CHIU AS A
JOINT JOINT AUTHOR AND ELOISE
REST. OF THIS IS OBVIOUSLY BEEN
NINE SEVEN NINE HAS BEEN- WHAT
WE HAD HOPED IT WOULD BE. OF A
BILL THAT WOULD CAUSE THERE TO
BE MORE CAUGHT CONVERSATION
AROUND. INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY
IN THE WORKPLACE AND IN THE
CORPORATE BOARDROOM. I WANT TO
THANK THE PANELISTS TODAY I
THINK THEY DID AN OUTSTANDING
JOB. OF THEY BROUGHT. OF OUR
GREAT INSIDE AND ABREAST. OF
CLARITY. AROUND SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
ASKING QUESTIONS AROUND. AND SO
I THINK THEM FOR BEING A PART
OF THAT AND- MAKING THIS A
VERY. INFORMATIVE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING- I ALSO LIKE TO THANK.
OUR STAFFS BECAUSE THEY- WORK
VERY HARD LINDA RIOS AND- MY
OFFICE AND TIFFANY. RYAN AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S OFFICE.
FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
FINDING THE PANELISTS. SAID IN
THE PROGRAM STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
AND CLEARLY WAS VERY ROBUST AND
A LOT OF INFORMATION TO COVER
AND SO. WE TRY TO DO THAT- IN A
RESPECTFUL WAY OF GIVING. ALL
OF MEMBERS OF THE PANEL OF
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND. ON THEIR
THOUGHTS- AS I CLOSE I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT. I. AM
DISAPPOINTED AND- THOSE WHO
SHOW UP WITH A DIFFERENT KIND
OF AGENDA. AND THIS IS THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. BUT WE TRY TO
STAY ON TOPIC ON THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND-
AND TO HAVE DECORUM IN DOING SO
AND THAT WAS VIOLATED AT THE
END OF THIS MEETING. AND I'M
DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE IT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THAT BE WHAT MARS WHAT I HOPE.
MOST WILL SEE IS A VERY
PRODUCTIVE AND APPROPRIATE
HEARING- SO WITH THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
TO KEEP. THESE ISSUES GOING AND
CONVERSATION HAPPENING OF THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THEM.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE PROGRESS OF HOW THE COMPANY
IN CALIFORNIA. ARE WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT OF THE OUTLINES OF
THE TWO BILLS THERE WERE
SUBJECTS OF CONVERSATION TODAY.
AND WITH THAT HAVING NOTHING
ELSE TO SAY. MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.